ARE GOING TO BEGIN IN A MOMENT
AS A SUB COMMITTEE- IF THERE
ARE ANY SENATORS THEY'RE
LISTENING WERE VERY CLOSE TO A
QUORUM WE WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO
COME TO THE ROOM AND ESTABLISH
A QUORUM- JUST. FOR THE RECORD
THE BEGINNING WE HAVE NINE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FILE
ITEM ONE S. B. TWENTY FIVE HAS
BEEN PULLED AND ONE BUILT THIS
ON CONSENT TO FIGHT HIM NINE.
OF THE SERVER IT JUST TORE UP
GO THROUGH THE PARTICULARS OF
OUR HEARING- IN RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST- LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SHOULD
HEAR TO SOCIAL DESTROYING
DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY FOR OUR MEMBER
SENATOR LEE MOMENT SO LET ME
JUST RECOGNIZE SENATOR LEE MON
AND ASK FOR- TWO DEAD YOURSELF
AND HER STAFF PERSON SHE HAS
WITH HER IN HER LOCATION. THANK
YOU CHAIR SENATOR LEE MALONE%
AND I HAVE YET NAY LOCUSTS AND
MY DISTRICT OFFICE IN SANTA
BARBARA. PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU HERE WITH US TODAY. AND
SENATORS AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK BY ACID EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED HE USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE THE
PROGRAM. AND EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
POLICE SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
BUTTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATEYOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. A REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THAN WE HAVE IN
ADDITION TO THIS HEARING ROOM
OR SITTING IN ON THE FOURTH
FLOOR WE HAVE ROM TWENTY
FORTY. AND FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT'LL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW- TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE OH SIX FOUR
ZERO EIGHT TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARX
REFERRED TO THE SENATE OR THIS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIE ONE DAY ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WHITE ONCE YOU RECEIVE- YOUR
LONG NUMBER YOUR WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS TO COMMITTEE
AND EVEN THOUGH YOU'LL BE ON
MUTED YOU SHOULD MAKE SURE YOUR
ON MUTE IT BECAUSE WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME WAITING FOR PEOPLE
TO SO JUST TO A POINT YOU'RE A
MUTED BY THE- BOB. AND NOW FOR
AN EMPLOYEE ANNOUNCEMENT ON THE
PROCESS WE WILL BE ALLOWING
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO EACH BILL W. UP
OPENING THREE MINUTES EACH SIDE
SO THE LEAD PEOPLE CAN DO THREE
MINUTES AND THEN FIFTEEN
MINUTES TOTAL. AND WHEN WE GET
TO THE FIFTEEN MINUTES IT'S
JUST WHAT WE CALL A ME TOO YOU
JUST SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL ANY
SPEECHES WILL BE CUT OFF
BECAUSE ANYBODY THAT SPEAKS
LONGER THAN THAT BRIEFLY WILL
CUT OFF THE ABILITY FOR MORE
PEOPLE TO WEIGH IN WITH THEIR
POSITION. AND PLEASE NOTE THAT
YOU IF YOU'RE IN THAT SITUATION
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING ON THE HEARING PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. I WILL MAIN MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEED.
WHILE EVERY HAVE HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. AND
PATIENT. WE WERE GOING TO OPEN
THIS HEARING WITH AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON AN
UPDATE ON STATE OIL AND GAS
REGULATION WITH US SECRETARY OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY A
VERY IMPORTANT POSITION. OF
THIS PERSON WHITE CROW FOOT TO
THE PROVIDE THE UPDATE. WE HAVE
SECRETARY CROWFOOT TO ADDRESS A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS WHICH- I
SHOULD BE IN THE MENTORS
BINDERS INTERVALE THE PUBLIC
FROM THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE WE'VE
LEARNED THAT SECRETARY CROWFOOT
WOULD BE UNABLE TO JOIN THIS
MORNING- AND SO. I SHOULD OR
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
FIRST I MINIMUM AND LET ME JUST
REMIND OF SINCE ARCH REMOTE
I'VE BEEN A TO CHECK THE
HEARING TODAY SO I WILL BE
CHAIRING THE HEARING TODAY. AND
TO REPEAT WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA FILE ITEM ONE SB
TWENTY FIVE HAS BEEN PULLED ONE
BILL WAS ON CONSENT FILE ITEM
NINE ENTER WITH FAT- WE WILL
MOVE TO THE FIRST BILL OUR ARMS
TO HEAR WHICH IN IN OUR GENDER
IS LISTED IS FILE ITEM TWO SB
FORTY SEVEN SENATOR DAMONE- AND
HEART WOULD WELCOME LIMóN TO
THE COMMITTEE AND GIVE YOU THE-
OPPORTUNITY 2% THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SB FORTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES THE SERIOUS PROBLEM
OF DESERTED WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
IT HAS BEEN ESTIMATED THAT
CALIFORNIA HASN'T A LIABILITY
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION AND FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS. DESERTED
WELLS ARE A FINANCIAL LIABILITY
AT THE STATE AND DANGEROUS TO
THE SURROUNDING ENVIRONMENT AND
RESIDENTS THE WELLS CAN LEAK.
DEGRADING AIR QUALITY AND
CONTAMINATING AQUIFERS HARMING
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. AND
MY DISTRICT WE HAVE SEEN THE
REAL IMPACT OF THE OIL
COMPANIES GOING BANKRUPT AND
LEAVING TAXPAYERS TO PAY THE
PRICE OF CLEANING UP AGING OIL
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS ESSENTIAL
FOR THE STATE TO HAVE THE FUNDS
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM YOUR
SUPPORT MA'AM. THE BILL
INCREASES THE ANNUAL AMOUNT CAL
CHEN CAN SPEND TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND ALLOWS CAL
CHEN SAVE UP TO A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER DECADES
FOR FUTURE. PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING WORK. IN THIS
ALLOCATE. IS THE SOUND OF TO GO
BACK TO ONE DOLLARS A YEAR.
USING MUST READ TWENTY NINETEEN
IDLE REPORT IT COULD TAKE CAL
GEM OVER BY HUNDRED YEARS TO
CLEAN UP THE WELLS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED LIKELY DESERTED. I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION ON THIS
ISSUE AND REMAIN COMMITTED TO
FINDING A SOLUTION THAT
ADDRESSES SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
TAXPAYERS. TODAY WIKI- WITH ME
IN SUPPORT IS LAUREN CALLING
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB AND
ELIZABETH ESPINO SEVER
PRESENTING. HOW JUST AND THE OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE WE OF
AND- IT WILL JOINED IN BOTH K.
ON CO HOST PHONE LAW. THE FIRST
ONE IS MORE AND CALL FROM THE
SHERIFF THE SECOND ONE IS A
LIST S. FROM COUNTY AND YOU
HAVE A TOTAL THREE BETWEEN YOU
SO JUST LETTING YOU KNOW SO
THAT IF ONE OF YOU USES THREE
MINUTES YOU CUT OFF THE OTHER
ONE SO. AS BEST AS POSSIBLE BE
DISCIPLINED TO USE THE TIME
BETWEEN USER WILL BEGIN WITH
WARRANT COLUMN WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALARMCOM BEHALF OF YOUR
COOKING. REPRESENT HAPPEN
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS ACROSS
THE STATE. OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT AS FORTY FIVE BECAUSE
OF HELP YOU FUND FOR CALL
ABANDONED VERY WELL CALIFORNIA.
STATE OF THE MATH OF AN EXTRA I
DON'T. OIL WEALTH. WITH THE
BOTTOM IN THE CAR MORE ON ARE
ANY NUMBER. TO KEEP THE ON THE
DATA WHILE. THE TECHNOLOGY
REPORT ESTIMATED TO COST ABOUT
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS TO REMEDIATE ALL IDLE
ECONOMICALLY MARGINAL AND THE
BIRD WELL. OR HELP ON THE
ENVIRONMENT IT CAN LEAK THE
GREAT AIR QUALITY CONTAINING
AWKWARD AND DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES CREATING OILSEEDS AND
HARMING NEARBY COMMUNITY PLUGIN
ABANDONED WELL THE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
FORTY WILL HAVE A WITH ROYAL UP
BY ALL CAL INDEPENDENT TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON
PARKING BAND OIL WELL. ALLOWING
TO USE MORE FUNDS IN ORDER TO
DO THE PROJECT WHILE ENSURING
ACOSTA NOT PASS LONGER. SB
FORTY SEVEN IN IMPORTANT AND
URGENT GOAL TO HELP ADDRESS THE
STATE I WAS VERY OIL WEALTH
PROBLEM WE THANK CENTER MOST
OVER READERSHIP AND WE URGE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO VOTE AYE
ON AT THE FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA. YES GOOD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSUS
ELIZABETH ASKING US ON BEHALF
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR LEE MONTHS SB FORTY
SEVEN. THE RECORD IS CLEAR ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS
ASSOCIATED WITH DESERTED WEALTH
AS WELL AS THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM. THE COUNTY VENTURA
THEREFORE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
DESERTED OR POTENTIALLY
DESERTED WELLS INCLUDING JUST
OVER FORTY BETTER OFF SHORE.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
CLEAR POLICY SUPPORT. CLEAR
POLICY TO SUPPORT LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS THAT PROMOTE DEVELOPING
A CLEAR PLAN TIMELINE AND
FUNDING MECHANISM. TO
ADEQUATELY ASSURE THE
RECLAMATION OF ALL OIL SITES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS BILL
CLEARLY ALIGNS WITH THE BOARD'S
POLICY ENVISIONED FOR
PRIORITIZING THE PLUGGING OF
DESERTED WELLS. ABSENT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE CAP ON
CAL JOBS EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
WOULD DROP TO A MILLION
DOLLARS. IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE WHEN IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE AGGREGATE STATEWIDE
PROBLEMS. IN FACT THE MAN'S A
SOLUTION AND THE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH CONTENT
POTENTIAL LEAKS. AND RESULTING
CONTAMINATION ARE TOO GREAT A
THREAT TO LEAVE THIS PROBLEM
AND ADDRESSED. AND FOR THESE
REASONS THE COUNTY CENTER IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND- HE IN A- WE'RE
GOING GO TO THE- TELECONFERENCE
LINE FOR SUPPORT. BUT INCLUDING
SENATOR LEE MON WE HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW. AND SO I WAS
GOING TO ASK THE- COMMITTEE
BLARED HERE HERE JONES JONES
HERE ALLEN EGGMAN GROVE HERE
GROW HERE HERTZBERG HUESO HERE
HUESO HERE LONG. AND I REALLY
ONE HERE MON HERE'S STERN.
STERN HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED QUORUM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M GETTING
WORD FROM ALL SIDES THAT OUR
CONFERENCE LINE IS FULL. SO YOU
WE WILL DO OUR BEST HERE WE ARE
GOING TO NOW MOVES. TO THE CAR-
TO THOSE THAT WISH TO DO A ME
TOO OR JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WISHES TO
DO THAT. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT WISHES
TO DO THAT. SEEING NO ONE OUR
MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE AND THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY. TO
GIVE A- A ME TOO IN SUPPORT
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
AND WE HAVE A MAXIMUM OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR THIS
ALTHOUGH IT DOESN'T HAVE TO GO
THE FULL FIFTEEN MINUTES SO
MODERATOR. OF PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY SEVEN PEOPLE WENT
WHEN YOU'RE ASKED TO DIAL IN
THIS IS SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN
WE MOAN MODERATOR. THANK YOU
CHAIRPERSON IF YOU WISH TO BE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. FOR
PERSONAL COMPLY NUMBER SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
SIXTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. I AM
ACTUALLY HOLDING UP ON A BILL
LATER IN THE CALENDAR. OKAY
ANYBODY ELSE FOUR S. B. FORTY
SEVEN. IF I HAD MADE SURE I'
THIS IS LAURIE CALLING WITH
YOUR CLUB I'M ON THE I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO THE ONE ZERO BUT
I'D LIKE TO REGISTER BEFORE FOR
SOME FOLKS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO CALL AND- NOT OKAY. I
GUESS SOME. GO FOR. JUST
BECAUSE THE COMPANY WONDERFUL
I'D LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR SB FORTY SEVEN FOR NOW TO
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. USA
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
CLEAN WATER ACTION CALIFORNIA
COASTAL PROTECTION NETWORK
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA. JUSTICE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY- AND BOB ABOUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- THANK YOU FOR
BEING EFFICIENT- SO ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE LINE
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT FOR S. B.
FORTY SEVEN. YES WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILLIAMS
CHAIRPERSON ARE NO OTHERS AND
SHE IS WHAT. LET'S MOVE TO THE
NEXT ONE HUNDRED OR AND LET ME
JUST REMIND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DONE BUTTE YOURSELF NOT JUST BE
ON MUTED BY THE MODERATORS SO
MODERATE OR ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FORTY SEVEN.
AND AS A REMINDER LAYS JUNKIES
PRESS ONE YOUR WHAT. TWENTY
FIVE. MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE
HAVE NO ONE TO LOOK ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FOR. I'M SORRY I
COULDN'T HEAR WHAT YOU JUST
SAID MODERATOR. MY APOLOGIES
JEFFERSON ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GET THE NEXT PARTY OKAY.
BECAUSE YOU'RE- WORTH THE FIRST
WERE. SIXTY SEVEN. ME JUST ONE
MOMENT. OR. YOUR BIRTH. ONE
FOUR ONE. AND IF YOU ARE A USER
OF. YEAH WELL- ALL. COLLEGES
SHIPPERS TO BE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT. THE ONLY HAPPENS ON HIS.
GOING ON. SEVEN TROUBLING
PEOPLE. AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MERCEDES
LYSIAS KERN COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT PERSON. WORKING AT THE
TIME I SHOW NO WATERS ACUTE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
JUST FOR EVERYBODY THEY HAVE
OPEN SOME MORE LINE SO THEY'RE
TRYING TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OPPOSITION FOUR SB FORTY
SEVEN TO LEAD OPPOSITION IS
STILL POTHOLES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION MISSED POWERHOUSE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
APPEAL FAILS REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. OF
TWENTY SEVEN IT'S NOT THAT WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT LIABILITY
FOR ORCHARD WELLS IS NOT A REAL
PROBLEM IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE AN OPEN DEBATE.
REPORT FOR YEARS NOW ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE AND CAL GEM QUALITY
ISSUE. THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
THE FORTY SEVEN IT'S ABOUT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE VAST AMOUNT
OF LAW MAKING AND POLICY MAKING
THAT'S HAPPENED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. CURRENTLY THERE'S A
THREE MILLION DOLLAR OR FROM
WELL ACCOUNT. NOT COLLECTED THE
MONEY FROM THE INDUSTRY THAT IS
NOT SPENT. THE ENTIRE GALA
COULD NOT STAND EACH YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE UP TO
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
HEAD WHILE FUND. WHICH IS ALSO
FINANCED BY FEES. IDLE DEVOTED
WELL. THAT MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THE SUBJECT. OF A BILL IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY. IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
CENTER ON BAIL. TEN FIFTY FROM
LAST YEAR INCREASED BY
LIABILITY FOR ALL WELLS BY
OPERATORS OF A MAXIMUM OF
FIFTEEN MILLION TO A MAXIMUM OF
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE BILL ALSO CONTEMPLATES THE
GEOMETRICALLY INCREASED AMOUNT
IN ON ALL QUALIFY. WHAT WE'VE
DONE SO MUCH TO MY NEEDS AREN'T
BEING USED ALREADY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SELECT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR BALANCE OUT OF IT HAD
LOST FONG BECAUSE CAL CHEN WAS
NOT EXTENDED NOTES FARMS.
ABANDONED WELL. WE NEED TO LET
THE WORLD. AT ALL IN PLACE WORK
GO AHEAD AND EXPAND YEAR
DURATION OF THE CURRENT FORM
WELL DEFINED WHAT MAY BE A
MARGINAL INCREASE OF THAT
BALANCE BUT FOR NOW BOTH MONEY
JUST SIMPLY WILL NOT BE SPENT
BY CALTRANS. UNTIL THAT PROCESS
STRAIGHTENS ITSELF OUT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL AND TIMELY
AND. FOR THOSE REASONS OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- OF. WAS THE
ONE AND DONE A FIRED LEAD
OPPOSITION WE WILL MOVE TO- THE
OPPOSING ME TOOS. AND ARE WE
HAVE UP TO FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
THIS AND WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH THIS HEARING ROOM SO SURE
ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO OPPOSE
HERE IN THIS HEARING. PLEASE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE YOURSELF BUT
WHAT ARE GET READY FOR THIS
MICROPHONE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL INSTANCES EACH
ELECTRICAL WORKERS FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR PASS.
WE'RE OPPOSED TO IT SB FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST REPRESENTING
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
BUT IT'S CURTIS DAY A MEMBER OF
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
LOCAL TWELVE I STAND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT. SIX SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD SHALLOWLY LAVERY WITH THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
STANDING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT.
WHERE MEMBERS ARE MANY MAJOR
PROBLEMS REPRESENTING
CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE FIFTY TWO
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND- WE
ARE AGAINST THE BILL ALSO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT. RON RELAT
REPRESENTING THIS SOLANO COUNTY
CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTY WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AMOS TOM MAIDEN FROM THE
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS ARGUE
BILL CHAN WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MORE
MATURE CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IT'S- EXCUSE ME OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN JOHN
TWEED DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
GROUP GLAZERS LOCAL SEVEN SIX
SEVEN. WE STAND IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOUVERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S RANDALL NOON
DISCALCED SIXTEEN PRINTERS
ALLEY TRADE LOCAL FORTY SEVEN
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM. THEN
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE I'VE
BEEN SHARING HEARING THERE
SOMEBODY IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
SO WOULD PEOPLE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- SOCIALLY DISTANCE
YOURSELF AND STEP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND OFFER YOUR
POSITION. WHY IT MATTERS
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
AND I STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPECIAL BUCKLE IRONWORKERS
LOCAL EIGHTEEN WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BY MICHAEL
DREILING ESTIMATE TO TRADES-
LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE PITTSBURG
CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. TRANSCEND IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN SACRAMENTO
AND WE STE STAND IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. OKAY ANYONE OKAY.
WELCOME MORNING MY NAME IS
JASON LYNSEY IRONWORKERS LOCAL
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN KEN MILLER IRONWORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THE
CHICAGO CUBS FAN. NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHUCK
LEONARD THOMAS BUSINESS REP
PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS
LOCAL THREE FORTY TWO WE STAND
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE NON
THAN MODERATOR OF THIS WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY ON
THE TELECONFERENCING LINE- TO
JUST DO THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION IN OPPOSITION TO A
FILE ITEM TWO SENATE BILL FORTY
SEVEN. I THANK MR PERSON ONE
CAN LAYS GENTLEMAN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST LINE'S
GOING TO BE I NUMBER ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SINCE THE
HERE. IN ANNOUNCING THAT IT JIM
TRIED ONE OKAY. IN ORDER TO GO
AND MOVE ON TO ONE NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT. THE
MOBILE LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO MY NAME IS
JAMES FORD FROM AIR ENERGY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOUR SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
NEXT PERSON. NEXT TIME THE
NUMBER LINES ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DOUG KAPLER CONCERT FOR THE
COAST MOUNTAINS COMING STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MONSTER DOES NOT
RESPECT TO A LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS REGINA HELLO IBEW
LOCAL FIVE NINETY FIVE. AND IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT'S WHAT ONE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KINNUNEN WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS UNION AND WE STRUCK
PLEASE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT
ONE OF THE ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MMHM. UNMUTE
MY NUMBER FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. WHAT MY NUMBER
ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE- TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR PERSONAL CAROLINA
BURKE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER EIGHTEEN LINE IS OPEN.
IN ORDER TO SHARE PERSONAL
GUIDELINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SEVENTY SIX. AT THE WATER LINE
FOR ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARING
COMMITTEE THIS IS ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. A LINE
OF A ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS THAT
QUITE OFTEN THAN WHAT THEIR
ENERGYAND STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
NUMBER TWO YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH WELL I NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
OF TIME I GOT ONE WILL CONTINUE
TO GO YEAH RIGHT WHICH IS
PROBABLY NINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHTY LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE WATER LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HIGHS ACREE LEERY ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE BEEN A
PROGRAMMER AMENDED PETITION ON
THE ARM SB FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
POLITE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
A SUPER ALSO AB F. ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. FOUR SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BORDERLINE NUMBER ONE ONE NINE
IT'S ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD MY NAME IS TODD HE
ALSO ON THE BUSINESS MANAGER
HONOR THEM QUITE BITTER YOU A
LOCAL FOUR FOUR SEVEN AND A
VICE PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO CA
ARE BUILDING TRADE I'M CALLING
IN TODAY TO STAND IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER.
WHAT ARE YOUR LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NUMBER ONE NUMBER FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS RAVI ZACHARIAS FROM
ERIN ENERGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALONG THE GULF. YES ONE THOUGH
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THAT YOU JUST SAID THAT NO NEED
TO CALL BACK WHEN WE GET TO
THAT BILL A MODERATOR NEXT UP-
PERSON. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRPERSON WHY NUMBER FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT.
BY NUMBER FORTY THREE LINE IS
OPEN. MODERATOR WE HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR THE OPPOSING ME
TOOS AND WERE A BIT OVER TEN
MINUTES AND HOW MANY MORE DO WE
HAVE BEEN LONG. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON JOINED ABOUT TWENTY
IN LINE I'M SORRY I COULDN'T
HEAR. TWENTY FIVE OKAY SO IN
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES EVERYBODY
BE AS QUICK AS THEY CAN SO WE
CAN TRY TO GET EVERYBODY IN.
MODERATOR WHO'S NEXT. THANK YOU
I NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MATE BERMAN
BUSINESS MANAGER OF IBEW FOR
SIXTY FIVE IN OPPOSITION SB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT ONE. FINALLY WON
ALL THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DISADVANTAGED ISSUE SO LOCAL
SIXTEEN HEAT ACROSS INSULATORS
MERRIN STRONG OPPOSITION SB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
YOU ARE OPEN THERE ARE. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DON
CHAMPION FROM CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. BY NUMBER
ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS STREETS
OVER ANYTIME WITH CHEVRON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB CORSICA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. NOT TO ALIGN OVER
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO EUROPEN.
YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT
KREMIN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
LITTLE ANIMAL. THANK YOU BYE
NUMBER ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS PATRICK
FLORES FROM ERIN ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN. AND JUST FOR THE RECORD
WE ARE ON S. P. FORTY SEVEN SO
PLEASE LINE UP. IF YOU WANT TO
IMPOSE SB FORTY SEVEN MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NEXT ONE OF THE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EXCELLENT NUMBER
ONE A ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE A ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
ZERO ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOPFRONT ROCK
HUMBOLDT DEL NORD BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE STRONGLY
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES S. B. FORTY SEVEN
OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MONTEREY- NEXT COURT. NEXT
LINE'S GOING TO BE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
TWENTY THREE ARE OPEN. SPECIAL
NUMBER TWO OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEVEN GOMEZ I'M THE BUSINESS
MANAGER THE PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOR SIXTY IN
KERN COUNTY AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT KOHLER. CONNECT
FINALLY WON ALL FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HE WAS JOE CARSON WITH
THE TORRANCE REFINING COMPANY
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN AND THIS IS
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN THAT WE
ARE TAKING TESTIMONY ON WE WILL
NOTE THAT MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
PUBLIC ONE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. POLITE NUMBER.
SEVENTY FIVE. ONE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SIX PRESENT-
TRANSPORTATION FEEDBACK PITCHER
PERSON LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTIES IN Q. I'M SORRY
WHAT DID YOU JUST SAY. WE'RE
DONE PERFECT BECAUSE WE'RE
RIGHT AT FIFTEEN MINUTES- SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK- BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS THAT COMPLETES THE-
OPPOSITION TWO PEOPLE HAVE-
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR GROVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR M. MR ONE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING YOUR BILL FORWARD AND
I APPRECIATE- THIS COMMENTS- IN
OPPOSITION SPECIFICALLY.
BECAUSE 70% OF THE OIL PRODUCED
IN THE STATE IS PRODUCED IN MY
COUNTY- I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON THE A DOLLAR
VALUE- YOU KNOW THERE'S THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE SENSE I
BELIEVE THIS OR FROM THE BAND
WILL FIND ANOTHER STE- THERE
WAS THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING THERE WAS
TEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
SWEPT OUT INTO THE- AND- I
BELIEVE THE GENERAL FUND. IF
THERE'S RESOURCES THAT ARE
BEING USED BY CAL JIM TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS BASED ON YOUR
PREVIOUS BILL LAST YEAR AND
OTHER BILLS. IN THE RESOURCES
ARE IN THESE FUNDS HOWEVER
THEY'RE NOT BEING USED IN THEIR
BEING SWEPT OUT TO BE FUNDING
AT OTHER PARTS OF GOVERNMENT- I
GUESS I WANT TO SAY DON'T YOU
THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE THAT
WE INCREASE THE FEES EVEN
THOUGH THE FEES ARE ALREADY-
NOT BEING USED. ALREADY- BUT I
DON'T WANT TO BE I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE RUDE I JUST DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER WAY TO ASK IT SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT. IF
THE FUNDS ARE BEING SWEPT FROM
THIS- THAT THE MONEY IS BEING
SWEPT FROM THESE THIS FUND. FOR
OTHER USES AND YOUR BILL IS TO
INCREASE THE SPEND SO MONEY CAN
BE USED FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PURPOSE OF CAL JAM. THE CALCIUM
IS EASING THE FENCE I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IT WHY IS THERE A
PURPOSE FOR YOUR BILL. IF THE
MONEY'S BEING USED- NOT BEING
USED ALREADY AND IT'S BEEN
SWEPT TO ANOTHER. PART OF
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR-
AND I DON'T WANT TO ACTUALLY.
POINTS TO THE ANALYSIS ON BOTH
PAGE FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS AND
ALSO ASK THREE. OF THE ANALYSIS
AS WELL AS TEACH NINETEEN AT
THE IDYLLWILD REPORTS TALKS
ABOUT HOW TO FIND IT- EXIST AND
I THINK THAT THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE MADE. HAVE BEEN MADE THAT
THE- I'M MONEY HAS NOT BEEN. A
WIDELY USED COMPLETELY. IS
ACTUALLY NOT THE FULL PICTURE
AND THE ANALYSIS GOES INTO THE
DETAILS- CAL CHEN HAS TO.
GATHER THE MONEY AND THEN BE
ABLE TO WORK ON THE PROJECT AND
SO THEY HAVESPENT UP TO THREE
MILLION THEY CANNOT SPEND OVER
AND SO IT HAS BEEN A VERY
DELICATE MATCH OF FINDING THE
RIGHT PROJECT. TO BE ABLE TO DO
AND SO AGAIN IF FROM THE
ANALYSIS WE WILL SEE THAT TO-
THE PICTURE THAT'S BEEN PAINTED
THAT THE FUNDS HAVE NOT BEEN
USED APPROPRIATELY- IT IS NOT
THE FULL PICTURE- THERE IS ALSO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. EVEN WITH
EXISTING EFFORTS AS POINTS OUT
IN THE ANALYSIS. OF THE
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS YOU
REFERENCE MY BILL IN THE PAST
IS STILL NOT ENOUGH IF YOU HAVE
A RANGE FROM FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PLUS MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIVE POINT TWO MILLION THAT'S
ESTIMATED. ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
ARE STILL NOT ENOUGH TO PLUG
AND ABANDON THE CURRENT WELLS
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
KNOW THAT'S NOT EVEN
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL
FUTURE WELLS. THAT COULD BE
ABANDONED AND SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS WHY THIS BILL IS
NEEDED- AND- I DON'T AGREE THAT
IT'S A YOU KNOW. RIGHT NOT
APPROPRIATE TO BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK THAT IT'S
NEEDED I THINK THAT THE
ANALYSIS- HIGHLIGHTS THAT AND
CLARIFIES- TO THE OPPOSITION-
THAT THE FUNDING REALLY IS
BEING. USED- IN AN APPROPRIATE
WAY. SO ARE YOU SEE NOAM WAS
FROM THIS ACCOUNT TO GO TO
OTHER GOVERNMENT ENTITIES ITS
1100% INDUSTRY FUNDED. I CANNOT
SPEAK ON THE MANY SLACKS STUDY
I AM NOT I AM NOT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND SO I CAN'T. SPEAK
TO THAT AND I WILL SEE IF. THE
COMMITTEE STAFF CAN SPEAK TO
THE IN A DIFFERENT WAY. OKAY
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE THREE
MILLION IN THE SPECIAL FUNDS
RIGHT SO I GUESS BUT YOUR BILL
WANTS TO INCREASE THOSE
DOLLARS. AND A THREE MILLION TO
THE SPECIAL FUND CORRECT THE
THREE MILLION TO THE SPECIAL
FINE. BUT MANY HAS BEEN SWEPT
FROM THIS FUND INTO OTHER AREAS
OF GOVERNMENT- YOU KNOW I GUESS
WE CAN GET IT. I DON'T HAVE
LIKE A BALANCE SHEET THAT SHOWS
MANY IN AND OUT BUT- MONEY FROM
THIS FUND THAT YOU WANT TO
INCREASE WASN'T USED IN WAS HE
AND THEN WAS SWEPT TO ANOTHER
PART OF GOVERNMENT FOR. ANOTHER
USE- I JUST THINK IT WOULD BE.
I DON'T SEE MORE PRODUCTIVE I
JUST THINK THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MONEY THAT IS IN
THIS FUND IS USED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE FUND WHICH IS
TO ADDRESS THE ORPHANED AND
ABANDONED WELLS- AND IF MONEY'S
BEEN TAKEN FROM THE SEVEN WHICH
IT APPEARS THAT IT IS- WE DON'T
NEED MORE LEGISLATION TO
INCREASE MONEY TO GO BACK INTO
THIS FUND WE NEED MANY TO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
MONEY IN THIS FUND IS USED FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE FUND IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND I WILL SAY THAT I THINK.
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
IDENTIFYING TWO DIFFERENT ITEMS
ONE. YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY.
IS NEEDED TO ACTUALLY. SECURE
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM RIGHT OF
THE ABANDONED WELLS- THE BUT
YOU'RE ALSO SPEAKING TO- DAY.
THAT HE LEFT. FUNDS SO THOSE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT FUNDS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO THE
THREE MILLION SPECIAL SIGN IS
NOT THAT. HE WAS FUNDS THAT'S
H. E. W. A S. I CAN'T RESPOND
TO THAT QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S
NOT A FUND THAT I'M DEALING
WITH. THEY ARE SEPARATE SIGNS.
THAT YOU'RE LEADING TO AND
CERTAINLY- I ACTUALLY SHARE.
YOUR OPINION THAT- MONEY FOR
ABANDONED UP AND PLUG WHAT
ABOUT FOR BILL- BATTING IN AND
PLUGGING WELLS. SHOULD BE USED
FOR THAT. SO I JUST WANT TO
IDENTIFY THAT THE MONEY THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT WAS
SWEPT. INTO IS NOT THIS TIME.
IT'S. THE- HE'D WHAT FUNDS. A
BUT ALL THESE FUNDS ARE
CONTROLLED BY CAL JIM RATE OR
NOT. SO I ME BUT I CAN'T SO
AGAIN I CAN'T SPEAK TO A
DIFFERENT FUND AND BUILD THIS
BILL DOES NOT. LEAD TO AN END
SO THAT IT YOU KNOW IF THERE IS
A DIFFERENT WORKER DIFFERENT
BILL. FOR A DIFFERENT FIND I'M
I APPRECIATE THAT- BUT I SHARE
THE OPINION THAT. FUNDS SHOULD
BE USED FOR THE INTENDED
PURPOSE THANK YOU MA'AM. FROM
SENATOR LIMóN- CENTER GROVE
SAID SHE SHOULD KNOW HOW TO ASK
THE QUESTION ANOTHER WAY. AND I
THINK I DO WANT TO ASK THE
QUESTION ANOTHER WAY. BECAUSE
THE- WHEN I WAS RESOURCES
SECRETARY AND OVERSAW THAN
DARKER. WE HAD THIS INCREDIBLE
FOR FUN WHILE PROBLEM WHO WHERE
IT WAS SOMETHING TO LOSE SLEEP
OVER THAT THERE WERE THESE
ORPHAN WELLS COMING WHERE THERE
WAS NO AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT
WAS IN RESERVE FOR ANYWHERE
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO DO
IT AND IT LOOKED LIKE THERE WAS
GOING TO BE A HUGE COST DUMPED
BURKE UNDER THE TAXPAYERS SO
THE QUESTION IS. DO YOU HAVE
SOME SENSE. OF COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM WHAT GOES INTO
THESE FUNDS OR WHAT BILLS THE
BILLS SAY SOME SENSE OF WHAT
THE POTENTIAL COST IS FOR MORE
FOR ORPHAN WELLS THAT EXIST OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA.
YES CHAIR AND ACTUALLY THAT
REALLY DOES RANGE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS ON THE
CURRENT WELLS AND THIS IS FROM
THE TWENTY NINETEEN IDYLLWILD
REPORT- SO THIS IS A
CALCULATION SO THIS IS WHY. WE
ARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
REMEDY THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
WANT THE TAXPAYERS TO BIRD AND
ALL OF THAT- THE COST IT IS A
VERY BIG COSTS SO IF. YOU JUST
LOOKING AT THE WELLS OUT THERE-
EATS A BIG RANGE- AND CERTAINLY
AT ONE MILLION WHICH IS WHAT
THE ORIGINAL AMOUNT WAS AND AS
THE FIND- IT WOULD TAKE US OVER
FIVE HUNDRED YEARS I TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE MINIMAL WORK- BUT WE
REALLY WON'T KNOW UNTIL THE
WORK. YOU KNOW IT IS STARTED
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS AT
IMPORTANT WORK YOU KNOW FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND SO IT'S
REGRETTABLE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S NINE PINYIN THAT
INCREASING THE FINE WOULD
CREATE MORE YOU KNOW JOBS- BUT
IT CERTAINLY THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT- WE WANT
THIS WORKED AND WE WANT. TO BE
ABLE TO FIND WAYS TO. FOR THE
CLEANUP OF THIS- YOU KNOW OF
THESE AND THIS BIG PROBLEM HAS
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY INDUSTRY
IT IS A BIG PROBLEM THAT THAT I
THINK THAT IS A COMMON
DENOMINATOR WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS IS A PROBLEM- AND THESE
ARE REALLY BIG FUNDS WERE
LOOKING AT SO WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO FIND A WAY. TO SOLVE NOW AND
THEN THERE. THE POINT ABOUT
SWEEPING MONEY FROM ANY FUND
MAKES NO SENSE IT IT'S LIKE WHY
WOULD YOU SWEEP MONEY FROM THE
FUND. IF IT'S BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION AND SOME
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
OBLIGATION THAT EXISTS OUT
THERE HE IS YOUR BILL
ADDRESSING THE MAXIMUM THAT
WOULD PREVENT. THE SWEEPING. OF
FUNDS IN THE FUTURE. TELL MY
BILL ALLOWS FOR AN INCREASE OF.
ANY DOES SPECIFY THAT IT WOULD
BE FOR IT PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING WELLS. AND SO IF
THERE WAS INTEREST IN IT.
DOUBLE OR PROCESS TO FIND OUT I
WOULD CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO DO THAT I MEAN
THAT READ THIS IS VERY VERY
SPECIFIC- FOR THIS EFFORT. AND
WE DON'T KNOW OF ANY INSTANCE
WHERE ANY FUNDS HAVE BEEN SWEPT
FROM THIS FIND THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON- AND- I THINK THAT
THERE IS. ALSO A LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT YOU KNOW
ALL. BECAUSE THIS FUND WILL
NEVER AT LEAST IN THIS
ITERATION OF THE OF THE BILL
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH. FOR THE
ENTIRE PROBLEM BUT IT WILL BE
BETTER ADDRESS THE PROBLEM- I A
THINK THAT THERE IS THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE VALUE OF
LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO
PAY FOR IT. THE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. IF THERE IS A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR PROBLEM AFTER-
AND THE FACT THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO TAXPAYERS TO PAY THAT- END
WE WOULD LIKE THERE TO BE JOBS
THAT REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA-
TOWARD DEALING WITH ORPHAN
WELLS. IF THERE'S ANY PART OF
YOUR BILL THAT DOESN'T ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES CLEARLY IF THIS
BILL MOVES TODAY WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT GETS
ADDRESSED CORRECTLY. ABSOLUTELY
OKAY BIGGER BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED AT THE
COMMITTEE ARE VERY LEGITIMATE
THE END AT THE END WE SHOULD-
RICHEST ARE NOTE THE MANY
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED TO
TRY TO WORK DID YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED AGAINST CENTER GROVE
CITY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
DO AGREE WITH YOU MISS SOLOMON
THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
ORPHANED AND ABANDONED WELLS
AND- YOU KNOW BY A CONTRACTOR
THE OTHER DAY THAT WAS
CONTACTING ME REGARDING CAL JAM
BECAUSE THEY WERE ABANDONED IN
A HUNDRED YEAR OLD WELL
SOMEPLACE DOWN IN NEWPORT
BEACH- LONG BEACH OR- SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. M. SO I DO AGREE
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM OUT
THERE AT. I DON'T I DO AND I DO
NOT I DO UNDERSTAND THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE RESOURCES IN THERE
TO ADDRESS- THE ABANDONED OR
FROM WELL FIND ISSUE- AGAIN
REPRESENTING 70% OF THE OIL
THAT'S PRODUCED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I GET BEAT I GET I
THINK I HAVE A GREAT AT GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF THE INDUSTRY
NOT AN EXPERT UNDERSTANDING BUT
A GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF THE
INDUSTRY. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
IT'S LISTENING TO THIS
CONVERSATION- NOT. ONE DIME HAS
EVER BEEN PAID FOR BY TAXPAYERS
TO ADDRESS- ORPHANED OR
ABANDONED WELLS. IT'S ALL 1100%
INDUSTRY FUNDED. AND IF THIS
FEE GOES FORWARD INDUSTRY WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO PAY FOR AND THIS
IT WAS FOR THIS FUND IT WOULD
NOT GO ON TAXPAYERS SHOULDERS.
M. THE FRUSTRATION THAT I HAVE
IS WHETHER IT'S TEN MILLION
FIFTY MILLION FIVE MILLION
THREE MILLION THE MONEY EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE TWO SEPARATE
FUNDS THEIR USE FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE TO ADDRESS THE ORPHAN
AND WENT ABANDONED WELL ISSUE
THAT WE ALL EVERYONE INCLUDING
INDUSTRY AS A CONCERN WITH THAT
MANY IS NEVERTHELESS STILL
BEING SWEPT OUT OF THESE
ACCOUNTS IN INTO OTHER SOURCES
OF OUR OTHER REASONS TO SPEND
MANY IN GOVERNMENT. SO THAT I
HAVE I DO HAVE THAT CONCERN I
ALSO- I DON'T KNOW IF COMMITTEE
STAFF CAN ANSWER THIS AND I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T POINT THIS
QUESTION AT YOU MISS LIMóN
BECAUSE I DON'T I MEAN YOU'RE
BRILLIANT AND I'M SURE YOU
MIGHT HAVE THE ANSWER BUT IF
YOU DON'T- COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
STAFF CAN ANSWER IT. WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THESE WELLS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TOP THREE
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE. I DON'T
HAVE THAT ANSWER- BUT CERTAINLY
I'VE COMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE IT
WE'D BE HAPPY TO GET YOU THAT
ANSWER. BUT I DON'T HAVE THAT
ANSWER OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
I THINK THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND AS WELL. ANYWAYS
THANK YOU MISS SOMEONE FOR
LETTING ME ASK THESE QUESTIONS
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. AND I THINK I'M
GOING TO ADD TO THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S ONE THING THAT KEEPS
GETTING SAID BUT I DON'T THINK
THE TO KEEP SAYING THIS THE
FUNDS WERE SWEPT IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS A LOAN THAT
WOULD BE PAID BACK TO THE PHONE
TO SET DOES ANYBODY KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
SENATOR LAMONT YOU KNOW IF IT
WAS A LOAN IT WASN'T JUST SWEPT
IT WAS A LOAN THAT FINANCED A
GRUNT. I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
I'M SORRY IT YOU KNOW AGAIN
THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T DEAL
WITH THAT FUND THAT'S BEING
REFERENCED OKAY. THEN WE'RE
GOOD IT'S JUST MY EXPERIENCE IN
THE PAST IS THAT WAS ALONE THIS
BUT MISTER CHAIR THE POINT IS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS ON
ESTIMATES ONLY AND WE'RE TAKING
MONEY. FROM A SOLELY INDUSTRY
PROVIDED FUND NOT TAX FOR ITS
ITS SOLELY INDUSTRY FUNDED. AND
WE'RE TAKING THE INDUSTRY
CONSISTS MANY THESE FRIENDS
RATHER IT'S THE ABANDONED OR
FROM A FINE OR THAT THE OTHER
FIND THEIR USE FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE A TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS AND THEY
TAKE THAT MONEY FROM THOSE FANS
THEY'VE SWEEP IT LOAN AT
WHATEVER. WINS LAST TIME ALONE
IS BEEN PAID BACK YOU KNOW
HELLO MOORLACH SORRY I WAS
BUDGET CHAIR. SIXTEEN YEARS AGO
WE DID. OF LOANS AND THEN JERRY
BROWN PAID THE MALL BACK. SO
DO. SO BUT I THINK. I THINK IT
IS SIGNIFICANT IF IT'S A LONE
ENDED AND IT'S SORT ARE WILL
STIPULATE THAT THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT MAKES ME CRAZY OF A
BECAUSE- THEY DON'T HAVE WORK.
AWARENESS OF HOW IT MIGHT
POLITICALLY UP BECAUSE THIS IS
PAID FOR BY THE THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE REGULATED AND SHOULD
GO FOR THE STATED PURPOSE
PERIOD THE END TEN IT IS NOT
PART OF THIS BILL AND I THINK
THE SECOND THING. IS THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
UPDATED INFORMATION BUT I KNOW
THAT WHEN I WAS WORKING WITH
THE SUBJECT PART OF THE
EXASPERATION IS THE STATE
AGENCY WAS TAKING FOREVER TO
PROCESS THE ORPHAN WELLS IN
THAT YEAR THERE MIGHT BE A LOT
OF ORPHAN WELLS OUT THERE BUT
DEALING WITH IT AND I THINK
THERE'S EVEN A BUDGET REQUEST
THIS YEAR TO TRY TO GIVE THEM
THE STAFF TO MAKE SURE THEY
MOVED TO. THE FOREFRONT WHILE
CENTER FOR CERTIFICATION UP
MORE SENATOR LAMONT YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT. SORRY
EIGHT. WHAT DO I KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT PART OF WHAT YOU
SAID BUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
OF A BUDGET ASK OR SOMETHING
OUT THERE TO GET THEM TO
PROCESS THE ORPHAN WELLS
QUICKER. WELL I MEAN IS THAT
THE BILL THAT WE CARRIED IT IN
THE PAST WAS IT AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE THE CAPACITY OF CAL
JAM IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PROCESS IT- FASTER. SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT OF ONE THIS YEAR-
THEN THAT MAN. NO MORE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME WE'RE NOT OF THE
SEPT OF FINAL ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS. LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND BEFORE I ASK YOU
TO CLOSE LET ME MAKE A COMMENT-
WE HAVE A LOT. THAT HAS BEEN
BROUGHT IN FRONT OF US THERE'S
STRONG OPPOSITION FROM PEOPLE
THAT ARE REALLY CONCERNED.
ABOUT JOBS. THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER FOR FRIEND WELLS
ARE BEING PROCESS QUICK ENOUGH.
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER FINANCES THING IS A
LOAN RATHER THAN- PER PER
COMPLETE SWEEP THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THAT
MONEY WILL COME BACK. AND ALL
THOSE THINGS ARE THINGS THAT I
THINK WOULD INFLUENCE THIS AND
THE AUTHOR HAS SAID. SHE WOULD
BE WILLING TO WORK ON THESE I
FOR ONE WOULD BE WILLING. TO
GIVE THE AUTHOR A CHANCE TO
MOVE THIS ALONG AND WORK ON IT
BUT I THINK THAT. FOR THIS BILL
TO MOVE THOSE QUESTIONS NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED. IT IN A WAY THAT
PEOPLE FEEL COMPLEMENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG YOU SEEKING TO BE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SIR YES
YES. GO AHEAD. YES I JUST
WANTED TO SUPPORT YOUR
OBSERVATIONS THERE WITH RESPECT
TO THESE OPEN ISSUES AND
SUPPORT BUT- OBVIOUSLY THESE
THINGS NEED TO BE RESOLVED SO I
JUST WANT. TO STAND SUPPORTERS
STATE AFTER. AND THE OTHER
THING SHOULD JUST FOR AS MUCH.
IT'S ALL NEVER THE TIME I WAS
MAYOR. AND WE HAD TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE SITTING IN THE ROOM
WAITING FOR AN ITEM. AND WE HAD
AN ITEM WITH TWO PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM ABOUT THE HOTEL HEIGHT.
AND I THOUGHT I'D TAKE IT
QUICKLY TO GET IT OUT OF THE
WAY ON ALL TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THE HOTEL
SIDE BECAUSE I HAD ME SIT THERE
WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT AND I
THINK WE ARE. HAVING THAT
DYNAMIC HERE EVERYBODY'S
WAITING FOR THE FRACKING BILL
AND THEY'RE WEIGHING IN ON ON
THIS. SO ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE SENATOR
WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU CARE AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT
CONVERSATION AND I THINK. YOU
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO. THERE IS
DIFFERENT FORMS OF OPPOSITION
ONE NOT RELATED TO THE BILL-
BUT TO A DIFFERENT BILL THAT'S
COMING FORWARD BUT ALSO TO THE
CONCERNS FROM- ARE YOU KNOW
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN LABOR
AYE. EXTINCT AYE IHOPE THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME AND VALUE IN
AND ANALYZING THE BILL AND
LOOKING AT THE FACT THAT.
INCREASING THE FUNDS- CREATES
MORE JOBS AND OR YOU KNOW THAT
THE WORK NEEDS TO GET DONE IN
AND ABANDONING END UP LIKING
WELLS APPROPRIATELY. I THINK TO
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT FINE I JUST ASK FOR-
A SEPARATION OF THE TO FIND THE
WE ARE IN THIS BILLS. YOU KNOW
WHAT EALS WITH ONE OF FIND NOT
THE FUND THAT'S BEING
REFERENCED. AND I THINK THAT
THE THIRD POINT- ABOUT
CLARIFYING. THAT THESE THAT
FUNDS SHOULD ONLY BE USED FOR
PURPOSES OF THE BANNING AND
ABANDONING END UP LIKING. AND
PLUGGING WELLS APPROPRIATELY IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THAT
THERE IS GENERAL CONSENSUS WITH
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO. ENSURE
THAT IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
WE CLARIFY THAT AND STRENGTH IN
THAT PIECE IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE MOTION
ON THIS BILL. SAN HERTZBERG. TO
THE WHAT DO. CALL THE ROLL. SB
TWENTY OF FORTY SEVEN LIMóN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI THERE
ALL RIGHT JONES. ALLEN EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D HUESO
LIMóN. AN EARLY NON AYE MON
AYE STERN HI STERN HI THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES BUT WE'LL PUT IT
ON CALL FOR THE- REMAINING
MEMBERS JUST BEFORE WE MOVED TO
FILE ITEM THREE WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ON CONSENT WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. MOTION
BY GROVE PRESS CORRECT RIGHT
YOU DID THAT OR WAS IT A-
MOTION BY EGGMAN I CAN'T- KNOWS
WHAT WE'RE GOOD I JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHO WAS MOTION BY EGGMAN
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
THE CONSENT CURRENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM NINE. LAYERED HI
THERE ALL RIGHT JONES. ALLEN
EGGMAN. RIGHT EGGMAN ALL RIGHT
GROW. GROVE HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI HUESO LOAN. EARLY
MAN I MON RIGHT STERN PART
STERN ALL RIGHT DENNIS SIX
VOTES WILL PUT IT ON CALL I
WILL MOVE TO FINAL ITEM THREE
WHICH IS S. BEFORE- OH SIX
SENATOR STERN WE HAVE ONE WEEK
SUPPORT WITH MISS. OR NO WE
HAVE TO- THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THAT'S EIGHTY FOUR OH SIX THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND FOR THE
SECOND TIME I APPRECIATE YOU
STEPPING UP TO CHAIR THIS
COMMITTEE- IN LIGHT OF THE
SENSITIVITY OF MY CIRCUMSTANCES
AND ALLOW ME TO PRESENT HERE.
WITH YOU TODAY I'LL BE BRIEF-
YOU YOU'VE OUCHED ON SOME OF
THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES ALREADY
THAT ARE GOING. THAT THEY'RE
TAKING PLACE A CALLA JIM. LESS
SO- IN ISSUE A- IT INDUSTRY
VERSUS ENVIRONMENT OR CONCERNS
FOR BETWEEN YOU KNOW LABOR AND
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES WE'RE
GONNA HEAR A LOT OF THOSE
ARGUMENTS PLAY OUT TODAY BUT
THIS BILL. IS IT IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT LANE IN THAT IT'S
REALLY JUST TRYING TO
INSTITUTE. A REGULATORY
COMPETENCIES SO THAT. WHEN WE
PASS LAWS THAT THE AGENCIES
ACTUALLY HAVE THE IMPRIMATUR
AND THE PUSH TO DO IT. A DOZEN
OBVIOUSLY DOING SOME OF THE
BUDGET ISSUES OUT THERE BUT
WE'VE HAD ONGOING ISSUES IN
TERMS OF- TRACKING WELL
HISTORY'S DISCLOSURE AROUND
SITES- UPDATES TO WEBSITES
TRYING TO EXPEDITE ADA
COMPLIANCE FOR DOCUMENT
REQUESTS A LOT OF THE INDUSTRY
STILL ON PAPER AND SO THINGS
ARE HAVING TO GET. SCANNED AND
ENTERED BY HAND IN THEIRS
BACKLOGS IN FRUSTRATION AT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL WHEN
ZONING ADMINISTRATORS LIKE IN
MY BACKYARD ACTUALLY WERE MY
OWN FAMILY LIVES THERE'S A WELL
SITE LITERALLY BEHIND- MY
FATHER IN LAW'S OLD APARTMENT
AND- WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DEAL
WITH. ZONING ADMINISTRATOR
THERE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND TRYING TO GET
RECORDS DISCLOSED- AND CAL JIM
AND THE CITY. DON'T SIMPLY HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIP AND IT'S ODD-
BUT THAT'S THE CIRCUMSTANCE
RIGHT NOW AND SOME OF IT HAS TO
DO WITH THE THINGS THIS BILLS
TRYING TO SOLVE- I CAN GET INTO
A FEW MORE DETAILS BUT- THINGS
LIKE WELL EXPIRATION DATES.
NOTICES OF VIOLATION- THOSE
KIND OF ISSUES AND WILL HISTORY
I THINK BY GETTING ALL THAT
CLEAR IN THE LAW. AND HOPEFULLY
HAVING. A RENEWAL PLAN THAT I
THINK THE AGENCY IS COMMITTED
TO BRINGING AND SECRETARY
CROWFOOT WAS GOING TO BE
TESTIFYING HERE THIS MORNING. I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT- THEY
SHOULD BE COMING BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE WAS SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL SO WE
WANT THIS TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND TRY TO SET. A NEW CHAPTER
IN THIS THIS NEW DIVISION OVER
IT AT THE RESOURCES AGENCY
WOULD SO WITH THAT. I WILL I
WILL CUT MY REMARKS AND- ASKED
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I THINK WE
HAVE. ON THE ON THE LINE- ONE
OF THE COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
ACTUALLY AND FOLKS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE WELL I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT- ALONG THAT PECO
CORRIDOR. AS WELL AS AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE SIERRA CLUB
ABOUT THIS SENATE FLOOR COMMON
PROFESSOR MICHAEL SOLOMON WE
HAVE TO. A MORE INCOME FROM THE
SIERRA CLUB AND PROFESSOR
MICHAEL SOLOMON YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES BETWEEN YOU. I KNOW
THAT- MS COLUMN TODAY FEDERAL
EXPRESS VERSION OF HER
TESTIMONY LAST TIME IT SOUNDED
LIKE THE END OF A CAR
COMMERCIAL QUICK SHE WENT. SO
WE HAVE THREE MINUTES HERE
WE'LL GO FIRST. TO- OF WARM
CALL. THANK YOU JERRY GOOD
MORNING LEARN COLUMBIA ERICA
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING HALF
MILLION MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
ACROSS THE STATE. JERICHO
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT AT THE
FOURTH TECH BECAUSE IT'LL HELP
INCREASE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY HOW TO.
THANK YOU TELL THEM ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THE COMMISSION AMONG
PUBLIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISTS. IN THE TWENTY ONE
ABOUT BEING AGED BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC TRUST REPORTS THAT HELPS.
WITH THAT CONCLUSION. YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING. BARNES INCREASE.
MAKING WATER MAY ACCESSIBLE THE
PUBLIC ESPECIALLY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC PUBLIC DELIVERY NEXT
DOOR TO OIL AND GAS ACTIVITY
AND THREATENED BY THESE ISSUES
HELP FOR. IN ADDITION DURING
LOCAL AGENCIES KNOW HOW TO
INTERACT WITH CHILDREN TO HELP
IMPLEMENT OR ENFORCE LOCAL
ORDINANCES AND CONDITIONS CORD
ALTHOUGH THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ENSURE
ENFORCEMENT. OUTREACH EFFORTS
TO INCREASE COMMUNICATION TO
THE STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF REPRESENTED
MY CONTRACT THAT WILL HELP I
THINK WE KNOW MANY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND RESIDENTS AND.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY. BUT
SHE'S COMMITTEE RESIDENT A
RIGHT TO. THAT IS NEVER
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE WORLD FORGOT
WELL. RENDON ACTIVELY IN THE
DIRTY EMISSIONS LONGER TWELVE.
HEALTH COMBAT I JUST BOUGHT
WRITE IT WORN OUT THAT YOU. AND
BEFORE THE GLENCORE BILL TO
HELP CONTINUE TO REFORM OF. I
CALDERON WE CENTERS LEADER. AND
URGED OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF A PROFESSOR
SOLOMON. MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ASTRID PLEASE CONSULT SENATOR
STERN HOW MUCH TIME I HAVE. HE
JUST GO FOR TWO MINUTES I'LL
GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES AS IF
THERE WERE FOUR BUT JUST GO.
OKAY MY NAME IS MICHAEL SALMAN
I'M A RECENTLYRETIRED
PROFESSOR OF HISTORY AT UCLA.
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN I'VE BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN UNPAID
CITIZEN ADVOCACY ABOUT OIL
REGULATION. AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE SOUTH COAST AQ MD
AND THE STATE. READY ACCESS TO
THE OIL WELL RECORDS THAT WOULD
BE MANDATED BY S. BEFORE A SIX
IS CRITICAL TO THE PUBLIC. IT'S
ALSO CRITICAL TO LOCAL AGENCY
PERFORMANCE OF SEQUIN COOPER
DUTIES THAT ARE MANDATED BY
STATE LAW. THIS THE STATE HAS
AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE WORLD
RECORDS READILY AVAILABLE
ACCESS BY THE PUBLIC AND LOCAL
AGENCIES IS ALSO NECESSARY FOR
CAL JIM TO PERFORM ITS DUTIES
PROPERLY. I'LL ILLUSTRATE THIS
WITH TWO EXAMPLES FROM LARGE
OIL DRILL SITES IN LA CITY
DOCUMENTS AVAILABLE ON REQUEST
AND- SENATOR STERN AND HIS
SPEND THE COMMITTEE STAFF. HAVE
A COPY OF THIS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY UPON CUT SHORT. THE
WEST PICO DUAL SIDED IN THE
LARGELY WHITE UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS PEOPLE ROBERTSON
NEIGHBORHOOD AS FIFTY SEVEN
WELLS. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE OPERATING
COMPANY DRILL TWO NEW WELLS
TWELVE THREE DRILLS INTO TEN
WELL CONVERSIONS WITH DOCTOR
PERMITS. ALL OF THESE PROJECTS
REQUIRE DISCRETIONARY APPROVAL
BY CITY PLANNING AND SECRET
CLEARANCE BUT NO APPLICATIONS
WERE MADE AND THE CITY DOES NO
COMPLIANCE INSPECTIONS TO CHECK
FOR UNAPPROVED PROJECTS. WITH
THE OPERATOR APPLIED FOR THE
DOCTOR PROPER PERMITS THE CHECK
BOXES STATING THAT NO LOCAL
AGENCY SEQUEL CLEARANCE WAS
REQUIRED. I WAS ABLE TO TRACK
THESE TWENTY FOUR ON APPROVED
PROJECTS ONLY BECAUSE THE DOG-
WELL RECORDS DATA FROM BEFORE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AFTER APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DOGRA STOPPED
UPDATING ONLINE FILES AND I
READ ALL THE FILES BEFORE CAL
JIM DISCONNECTED IT'S FTP
SERVER IN SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY.
THE BANNING DRILL SITE IN THE
LARGELY LATINO WORKING CLASS
WILMINGTON NEIGHBORHOOD HAS
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY WELLS. THIS IS THE NEW
ASTRAL SIGHT IN THE CITY OPENED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX WITH CITY
APPROVAL TO DRILL FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY WELLS OVER A TWELVE YEAR
PERIOD ENDING IN AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AFTER THE EXPIRATION
THE SITE OPERATOR REPLIED TO
DOCTOR FOR ABOUT A HALF DOZEN
PERMITS TO DRILL NEW WELLS.
USING WELL STAR THE OPERATORS
SUBMITTED THE EXPO TO. SIX CITY
PA APPROVED. AND MITIGATED
NEGATIVE. THE OPERATOR RECEIVED
DOCTOR PERMITS THE OPERATOR
ALSO APPLIED FOR TO REACH ALL
PERMITS AND PRESENTED THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX APPROVAL WHICH
NEVER AUTHORIZED. REDRAWING AND
THEIR APPLICATION. SALMON IF
YOU. COULD SEE PLEASE WRAP
PLEASE WRAP IT BUT IT IS
UNCLEAR APPLICATIONS THE
OPERATOR LISTED AS LOCAL AGENCY
CONTACT. A PLANNING STAFFERS
LAST WORK FOR THE CITY IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. NEITHER LOCAL
AGENCIES NOR CAL JIM CAN DO
THEIR JOB PROPERLY WITH A
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CRITICAL
RECORDS OF OIL WELLS. CAL JIM'S
INVITATION I PARTICIPATED IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY ADVANCED
DEMONSTRATION. OF THE PUBLIC
FACEOF WELLSTAR NO WELL
RECORDS WERE GOING TO BE MADE
ACCESSIBLE PROFESSORS TOM
UNLIMITED SHE ADDED UNDER PRIOR
LEADERSHIP. PROFESSOR SIMON
HERE YOUR SIDE HAS GONE MINUTES
OVER AND WE HAVE THIS MAIN
EVENT A BILL THAT THE WHOLE
WORLD IS WAITING FOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURTESY NEED TO GO.
THANK YOU. OKAY. NOW WILL GO
TO- PEOPLE DOING ME TO INS. IS
THERE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM
HERE THAT WISHES TO INDICATE
THEIR SUPPORT. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THAT WISHES TO COME TO
THE PODIUM AND INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS ITEM S. BEFORE.
SIX SEEING NONE MODERATOR THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCES
SYSTEM TO OFFER SUPPORT FOR S.
B. FOUR OH SIX AND I EMPHASIZE.
FOUR OH SIX. THANK YOU TO OUR
OFFER SUPPORT FOR FOUR OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. NAME AN
AFFILIATION FOR LEGISLATIVE
RECORD AND WE NOW GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FIFTY THREE. THE LION
TO SIXTY FIVE GO HEAD TO SIXTY
FIVE. ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MERCEDES YES AND
THE PORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO LINE
TO FORTY FIVE POINT NINE TWO
FORTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
JEREMY SANTOS AND NINE ON IN
SUPPORT OF A SPEAKER SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE ONE SEVENTY
TWO BILLION. THIS IS VERONICA
WILL OPEN UP I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF TOWARDS ZERO SIX BUT
I AM BEEN CUT OFF IN WAS IN
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR SEVEN AND
IN CASE WE ARE GETTING SHUT OUT
FOR FUTURE BUILD TODAY I IN
SUPPORT OF COURSE SIX SEVEN.
OUR QUICKLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WHAT WE RE ANNOUNCE THAT.
THE PHONE LINES FILLED UP EARLY
AND THE MODERATOR ADDED TWENTY
FIVE MORE AND THEY SHOWED UP
AND THEN THE MODERATOR ADDED
FIFTY MORE AND THEY FILLED UP.
SO LET ME JUST FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE LOWER. I'M I'M ON A
I'M SORRY. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT WE'RE DONE WITH THAT
BUT IT'S I JUST WANT EVERYBODY
TO KNOW THAT THAT'S THE CASE
MODERATE OR ANYBODY. ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR OH SIX. HE
RECLINED THIRTY GO PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY THEIR QUEUED UP EARLY
THEY MAY NOT HAVE BEEN IN
SUPPORT WILL FIND OUT LINE TO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE TO
THIRTEEN. MODERATE RISES FORTY
NINE PEOPLE WROTE IT UP
THINKING IT WAS ANOTHER BILL SO
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING-
POSSIBLY WE ONLY HAVE TWO MORE
ONLY CHECK REAL QUICK WE HAVE
ONE TWO SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
OF CARE AND SUPPORT FOR SIX.
TWO SEVENTY IS LEFT THE QUEUE
IN THE LINE TO FORTY EIGHT. TO
CREATE WHAT THE QUEUE MEMORY TO
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR- WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO PROPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR OH SIX WE
HAD NO LEAD WITNESS. SAYING NO
ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO PASS BEFORE SIX.
SAYING NO ONE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. FOUR OH SIX. YES SIR
THE GENTLEMAN TO- SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BEFORE SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN A PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME- MIXTURE
WE HAVE NOBODY IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO MATTERS BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YES SENATOR GROVE
THANK YOU THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SOLUTION I UNDERSTAND I
REALLY DO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BECAUSE-
THERE IS A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT PEOPLE ARE WANTING TO
HAVE. AT THEIR FINGERTIPS I
GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN IS IN. IN
BELIEVE ME I HAVE MY OWN ISSUES
WITH CAL JIM SO I'M NOT HERE
TRYING TO DEFEND CAL JIM. AN
BUT YOU KNOW EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES THAT ANY OWNER OR- ANY
OWNER OF ANY WILL FILE. A WITH
CAL JIM THE SUPERVISOR MEANING-
SPECIFICALLY THE SUPERVISOR OF
CAL JAM. A MONTHLY STATEMENT TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN INFORMATION
RELATING TO THE WELL INCLUDING
THE SOURCE THE VOLUME THE
TREATMENT THE DISPOSITION OF
THE WATER PRODUCED IN THE OIL
AND GAS ACTIVITIES. EXISTING
LAW ALSO REQUIRES THE OWNER OF
ANY WILL TO FILE WITH THE
SUPERVISOR AGAIN CALCIUM. ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS SPECIFIED
INFORMATION RELATED TO- THE
WILL. OF THE SPECIFIED
INFORMATION AND IF THERE'S A
LIST THAT COULD GO ON AN
EXISTING ALSO REQUIRES THE
OPERATOR. AT THAT PRODUCES OIL
BY THE APPLICATION OF THE
MINING IN- AB. APPLICATION
MINING OR OTHER UNCONVENTIONAL
TECHNIQUES THAT HAVE TO BE
REPORTED EACH. EACH YEAR BY
MARCH FIRST AND THEN THE- ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION IS PUT UP
ON THE WEBSITE SO THE PUBLIC
HAS ACCESS TO IT. AND THERE'S A
EXTENDED TIME ON MONITORING
EXTENDED TIME ON. AND NEAR THE
LINK THE PROCESS OF HOW LONG
YOU KNOW THESE TO MONITOR ON
FRACKING SITUATIONS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME OR DAYS AND NOW
THEY DO IT. LEGALLY A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO THE
WEBSITE- AGAIN I AM NOT
DEFENDING CAL JIM IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM. I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IT- WITH EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
CAUGHT UP WITH. AND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THIS STUFF
IS AVAILABLE ADDING NEW
REQUIREMENTS TO THEM IS JUST. I
MEAN IS THERE ANY WAY TO TAKE A
PAUSE SO WE CAN. FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE THEY
STILL HAVEN'T STARTED COMPLYING
WITH THE STUFF THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN PUT INTO LEGISLATIVE
ACTION. THE LAST YEAR. I THINK
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS
MORE TO. LESS TO CHANGE. IT
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT LET'S
TO CHANGE THE ACTUAL
SUBSTANTIVE REQUIREMENT AND
MORE TO ELECTRONIC. ELECTRONIC
FIVE- DID. MAKE THE PROCESS
ELECTRONIC BECAUSE A LOT OF
THOSE MONTHLY REPORTS AND
THOSE. THINGS ARE COMEBACKER
LITERALLY STACKS OF PAPER. AND
WE SAY PUT ON THE WEBSITE BUT
THEN. YOU READY EIGHTY EIGHTY
ISSUES RUN THE SCANNING ISSUES.
YOU KNOW- BACKLOG SO IF WE CAN
MAKE THE PROCESS ELECTRONIC WE
THINK THAT MONTHLY PROCESS IN
THE COURT OF THE PROCESS WILL
GO A LOT FASTER. AND THERE'S A
FEW PIECE OF DATA THAT THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE I THINK IT'S-
ACID WELL TREATMENTS AREN'T IN
THERE AND THEN ALSO. THE
HISTORIC PEACE I GUESS. YOU'RE
RIGHT ABOUT THE SORT OF ON
GOING NEW ACTIVITY BUT I THINK
IT'S THE IT'S THE WILL HISTORY.
AND THE HISTORY ON THE NOTICES
OF VIOLATION OR THE HISTORIES
OF. OF A DIFFERENT TREATMENTS
AND THAT WELL. THAT AREN'T.
DIGITIZED AND THERE AREN'T ON
THEY ARE IN THE FILES RIGHT NOW
AND INFORMING WILL STAR SO
THAT'S- THAT'S WHY WE'RE
RUNNING IT NOT. NOT AT SPACE
BEING SLOW OF NEW SUBSTANTIVE
REQUIREMENTS. GET THE PROCESS
TO WORK I THINK IS THE PRIMARY
GOAL. THAT'S THAT THAT PMR
COMMITTEE. OKAY AND SO WHEN YOU
TALK TO US RECENTLY SAID ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF THE WELL SO YOU
HAVE AN OPERATOR. FOR INSTANCE
I'VE AN OPERATOR THAT'S TRYING
TO GET A TRANSFER OF SOMEBODY
WHO'S- GONNA BAN THE WELLS I
MEAN THEY'RE JUST GOING TO BE
ABANDONED AND SOMEBODY'S GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEM BUT
WE HAVE A VIABLE OPERATOR. THAT
WANTS TO TAKE OVER THOSE WELLS
TO MAKE THEM PRODUCTIVE- IN MY
DISTRICT AND THERE'S BEEN A-
HUGE CHALLENGE. TO TRY TO GET
PERMITS TO- TRANSFER
ACQUISITION TO TAKE PLACE. WHEN
WORKING WITH CALDERON CALLE JIM
ON THAT. AND I'M JUST USING HIS
EXAMPLE. THE REASON WHY THERE'S
A PROBLEM IS BECAUSE THE VIABLE
OPERATOR IS NOT WILLING TO TAKE
ON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF WHAT
HAPPENED A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
WITH THIS WELL. CAME THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED NOBODY KNOWS
WHAT HAPPENED. BUT IT WOULD
MAKE THIS NEW VIABLE OPERATOR
RESPONSIBLE. AND SO I GUESS
THERE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF STUFF THAT HAS TO BE
THERE WHEN THERE'S NO. THERE'S
NO WAY. TO TELL WHAT HAPPENED A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO WHEN THINGS
WERE REGULATOR FIFTY. AGO
THINGS AREN'T. THE WAY THEY ARE.
SO THERE'S NO WAY TO PUT IN
FOR. UP BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
EXIST WHAT. KIND OF-
REQUIREMENTS AS YOUR BILL GOING
TO REQUIRE THESE OPERATORS TO
BE OUR PRODUCERS. TO GO BACK
AND- FOR HOW LONG WHAT PERIOD
OF TIME AND RIGHT YOU KNOW
WHAT'S REQUIRED I MEAN IF YOU
AN OPERATOR THAT AT THE END OF
THE WELL AND SOMEBODY TOOK IT
OVER AND TRIED TO FIX IT AND
THEN THEY DID AND THEY RAN IT
FOR AWHILE AND THE BANDIT YOU
KNOW IS GONNA YOU KNOW IT WAS
TRANSFERRED AGAIN. THERE'S GOT
TO BE A POINT IN HISTORY WHERE
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS HAS
HAPPENED TO THESE PARTICULAR.
WELL YES I AGREE AND I THE BILL
DOES NOT FORCE THEM TO
NECESSARILY REACH BACK AND-
DIDN'T GET NEW HISTORY IT'S-
IT'S GETTING THOSE WELL. THE
EXISTING WELL HISTORIES ONLINE
AND MANAGEABLE. BUT I I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU IF. IF THERE'S
SOME IMPLICATION OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY HAVE TO. GO
THROUGH SOME EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES ARE IMPRACTICABLE
EFFORTS OR WHATEVER TO FIND.
I'M HAPPY TO WORK ON THAT
BECAUSE I WAS NOT THE INTENTION
TO. TAKE UP A WHOLE NEW- YET TO
GO DO THE FORENSICS A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO- MORE SO JUST MAKING
PROCESS WITH THAT COMPLETE
YOUR- YOUR QUESTION. YES SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR. LET ME ADD SOMETHING I WAS
WAITING FOR A BREAK IN THE
CONVERSATION. AND THAT IS IT. A
PRIOR INCARNATION- OF THE
THINGS WE DID WHEN IT WAS
DARKER WE BROUGHT IN A STRIKE
TEAM BECAUSE THERE WERE FIFTY
THOUSAND HISTORIC PERMITS. AND
TRY TO DIGITIZE ALL OF THEM.
AND THAT WAS NOT. ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT WAS DONE BY THE
AGENCY THEMSELVES AND HE ONE
THING. IS I HAVE NO IDEA THE
STATUS I HAVE NO IDEA IF THEY
GOT ALL THE WAY THROUGH I KNOW-
PARTWAY THROUGH- IN WHAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. IS IF YOU WOULD
IDENTIFY THAT AND THEN YOU
COULD SPEAK TO YOUR BILL IN
ADDITION TO WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
ALREADY AND IF IT IS BASICALLY.
THAT NOW THINGS WILL BE
SUBMITTED IN A DIGITAL FORMAT
SO THAT THE AGENCY DOESN'T HAVE
TO GO BACK AND DIGITIZED THEM
AFTER THE FACT THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD FACT TO KNOW AS THE BILL
IS MOVING FORWARD AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT. THAT IS THAT'S WHAT
YOU SHOULD DO IN CASE THE BILL
GETS OUT TODAY BEFORE YOU GET
TO YOUR NEXT STOP IN JUST A
POINT OF A CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST A POINT OF CLARIFICATION.
M. AND I APPRECIATE THE TEARS
IMMENSE HISTORY ESPECIALLY AS
BEING THE SECRETARY- IN THE IN
A PREVIOUS LIFE M. SO I
APPRECIATE HIS IMMENSE HISTORY
AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF HIS-
COMMENTS BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC REALLY
DOES UNDERSTAND THAT. IT'S NOT
THE AGENCY THAT PAYS FOR THIS
IT'S INDUSTRY THAT FUNDS THIS
AGENCY THAT PAYS FOR THIS SO
AGAIN IT'S AND IT'S INDUSTRY SO
EVEN IF INDUSTRY DID TAKE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF BILLS OR OF
SACRAMENTO WELLS AND- AND SAY
WE'RE GOING TO FIX THESE IN IT
AND THEN AGENCY PAYS FOR THEM
THE- AGENCY GETS THE FUNDING
FROM PRIVATE INDUSTRY. SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
PURPOSE BY APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH ME I
KNOW WE'VE HAD GREAT
CONVERSATIONS IN THE PAST-
AGAIN I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THE
OIL INDUSTRY JUST REPRESENT THE
LARGEST PORTION OF IT AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS
THAT WE HAVE COMING UP THANK
YOU THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR STERN YOU
MICHAEL. A MIXTURE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
SUGGESTION AND WILL TAKE YOU AT
THAT THE LETTER WE SENT TO
SECRETARY CROWFOOT ACTUALLY
ASKED THAT QUESTION OF STATUS
ON WORLD HISTORY IN COMPILATION
SO. WE SHOULD BE HEARING
HOPEFULLY BACK IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INFORM OUR
EFFORTS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE-
ANYONE WITH A MOTION. THE BILL
WAS MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN. OF
WOULD. YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE S. B.
FOUR OH SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WHERE'D HI. ALL
RIGHT JONES. ALLEN EGGMAN
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI HUESO
LIMóN. SHE'S MUTED A SENATOR
YOU MOAN I READ YOUR LIPS AND
YOU VOTED DIED BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR IT. WOULD LIKE TO
YUP WOULD. DOES SOMEBODY HAVE
TO UN MUTE SENATOR LIMóN OTHER
THAN CENTER LAMONT. IF DR
ALTHOUGH THE SIGN. KEEP TRYING
ONE MORE TIME. YEAH DID THE
CHAIR READ HER LIPS. AND SHE
JUST SAID I VERY DRAMATICALLY.
IT IS CLEARLY CENTERMAN LIMóN
SO WE WILL RECOGNIZE THAT AS AN
AYE VOTE KEEP GOING EASTERN.
STERN HI. K. THEIR FIVE VOTES
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND DON'T MOVE
SENATOR STERN BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FOUR ONE NINE
POINT SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE AND LET ME NOTE TO
THE AUTHOR OF SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR NEXT- SO COMPLICATED
PLEASE PROJECT MR I'LL I'LL BE
AS BRIEF AS I POSSIBLY CAN HERE
AND IN LIGHT OF. THE PENDING A
DISCUSSION ON ON THE NEXT BILL-
FIRST OF ALL SHE THE STAFF'S
WORK ON THIS HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THE
THAT ARE MENTIONED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS AT THIS BILL IS. IS
REALLY ABOUT. THE WORKING
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
RESPECT TO- THE LOCAL ECONOMIES
THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT
HISTORICALLY AND CURRENTLY
AROUND THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY- YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
WRESTLE WITH SOME SOME TOUGH
ISSUES HERE TODAY AND GOING
FORWARD AS WE- AS WE ENGAGE THE
OIL. CONVERSATION AND THE
CLIMATE CONVERSATION MORE
BROADLY BUT- YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT THERE'S- THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO LAND ON A
UNLIKELY CONSENSUS BETWEEN
UNLIKELY PARTNERS- THAT SAYS
THAT. WHEN IT COMES TO THE WORK
WE DO TO MAKE OUR- OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE. SAFER TO CLOSE-
THESE ABANDONED WELLS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT- TO PLUG
THESE IDLE WELLS WHEN THERE
WERE TAKEN OUT OF COMMISSION OR
DESERTED THAT THAT THAT WORK
SHOULD BE DONE BY SKILLED AND
TRAINED- CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
NOT. FROM TURN AROUND JOBS FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE- THEY
DON'T BENEFIT OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES WHEN YOU SEE A-
COMMUTER PLANE COMING IN FROM
TEXAS FILLED WITH OIL AND GAS
WORKERS YOU YOU WONDER IF THAT
REALLY MAKES SENSE- WHEN WE
HAVE. AN INCREDIBLY SKILLED
INDUSTRY WHETHER IT'S A PIPE
FITTER AND ELECTRICIAN OR A
OPERATING ENGINEER- OR EVEN
SOMEONE. COMING OUT OF A HARD
TIME IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION
TRYING TO FIND A BETTER CAREER
FOR THEMSELVES- THERE IS
LEGITIMACY IN THE CLAIM THAT
THERE ARE GOOD JOBS IN IN THIS
SECTOR AND I THINK THIS BILL IS
AN EFFORT. TO REALLY CEMENT
THAT THAT COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
WE HAVE IS A STATE WITH THE
SKILLS WE HAVE AND HOPEFULLY
SETTLE. ON A FEW PRINCIPLES
HERE TO GUIDE US- THROUGH THIS
ROCKY PERIOD IN OUR HISTORY- SO
WITH THAT YOU KNOW THE BILL
DOES APPLY MORE BROADLY- REPAIR
IT SOME INSTALLATION
MAINTENANCE WORK THE PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING SPACE- SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT JUST SOME OF THE DETAILS
BUT- WITH ME I THINK YOU'RE
TODAY HOPEFULLY THE PHONES OF
WORKED- IS. A REPRESENTED FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL
LEVIN- AND- THE PRESIDENT OF
THE TRI COUNTY BUILDING TREAT A
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR STERN. WHEEL WE HAVE
THOSE TOO THE DOWNSIDE IS
LEASED WITNESSES AND I
APOLOGIZE TAMI IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR LAST NAME BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S- A TAMI FIVE
A- FROM IBEW LOCALS ELEVEN AND
THEN WILL HAVE MARTIN RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE TRI COUNTIES BUILDING
AND- CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES BETWEEN
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
WITH TOMMY. FOR A WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU CHAIR
OF CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU JUST FINE. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR- AND THANK
YOU TO SENATOR STERN- FOR BRING
IN THIS- THIS ITEM OR IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
TOMMY CALL BY- I REPRESENT
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL UNION
ELEVEN- AND WE REPRESENT. OUR
LECTURE SHINS THAT ACTUALLY
WORK- INCOMES ISLANDS OVER HERE
AND LONG BEACH- WHICH THE
OPERATOR IS C. R. C. CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION- AND
THESE JOBS. THAT ARE WORKERS
WORK AT- YOU KNOW GAVE
OPPORTUNITY- FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
RECEIVE REALLY WELL BENEFITS.
AND OUR WAGES ARE SO THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES-
WITH THE WITH THE ECONOMY- THE
WAY IT LOOKS NOW- WE'VE BEEN A
CENTRAL WORKERS EVERY SENSE.
AND OUR WORKERS YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING- YOU KNOW TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THROUGH THIS- OF
THIS TRAGEDY YEAH WE HAVE- IN
OUR ECONOMY WHEN IT COMES TO
CALL GOOD NINETEEN. BUT WITH
OUR- WITH OUR WORKERS WORKING
IN THESE- IN THE SHOP
FACILITIES WE KNOW THAT HAVING
THESE GOOD WAGES AND HAVING
THIS- GOOD TRAINING. AND OF
SAFETY ON THE JOB SITE IT'S Q.
FOUR- OUR MEMBERS ARE IN THEIR
PLAN. TO MAKE IT HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES EVERY DAY- OUR WORK TO
THIS DAY OF LIVES- AND THEY TO
KEEP IT THIS WAY. AND WE URGE
THE COULD. AND SOME. OF BLOOD
SB FOUR NINETEEN- TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO MARK
RODRIGUEZ SAID YOU HAVE ABOUT A
MINUTE AND A HALF WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRPERSON. AND DINNER STERN-
YES I APPROVED THIS BILL AND-
AND I SUPPORT IT. MARTIN
RODRIGUEZ TRY COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES PRESIDENT AND- I WORKERS
BUSINESS STATE AND LOCAL FOR
THIRTY THREE. NO AND NOT.
FOURTEEN I WAS INVOLVED WITH UP
PARTNERING WITH C. R. C.
ADDITIONALLY AND STATE BUILDING
TRADES SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE THAT THEY PROVIDE
ALONG WITH INCORPORATING AN
EXISTING WORK FORCE BY UTILIZED
IN OUR TRAINING FACILITIES AND
METHODS AND MEANS ROCK FROM
YEARS OF TRAINING AND SAFETY
CURRICULUM THE WORKERS THAT
WERE BROUGHT INTO THE FOLD.
THEY WERE GIVEN A VOICE AND
ACCESS TO BENEFITS AND WAGES
NOT ROUTINELY AVAILABLE HE HAD
BEEN A IT WAS ELIMINATE IN A
TRANSIT OUT OF STATE WORKFORCE
AND PROVIDING JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
A LOT OF OUR- LOW- WORKERS- MY
NOT HAVE HAD A CHANCE. AND
RETAIN OUR LOCAL TAX BASE YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE COMPUTER
COMMUTER PLANE COMING IN WITH A
BUNCH OF- WORK IS NOT A STATE-
BUT IN REALITY- THERE'S A LINE
OF CARS COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE IT UP WE SAT IN FRONT OF
THE REFINERIES DOCUMENT AND
THIS WILL WITH PITCHERS AND- IT
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING THIS
THING HAPPEN BUT YOU HAVE NO
IDEA JUST HOW BIG THE WORKFORCE
PROBLEMS OR USED TO COME IN.
AND GO TAKE THE WAGES AND YOUR
TAX BASE WITH THEM IT STILL
HAPPENED A LOT OF WAYS IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES BUT- YEAH I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. BUT NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO ME TO USE JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. AND WE'RE GOING TO
START IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM SO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN THE- PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF
MEMBERS ON THE PHONE LINES YOU
CAN'T GET THROUGH- ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER SCOTT WHICH ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL THE STATUS OF SEASON
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SURE THE
MEMBERS MONEY JUST BROTHERS
CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE FIFTY TO
REPRESENT A COUNTRY BY THE
COUNTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S CURTIS DAY MEMBER
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
LOCAL TWELVE EXTENDED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BRONER LET
REPRESENTING CARPENTERS LOCAL
ONE EIGHTY OTHER SOLANO COUNTY
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. CHARLIE
RIVALRY WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE AT SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN MATTEO AND
STRETCHING TRADES COUNCIL
STANDING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FAT BILL FOR NINETEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING JOHN
TWEED DISCOUNTS SIXTEEN GLAZERS
LOCAL SEVEN SIX SEVEN WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING RENDON DISCUSSES
SIXTEEN ENTERS LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN NAME IS
TOM EIGHT NAMAN BUSINESS A
BUSINESS AGENT FOR PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AND WE STAND AS TRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS AUGIE BELL TRAN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SORRY YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
GOT TECH SOMEBODY COULDN'T GET
THROUGH THE TEAMSTERS- ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE
YOU SPEAKING UP FOR THEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE PEOPLE
LINED UP WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL. TRAHERNE
SAID IRONWORKERS LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. WHY IT MATTERS
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
WHERE SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BETUL BETUL IRON
WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN WE
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. JASON LINDSEY IRONWORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING KEN MILLER LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING INDRA
MEREDITH NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
CHUCK LETTERED UP THE STEEP
VOTERS LOCAL THREE FORTY TWO I
STAND IN SOLIDARITY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL DROWNING WE STAND I
SOLIDARITY WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL. WHERE WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SAYING NO ONE ELSE OF MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINE AND
WE WILL TAKE ME TO SUGGEST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IN
SUPPORT AND LET ME JUST
EMPHASIZE FOR EVERYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE THIS IS ONLY ABOUT
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETEEN.
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETEEN THANK
YOU AND IF. IF YOU KNOW THAT
PEOPLE CAN'T GET IN AND YOU CAN
REPRESENT FOR MORE THAN ONE
ENTITY YOU'RE WELCOME TO DO
THAT IN YOUR METERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THE
SPOKESPERSON ONE AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE WELL ONE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FOR PERSONAL LOAN.
TWENTY FOUR TO ON THE CRITICAL.
FOR ADDITIONAL PER. YEAH A
MANAGEMENT REPORT BONTA CHIU
STAR ABOUT VERONICA YOU'RE
BROADCASTING LIFE TO THE
UNIVERSE AND IT'S PROBABLY NOT
WORTH CONTINUING YOUR
CONVERSATION MODERATOR ME TOOS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINETEEN
COULD. THE LINE NUMBER. TWO TWO
FOUR. DON'T GET. MY NAME IS
WILLIAM. GLIMMERS OF TEAM LOCAL
COURSE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE B. ONE NINE. OKAY THANK YOU-
MUSKET. NEXT TO GO LINE THEM TO
A SO PLEASE CALL. MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COULD ABOUT MY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTEENTH MEMBER OF THE
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DESCRIPTION THEY'RE GOING
CONNECT YOUR LINE ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH THE
L. YEAH. HELLO YOU KNOW. I ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT ONE OF A ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HELLO IBEW
LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED ONE
TWO OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MY NAME STATE
OPERA LAURA ALONG WITH PLUMBERS
LOCAL SEVEN SIXTY ON AND WERE
IMPOSED REPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS GOODBYE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE WE STAND
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. EXHORT ONE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JANE BOSTON BUSINESS
MANAGER OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FORTY FOUR WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. S.
B. RO FOUR NINETEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEXICO LINE NUMBER
THREE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
BUT. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
SPAULDING AT MISSISQUOI COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND WE
STAND IT STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXTCODE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
OH THREE ZERO COULD. SORRY THIS
IS THE INTEREST LOCAL SIXTEEN
COST INSULATORS WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE ONE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. INTERPOL FROM
SHEET METAL WORKERS LOCAL 105%
OF THE BILL ENTERED THE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU HAVE ONE THREE
HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO TERRIBLE REMINDED SPELLED
OUT OF THE PARK RESULT ONE
EIGHTY AT A SOLANO COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
NINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
ONE NUMBER THREE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NAY FAIRMAN
FROM IDW FOR SIXTY FIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS STEVEN
GOMEZ I'M BASIS MANAGER
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOR SIXTY IN KERN COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOUR NINETEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT ONE NUMBER ONE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN A CIVIL
WAR LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON OF THE CRIMINAL
OTHERS IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK TO YOU
IN A MOMENT. IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM BECAUSE WE
ARE NOW MOVING TO OPPOSITION TO
SUCH SENATE BILL FOUR ONE NINE.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO ONE
MODERATOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL FOUR ONE NINE BY
SENATOR STERN- ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESENT ONE CAN-LEGITIMATELY DO WANNA HAVE
OPPOSITION AS HE FOUR NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE WHAT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MASAKA WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO EXPRESS
SOME CONCERNS ON ITS BILLS WERE
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE-
ONSTAGE AMENDMENTS BUT JUST
QUICKLY WE'RE HOPING THAT WE
CAN TAKE AMENDMENTS HAT WELL
NOW THIS IS. THIS IS JUST A ME
TOO SO I AM GOING TO ASSUME
THAT YOU. ARE YOU WANT
AMENDMENTS PROPOSE OR. WITH THE
REQUEST FOR AMENDMENTS. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATE OR ANYONE
ELSE. YES WITH A LINE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER ONE NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RADHIKA WILSON HOLDEN- SB FOUR
ONE NINE AND CAL AMENDMENT CAN
BE- THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN LAYS GENERATIVE
OPPOSITION SP FOUR ONE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MATURE PERSON WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR SIT IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG
ENGLISH CHAIR- SENATOR STERN
AYE AYE I WOULD LIKE IN THE
MOST- INSIGHTFUL WAY TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE INTEGRATION.
BETWEEN THIS MEASURE FILE IN
REPORT AND FOUND FIVE WHICH YOU
SUPPORT SUPPORT LAST YEAR IF IN
pBECAUSE I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY RELATE. IF
IN FACT THE IDEA HERE IS
SKILLED AND TRAINED AND F. AND
I LOOKED AT THE LIST HERE AND
AS I WAS TRYING TO FOLLOW ALONG
ALMOST EVERYBODY IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR MEASURE FOUR ONE NINE AS
OPPOSED TO THE NEXT MEASURE. OF
SENATOR WIENER'S AND SO MY
QUESTION IS. IT IN YOUR
DEADLINE DATES HERE ON THE
AMENDMENTS AMENDMENT ONE PAGE
OF FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS TALKS
ABOUT. APPLIES TO CONTRACTS ON
OR AFTER JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT SAME DATE
APPEARS AND IT WAS AMENDED BY
PEERS IN THE OTHER MEASURE. AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
FROM YOUR POINT OF VIEW YOU CAN
WORK ON THIS LONGER THAN I HAVE
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND
I'D LOVE TO JUST SURE GET YOUR
SUCH THOUGHTS ON THAT. IF YOU
WOULD IF YOU SHARE WITH US
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR- I'M LOOKING AT THE
TIMELINE YOU MENTION HERE. YET.
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY ONE- HOW THE
TIME LINES WOULD LINE UP I
DON'T EXACTLY KNOW WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS GOING TO PRESENT
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THEIR
INTENTIONS ON TIME FRAME- I
THINK THAT MAY BE. BEING
PROPOSED TO I DON'T I DON'T TO
GET AHEAD OF THE AUTHOR BUT-
FOR WHATEVER TIME FRAME WERE
PUT ON HERE. BUT WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S OUR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THE MOST SKILLED
SAFEST WORKING CONDITIONS WE
CAN HAVE- SO I GUESS THAT'S THE
SPACE THIS BILL TRYING TO FILL
WHILE THE WHILE THE BROADER
DEBATE GOES ON OKAY THANK YOU
SIR VERY MUCH APPRECIATE. THAT
NOTHING FOR THEM STRIP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER MEMBERS
YES CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT FIRST BY
PUSHING THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU AND I HAVE HAD OFFLINE I DO
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO-
STORIES. I GUESS ABOUT- MY
DISTRICT AND THE JOBS THAT ARE
AFFECTED. BY LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS I KNOW THAT- THEY WERE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF- SIGNATORY
COMPANIES ORGANIZATIONS UNION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAME FORWARD
AND SAID. THIS WOULD BE GREAT
AND WHEN THEY DID IT WITH C. OR
C. IT WAS GREAT WITH HIM IT WAS
GREAT FOR THEM. BUT IT WAS A
GREAT FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE LOCAL PEOPLE.
THAT LOST THEIR JOBS MY
CONSTITUENTS. THE WILDER PER SE
THAT HAD WORKED THERE FOR FORTY
YEARS. TAKE A WELDER IN IT THAT
WORKS AT CHEVRON UNDER
CONTRACTOR NOW AND I'M JUST
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A
CONTRACTOR THAT HAS SEVEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
THE OIL FIELDS- IN. A WELDER
THAT HIS MOTHER WAS CUT TO FIT
PAINT TO MATCH. THIS CONTRACTOR
HAS ONE OF THE LOWEST MODERATES
IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE SAFEST
CONTRACTORS YOU CAN HAVE IN THE
OIL FIELDS BUT THEY'RE NOT
SIGNATORY THEY'RE NOT UNION-
WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHAT HAPPENS TO. THE
JERRY FLORES WHO SPENT TIME IN
PELICAN BAY PRISON. A CAME OUT
IN WORKS FOR AN OIL INDUSTRY
CONTRACTOR AND OIL INDUSTRY
CONTRACTOR. AND HE JUST BOUGHT
HIS FIRST TIME IN THE SUN IS
THE FIRST PERSON IN HIS FAMILY
THAT'S GONE TO- COLLEGE.
EVERYBODY ELSE'S BEEN ON- HIGH
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE IN
THE SENATE'S FIRST WIN. AT THIS
INDIVIDUALS A MEMBER OF HIS PTA
MEETING HE'S GOT TATTOOS
EVERYWHERE- HE'S CHANGES LIFE
BECAUSE IT WILL INDUSTRIES
AFFORDED HIM THAT OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CRANE
OPERATORS THAT ALL SIMILAR TO
WHAT HAPPENED AT SEARS SEED
THEY LOST THEIR JOB. BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAD WORKED IN
THE INDUSTRY FOR YEARS AND THEY
WERE ALL LOCAL LIVING IN KERN
COUNTY LIVING IN BAKER SMELLED.
AND DIDN'T COME IN FROM TEXAS
AND THEY CAN COME IN FROM ANY
OTHER STATE THEY LIVED. MOST OF
THEM STARTED THERE WHEN THEY
WERE TEENAGERS. A BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE- CARD IN THEIR
WALLET AND THEY SAID THEY WERE
PART OF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE OR AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM ON ANY OF THEM UNION
SAID SPOKE UP TODAY. M. AND I'M
NOT PICKING ON THE INSIDE
THINK. EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A JOB
WHETHER YOU'RE SIGNATORY OR NOT
SIGNATORY. THERE ARE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
THAT INCLUDES GETTING PLAYED IN
THE KERN COUNTY OIL FIELDS THAT
ARE- THAT HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. BECAUSE THEY COME
FROM PRISON SYSTEMS THEY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON WE'D
CRUISE AND THEN GO UP TO- PLC
BOARDS ARE WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS OR- WELDERS WELDERS
HELPERS CRANE OPERATORS THEY
CAN. THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROMOTE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
NEED A COLLEGE DEGREE ANY
SPECIFIC EDUCATION. WHAT
HAPPENS TO ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CURRENT AND EXISTING.
BECAUSE WHEN C. OR C. HAPPENED
THOSE CONTRACTORS. WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO EVEN GET A SEPARATE AND
CREATE A UNION COMPANY EMPLOYEE
UNION THEY HAD TO GO BACK
THROUGH THE LABOR HALL OR TWO
THROUGH THE HALL WHATEVER CALL
IT WAS. AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE SENIORITY THAT OTHER. A
UNION PEOPLE DID. SO THEY ALL
LOST THEIR JOBS AND A LOT OF
THEM WENT TO TEXAS AND OTHER
PLACES SO THAT THEY COULD
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL
THESE LOCAL PEOPLE THAT ALREADY
HAVE THESE JOBS I MEAN IF THE
CONTRACTOR IS WILLING TO PAY
THE PREVAILING WAGE AND OFFER
BENEFITS WHICH- THEY OFFER
BENEFITS NOW BUT THEY DON'T PAY
PREVAILING WAGE. IS THERE AN
EGG AN EXCEPTION OR EXEMPTION
THERE. WHAT HAPPENS TO HAVE OUR
CABLE HOOD WHO HAS HIS OWN-
TWELVE LITTLE WELLS THAT HE
OPERATES IN HIS SON AND HIS
THREE EMPLOYEES IN HIS GRANDSON
OPERATE THAT. OF SO WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS TO MY LOCAL COMMUNITY.
WHEN YOUR BILL PASS. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER EIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENT AND YOUR
FLUENCY IN. THE PEOPLE YOU
SERVE IT. YOU KNOW THEM BY NAME
AND YOU KNOW THEIR WORK
CLOSELY- THE FOCUS THIS BILL
WAS. WAS ABOUT A BROADER TREND
WE'RE SEEING IN TURN AROUND
JOBS IN THE MIDSTREAM SERVICES
SECTOR THAT WAS SORT OF MY
INITIAL CONCERN. ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION- BUT AS FOR SORT OF
THE LOCAL IMPACT FOR HOWARD I
SEE OUR C. TYPE PARTNERSHIP
WOULD PLAY OUT IF THAT WERE
SCALED- I HAVEN'T BEEN THROUGH
ONE OF THOSE MYSELF I KNOW
THAT. WE DID HAVE PEOPLE- I
THINK OUR I. B. W. ELEVEN LEAD
WITNESS WENT THROUGH THAT OR
WHICH PART OF ONE OF THOSE
DEALS THAT THE THUMBS WORKER I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT IS IT
ALRIGHT IF I. ASK JUST FOR SOME
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW THEY SEE IT
PLAYING OUT GOOD FOR SOMEBODY'S
GOING THROUGH IT SENATE RIGHT
ABSOLUTELY DID YOU MY MISTER
JUST WHAT. WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATED I APPRECIATE THIS
DEBATE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WHAT
WE HAVE THE MAIN EVENT COMING
UP AND WE ARE TRYING TO GET TO
SUGGESTED IT TO THE EXTENT YOU
GUYS CAN DISCIPLINE YOURSELF
AND- GETTING TO THE END OF THIS
HOWEVER YOU DO IT I'D
APPRECIATE IT HI I AM READY TO
BE DISCIPLINE MISTER CHAIR YOU
YOU GO GO RIGHT AHEAD IF YOU'D
LIKE I'LL JUST KEEP GOING TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION. AND DO
YOUR BEST BUT I MEAN I JUST
WANT EVERYBODY TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE THE
HEARING. I UNDERSTAND- ONE
MINUTE I GUESS OUR LEGAL. IF IT
IS BRIEF AS YOU CAN- AT THE
THAT WAS MISTER A PROVIDE. IF
HE'S NOT AVAILABLE FOR ANY OF
YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION. WELL I'M NOT
AWARE OF THIS BILL IS GETTING
OUT IN THE NEXT BILL'S PRICE
TAG THIS WEEK ON THAT I'M THE
BUILDING TRADES PRESIDENT OF
THE TRI COUNTY YOU KNOW MY JUST
BEING JUST A QUICK COMMENT-
BAGLEY'S THAT MAKE YOUR
OBSERVATION. THAT WOULD. THAT
WAS NOT THE CASE. ONE THE ARTS
THE THAT WAS THE WAY LOST THEIR
JOBS- WE'D I WAS THERE AT THE
UNION HALL TO WIN- WE BROUGHT.
UP ALL OF THEIR WORKERS THAT
WERE PRIOR. UP WORKING IN
REFINERIES WENT RIGHT BACK TO
THE SAME JOB WE ORGANIZED. IN
MELTED THEM INTO OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS. AS AS WELL AS- ANY
ANYTHING THEY WERE DEFICIENT
IN. WE PUT HIM IN OUR TRADE
TRAINING PROGRAMS BRING THEM UP
TO SPEED BUT THAT WAS
DEFINITELY NOT THE CASE. THERE
WAS NO MASS EXODUS. OF LOCAL
LABOR- I CAN GIVE YOU THE-
NAMES ALSO OUTSOLD THE- PEOPLE
READ- I WORK WITH THEM
SPECIFICALLY. AND THEIR WORK
AND- NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE OLD BILL
AS WELL. THEY HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE OFFER OUT
BY THAT'LL FEEL. SO YOU WERE
MISTAKEN IN SOME WAYS- MS
GROSS. NOT BEING THIS RESPECT
WHEN ANYWAYS BUT- MAYBE
MISGUIDED BY THE MONEY
CONSTITUENTS THAT PUT THAT OUT
THERE. SMALL COMPANIES SMALL
CONTRACTORS AS WELL. BY MYSELF
ORGANIZE THEM. AND THEY'RE
DOING THE SAME THING. THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO SAY ON THAT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER'S. 323-816-7411
YOU WANT TO CALL ME. THANK YOU
VERY. ANY QUESTION SENATOR GROW
AND I AM GETTING I SUSPECT
OTHER P. MIGHT THEM NOW. I WILL
YOU A CALL ON THIS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I LIVE THROUGH IT- I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN THAT TOOK
PLACE. AND I TOOK THOUSANDS OF
PHONE CALLS THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS SO YOU
GUYS MAY HAVE BROUGHT BACK A
FEW- BUT I COULD RATTLE OFF ALL
THOSE NAMES AS WELL. AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WILL HAVE MOVING FORWARD I
REALLY DO HOPE YOU ARE SINCERE
IN MAKING SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO. I'M A LARGE
PORTION OF MY DISTRICT IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR STERN YOU
MAY CLOSE AT THE MISTER CHAIR
AND- THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
AND- I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
DIGGING IN AND- SHOT WILLING.
GETTING OUT TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND YOU KNOW ACTUALLY.
GET IN THERE IN PERSON TO SO-
YEAH YEAH MY COMMITMENT I'M I'M
LOOKING FOR TO GET THE FINAL
SHOT IN THE IN A NORMAL PLACE
AGAIN SOON SO. WE'LL BE. WE'LL
GET TO WORK IN RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL IN THE MEANTIME. GREAT TO
IS THERE ARE. MOVED BY SO
HERTZBERG WE PLAY CALL THE- BY
LAW FOR A B. FOR NINETY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A BUT
FIRST. TO THE- COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND RE. LET ON THERE ARE
JOE NO JONES NO OUR- EGGMAN.
EGGMAN ONLINE GROWTH GROVE NO
ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG HI HUESO
LIMóN. LEMOND'S BACK IN EARLY
MOUNT LAURIE STERN JANET STERN
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE FIVE VOTES
WE WILL PUT THAT ON CALL. R. AS
WE GET READY TO MOVE TO US
SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY SEVEN LET
ME JUST MAKE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SAN RAMON LEFT
AGAIN BUT IT'S HER VOTE WAS NOT
PROPERLY RECORDED WHEN SHE
COULD. NOT BE ON MUTED SO SHE
WILL BE LISTED. AS NOT VOTING
AND THEN BE ABLE TO VOTE WHEN
THE CALL WAS LIFTED ON THAT.
ITEM AS A SENATOR OUR WINNER
MOVES TO THE PODIUM ON S.
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN LET ME JUST
MAKE A FEW PROCESS COMMENTS. WE
WERE TECHNICALLY SCHEDULED TO
AND ELEVEN THIRTY WE HAVE BEEN
GIVEN PERMISSION TO GO PAST
THAT SO WE WILL. IT IS OUR HOPE
BECAUSE WE COULD GO WE HAVE THE
ROOM UNTIL AT LEAST ONE AND A
CENTER HERTZBERG HAS A TIME
CONSIDERATION FOR HIS BILL
AFTER THIS IT HAS TO GET OUT
TODAY TO DO THE DO REFERRAL. SO
IT IS GOING TO BE OUR ATTEMPTS
TO FINISH THE AGENDA. AND THEN
SECONDLY AS I HAVE ANNOUNCED-
WE KEEP ADDING MORE LINES AND
THEY KEEP FILLING UP RIGHT AWAY
FOR THE TELECONFERENCE SO LET
ME JUST SAY THAT. IF YOU WERE
ON THE LINE FOR THE PREVIOUS
BILL AND YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED
REMAINING IN THE HEARING GET
OFF THE LINE AND CREATE A SPACE
FOR OTHER PEOPLE. AND
ADDITIONALLY WE ONLY HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR THE ME TOOS
ON EACH SIDE AND MY SUSPICION
IS WILL GO TO THE MAX IF ANY OF
YOU ARE LISTENING TO THIS AND
YOU CAN'T GET IN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE BUT YOU
HAVE FRIENDS THAT ARE IN. MAKE
SURE THAT YOU TAX THEM FOR YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THEY CAN DO ME
TO SIT IN ONE PHONE CALL. AND
EVEN IF WE GO TO THE MAX AND
THERE'S STILL PEOPLE WAITING
THAT WE DON'T GET TO YOU CAN
RECORD YOUR POSITIONS WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND LETTERS AFTER THE
MEETING SO I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING OUR BEST
TO ACCOMMODATE EVERYBODY. AND
WE'LL BE DOING OUR BEST TO TAKE
YOUR OPINION REGARDLESS. IF YOU
CAN GET IN ON THE TIME LIMITED
TIME FOR THE ME TOOS WITH THAT
WE WILL MOVE TO SENATE BILL FOR
SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM. FIVE
SENATOR WINNER WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES AND I WANNA. REALLY
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US FOR. MONTHS ON THE ROLE
IN HELPING US MAKE A- IS GOOD A
BILL AS IT CAN BE- ON I WANT TO
JUST ALSO KNOWLEDGE ARMOR JUST
MENTION AS I THINK SUCH A
CENTERS FIRST. REFERRED TO
EARLIER- WE DO HAVE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE AUTHOR AMENDMENTS AT
THE COMMITTEE WAS KIND ENOUGH.
TO ALLOW US TO SUBMIT- LEE AND
THEY ARE FULLY DESCRIBED IN
THE- COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OF
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR
THAT- AND FOR THE BULK OF THE
EXTRACTION. PHASE OUT- IT'S A
LEASE. THAT TO TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE ON THE THIRTEEN YEAR BY
THE WAY AND THAT WAS BASED ON
NEW DATA. THAT CAME OUT- DATA
IN TERMS OF EXTRACTION HAS BEEN
A LITTLE SKETCHY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT WE GOT SOME
NEW DATA. AND SO WE MADE
REVISIONS AND A BILL TO ALLOW
FOR. A LENGTHY TRANSITION
PERIOD. SO COLLEAGUES- SB FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN I KNOWLEDGE THIS IS
IT'S A BIG BILL- AND IT'S TOUGH
BUILT. ON ONE LEVEL. IT'S TOUGH
FOR MORE LEVEL IT ISN'T- THAT'S
FOUR SIXTY SO. WILL HELP JUMP
BECOME. OF HAL AND WHEN.
CALIFORNIA WILL PHASE OUT- WILL
EXTRACTION IN THE STATE. OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME. THE BILL
FOCUSES ON SOME OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE- DOES MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FORMS OF THE BOIL
EXTRACTION. IN HAND STE
EXTRACTION TECHNIQUES- THAT
HAVE SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
AND NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH IMPACTS INCLUDING
HARMING THE HEALTH OF FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR CHILDREN-
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN ALSO
REQUIRES- A BUFFER ZONE OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FEET-
AROUND WHERE PEOPLE LIVE GO TO
SCHOOL WHERE KIDS ARE PLAYING
ON PLAYGROUNDS SENSITIVE AREAS-
WE'RE FRANKLY WE SHOULD NOT. BE
DRILLING- AND FINALLY TEST
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN. WILL DIRECT
THE STATE TO IDENTIFY FORMER
OIL WORKERS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS- AND INCENTIVIZE WILL WELL
REMEDIATION CONTRACTORS TO HIRE
THOSE WORKERS- AND I THINK THIS
DOVETAILS WITH THE PASSED BILL
AS I THINK WAS REFERENCE
BEFORE- THAT THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT ENORMOUS
AMOUNT. OF INFRASTRUCTURE
CAPITAL WORK THAT HAS TO HAPPEN
TO PLUG REMEDIATE OILFIELDS
ORPHAN WELLS- AND THOSE SHOULD
BE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE AND I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT PASSED. A
BILL. BECAUSE WE NEED TO REALLY-
BE BLIND HERE. IN CALIFORNIA-
WE VIEW OURSELVES. AS A GLOBAL
LEADER ON HERE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND CLIMATE ACTION.
AND IN MANY WAYS WE ARE THIS
STATE HAS DONE GREAT WORK ON
CLIMB IN SO MANY WAYS BUT NOT
UNIVERSALLY. AND THERE IS A
LARGE STAIN ON CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE RECORD AND THAT IS
WHILE. WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST OIL EXTRACTION STATES
KERN COUNTY IS THE SEVENTH
LARGEST OIL PRODUCING COUNTY IN
THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES.
BANKER COUNTY PRODUCES 3% OF
TOTAL US OIL. PRICES SOMETIMES
CALIFORNIA IS VIEWED AS LIKE
THE OPPOSITE OF FAIR TAXES ON
THIS WE REALLY ARE NOT. AND NOT
ONLY- OUR PRODUCTION NUMBERS
QUITE LARGE- IN CERTAIN AREAS
BUT WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY
MAJOR OIL PRODUCING STATES
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE MANDATORY
BUFFER ZONE OR DISTANCE BETWEEN
A HOME OR A SCHOOL AND AN
ACTIVE WELL. TEXAS HAS ONE.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT. THEN OF
THE OIL THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
STILL EXTRACT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN CALIFORNIA THE QUALITY
OF THAT OIL HAS DECREASED TO
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT EXTENT. THAT
WE ARE NOW ON PAR WITH THE
DIRTIEST SANDS. OIL FIELDS IN
CANADA. DOTTORE CALIFORNIA IS.
SO TO SUGGEST AS SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
IS SOMEHOW A MODEL OF SAFE AND
CLEAN OIL EXTRACTION IT'S
SIMPLY NOT THE CASE IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT WE EXTRACT AND WHERE WE
EXTRACTED NEAR WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE NEAR WHERE KIDS ARE GOING
TO SCHOOL. THESE ENHANCED
DRILLING TECHNIQUES SUCH AS
FRACKING OR LINKED TO PRENATAL
COMPLICATIONS CHILDHOOD ILLNESS
INCREASED RATES OF ASTHMA AND
RESPIRATORY DISEASE. AND
UNSURPRISINGLY HIGHER RATES OF
CANCER. THE HUMAN IMPACT OF
THESE ACTIONS ARE NOT JUST A
LIST OF SYMPTOMS. OVER TWO
MILLION PEOPLE OVER TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED FEET OF AN ACTIVE
OIL WEALTH IN OUR STATE. OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF INACTIVE OIL
WEALTH MOST OF WHOM ARE LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR. THOSE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CANNOT LIVE A NORMAL LIFE. A
HEALTHY LIFE NEAR AN OIL WELL
TEN LET'S BE CLEAR THIS IS
ABOUT CLIMATE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BUT IT IS ALSO ABOUT RACIAL
JUSTICE BECAUSE WE KNOW WHO IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIVING NEAR
THESE WELLS. PLEASE
CALIFORNIANS ARE REMINDED EVERY
DAY OF THE CHOICES THAT FOSSIL
FUEL COMPANIES MAKE TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR PROFITS. AND HEY'RE
LIVING IN THESE ARE FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LIVING OUT.
THE POTENTIAL OIL SPILLS AS
WE'VE SEEN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE FROM BOTH FOR PRODUCTION
AND REFINING- THE INTENSE
INCREASING AIR POLLUTANTS AND
NOISE AND LIGHT POLLUTION
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT. AT CETERA
THEY'RE ALL CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT
IN OF THEMSELVES BUT THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION IS
NOT HAPPENING IN A VACUUM IT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. ALMOST
LITERALLY IN PEOPLE'S BACKYARDS.
WHEN IT COMES TO OIL CALIFORNIA
IS FAR FROM BEING A LEADER ON
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATION AND SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN OFFERS US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT OUR
COURSE AND PUT US ON A TRACK TO
BE A GLOBAL LEADER AND HOW WE
APPROACH. OIL HOW DO I SAY
BECAUSE WE I KNOW THIS IS A BIG
BILL AND I THAT I'VE EXPRESSED
A DIFFERENT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE HAD
FLEXIBILITY ON THIS BILL FROM
THE BEGINNING THIS BILL IS A
CONVERSATION WE KNOW THAT IF
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY-
AND IF IT MOVES FORWARD IN THE
LEISLATURE. IT WILL BE A
CONVERSATION TO BRING PEOPLE TO
THE TABLE IN CONECTION WITH
THE LAST BILL. AND SENATOR THE
MOANS BILLS ETCETERA. ABOUT HOW
DO WE APPROACH WILL BIG PICTURE
GOING FORWARD. WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A LONG AND A GRADUAL
TRANSITION IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
OVERNIGHT WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
PROPOSES AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT A
TIME LINE. IN TERMS OF THIS
INDUSTRY. WE WILL SEE IF I CAN
GET KICKED DOWN THE ROAD OVER
AND OVER EVEN AS THE WHEEL AND
THE STREET NATURALLY DECLINES.
LOOK AT THE COAL INDUSTRY. WE
DIDN'T ACT WE DIDN'T ACT WE
DIDN'T ACT AND LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THE INDUSTRY. AND
THE PROBLEMS THAT THAT HAS
CAUSED IN COMMUNITIES. WE
SHOULD THE SHOULD BE
FACILITATED PROCESS. WHERE WE
LOOK OUT FOR THE WORKERS AND WE
COME UP WITH A STRONG
TRANSITION PLAN. THAT'S BEFORE
SIXTY SEVEN STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE BUFFER
ZONE. A LIMITING FACTOR
ELIMINATING FRACKING QUICKLY
AND THEN HAVING A GRADUAL PHASE
OUT. THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
WITH ME TODAY- AS OUR LEAD
WITNESSES- JUST ONE LEAD
WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN JUAN
FLORES WHO IS A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT. WE
ALSO HAVE ON THE LINE FOR
TECHNICAL RESPONSES IF THEY
COME UP- BUT NOT AS A
TESTIFYING WITNESS STAND RATS
WHO IS A STAFF ATTORNEY. AT THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND LET ME JUST CLARIFY BECAUSE
I HAD TO LEAD WITNESSES LISTED
YOU JUST HAVE ONE NOW VIRGINIA
CRIME. WORK ONE ON STANDBY IF
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OKAY- THEN
WE WILL MOVE TO JUAN FLORES
FROM THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY
AND ENVIRONMENT YOU HAVE UP TO
THREE MINUTES. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
WOEFULLY AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
THE LEGAL HEARING COMPOUND. THE
FATHER OF THE VERY CHILDREN
SEVEN MONTHS OLD SOCIAL INTO
YOUR BEAUTIFUL PENELOPE. WHEN I
MIGRATED TO CALIFORNIA I CAME
HERE WITH HOPES AND DREAMS OF
LIVING IN A BETTER LIGHT IN
SOME WAYS CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
THOSE HOPES. BUT I HAVE SEEN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO BURKE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BECAUSE TO
THEM- I HAVE ZERO TWO MINUTES
FOR TO CALL REPORTER QUALITY.
HELLO WATER AND DIRTY SO IT. I
HAVE SEEN MY NOTEBOOK NEIGHBORS
WE ENDED TO. ASTHMA. INDUSTRY
TALK SICK PROFIT MARGINS. THANK
CALIFORNIA FALLING BEHIND ALL
THE STATE. FARM HELP AND GAS
SETBACK. THAT HAVE BEEN
TRACKING. SETTING FORTH THE
REGULAR. ONLY AN OLDER LIKE.
THAT HAVE ALREADY MADE THE
PLANTS MANAGE DECLINE OVER FOR
YOUR CONDUCT STRUCTURE. IN
RESPONSE TO CRIME CARD. IT
SHOULD PUT IT EQUITY OVER THE
NATIONAL. MY DAUGHTER PENELOPE
MY OLDEST WAS BORN PREMATURELY
ALMOST A MONTH BEFORE HER DUE
DATE WHEN I FIRST TOLD MY
DAUGHTER IN MY ARMS BUT MY WIFE
RECOVER FROM SURGERY I TOLD HER
HOW MUCH I HOW MUCH I LOVE HER.
HOW MUCH SHE WAS LOVED BY HER
ENTIRE FAMILY. HOW MUCH WILL
THAT BE PREDATE I WAS GOING TO
UP FIGHT BUT SHE ACHIEVE
EVERYONE FOR JOINING. THOMAS
SORT THE BILL NOT BE A C. DAY
BUT HER. AND WELL BE OR NOT MY
PERSONAL. BUT BY. I THAT I WILL
NOT BE TO PULL MY FROM. I ASKED.
OKAY I PROMISED MY DAUGHTER
HELP ONE MORE DINNER DOLLAR IN.
HAVE SPENDING SMOKING.
COMMONSENSE REGULAR. BATTLE
KEEPS SERVER. WE PARENTS OF
CHILDREN IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY THANK OF COLOR. NO
NOT FROM FROM OUR GOVERNMENT.
TOTAL PLAY FEEL ONE COME FROM
YOUR SHOOT MIGHT BE BRIGHTER
FUTURE. DEAR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M NOT I'M YOU TO PAY FOR MY
FUTURE. I MUST YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BEFORE SIXTY. THE BAND THE
MOST DANGEROUS DRIVEN.
INCLUDING NAY THREE. ESTATE IT
MIGHT WIFE AND I DO. A LOT CHIU.
INTO MILLION OF CHIU A LONG
COULD. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THIRTY TO HELP THEM PEARL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCHFOR YOUR TEST. ARE WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SECTION OF ME TOOS WE HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE.
FIFTY NOW FOR PROS WE'LL GET TO
FIFTEEN IN OPPOSITION AND IT IS
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
PEOPLE LISTENING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LAW AND IF YOU
CAN'T GET IT AND THEN YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE PEOPLE ON THE LINE
FEEL FREE TO TAX THEM YOUR
INFORMATION AS WELL- THEN WE
WILL BEGIN- THE ME TOO SINCE
SUPPORT. IN THE HEARING ROOM
SIR ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO DO
THAT IN THIS HEARING. SEEING
NONE WERE MOVED TO A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WISHES TO OFFER. A SUPPORT
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE THE MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE THIS
IS- ME TO SUPPORT NAME-
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION FOR
S. B. FOUR SIX SEVEN MODERATOR.
THANK GOODNESS RICHARD TODAY-
YOU CAN ADD IN A FEW SUPPORTERS
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IN ON
THE PHONES. WHAT DO YOU MEAN.
IS THAT WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT ABOUT NOW HUNDREDS
OF SUPPORTERS ATTENDING COLIN
NOT LIST. MANY OF HOMELESSNESS
AND NOW SINCE YOU CAN'T GET
THROUGH. WONDERING IF I CAN.
THAT'S WHAT I JUST SAID IF
SOMEBODY WISHES TO LIST
ADDITIONAL ONES IN ADDITION TO
YOURSELF PLEASE DO IT AS THIS
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
EFFICIENT WITH THE TIME. SO
OPEN IT UP WHAT'S GO. THANK YOU
MISTER PERSON A PERSON'S GONNA
COME FROM MY NUMBER TWO ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER TWO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GO TO THE NEXT ONE
WATER LINE AND- THANK YOU MY
NUMBER THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KATHLEEN EVAN
I'M CALLING FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW DEAL
COALITION AND S. AND- TWO FIFTY
DAIRY ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. B. FOUR SIX SEVEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS WATER
LINE NUMBER TWO OH ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHAT CAN I NUMBER TWO
A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
CALL ONE NUMBER THREE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MONICA EMBREY WOULDN'T COST
GENTLEST CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND- CALLING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT WITH SUNRISE KERN
TOP OF FOR CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA INTERFAITH POWER AND
LIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT. EXHORT ONE NUMBER
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NICOLE EVAN
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT-
FROM I CANNOT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS TO HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MERCEDES
MISSING WITHIN KERN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXT ONE THREE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
THREE SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER THREE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KOBE NAY
SICK I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR SIX SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
VISION THE ENTIRE COALITION
INCLUDING THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
POSITION FOR SOCIAL SPONSORED
THOUGH THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT. STAY ON THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE- CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK
CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION AND THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA OUT IN A COLLECTIVE.
AS WELL AS ALLIES AND
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
MAKE IT ON THE PHONE BECAUSE
THE PHONE LINES ARE ALL TAKEN
UP AND- INADEQUATE FOR THIS
HEARING. WORKS ALLEN AS THE
LABOR NETWORK FOR
SUSTAINABILITY I THOUSAND
GRANDMOTHERS CLIMATE HAWKS VOTE
SOME RIGHTS MOVEMENT BAY AREA
SUNRISE MOVEMENT SACRAMENTO
ALRIGHT THEN THE LA THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO. THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA CLIMATE HEALTH NOW AND
MANY MORE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE WORKING WITH THE MORE THAN
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION.
FRONTLINE RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA COURT ACTED
VIOLENTLY GAS DRILLING IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NEXT TIME TO BE C. WHAT.
HI MY NAME IS A MAN KNOWS I
THAT. IN RIGHT CAL CALLING
CLINTON HEALTH NOW IN SUPPORT
AND BEFORE EIGHT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE NUMBER
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
RES THIS IS OUR THE FACT THAT
I'M NOT WITH MOTHER'S DAY FRONT
HELLO OR- IS STRONG OF S. B.
FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS WOULD ONE
NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY TWO FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT TO I NUMBER
ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER ONE THREE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ZERO ONE NUMBER
THREE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ACCORDED LINE NUMBER THREE
THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS DIANA CURIEL
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY ON A NUMBER
OF POSSIBLE THREE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT AGAINST THE
FIRST DEFENDANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR
LINE NUMBER THREE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MARIANNE
WAS TRYING TO COVER REPORTS AS
AN KERN COUNTY I OPPOSE SB FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN. WHEN ASKED YOU
BUT- NOW THIS JUST HAPPENS TO
BE SUPPORT SO WILL NOT THAT TO
NOT OUNTED AGAINST THE
SUPPORTS. TIME SO MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NEXT TIME BECAUSE-
WELL. BY NUMBER THREE TWO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THIS IS
GLORIA COLLIDED FROM ERA ENERGY
AND THE HAVE ALL MY CELLS AND
CRISTINA FAVOR AND DINNER
CARMONA OUT WITH ONLY A
POLITICAL AND BEFORE SIXTY
SEVEN AND THIS IS THIS IS THE
SUPPORT TIME SO WE WILL NOTE
THAT BUT NOT COUNTED AGAINST
THE TIME SO MODERATOR NEXT.
SUPPORT CALLER. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO GO TO LINE NUMBER NINE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KARINA MAYOR AND THE
PEDIATRICIAN AND LOS ANGELES
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FOURTEEN
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING NINETEEN THOUSAND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. IN
CALIFORNIA WHO RECOGNIZE THESE
HARMFUL EXTRACTION METHOD THAT
THE HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR SIX
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
TO A LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN BUTLER
GRAHAM CALLING FOR MOTHERS OUT
FRONT SILICON VALLEY ALSO FOR
MY CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF SB FOUR
SIX SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE NUMBER TWO
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. EDUCARE
NUMBERS BUT WHAT LARGER WITH
THE QUALITY CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JEREMY THING WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER EDC STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK AT THE ALTAR ON THURS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARCUS JOHNSON
WHICH DECISIONS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES IN
THE STAND L. A. COALITION OF
REPRESENTING OVER SEVENTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TEXTURA Y.
NUMBER TWO NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DURING GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT SINCE GUSTAVO HEATED
JUNIOR WAS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NETWORK
COMING IN TO GIVE A GREAT
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR SIX SEVEN
IN IN ADDITION TO THAT STROKES
THAT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT
TODAY. COLLEEN FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IN LOST HILLS CHAPTER
ARVIN CALIFORNIA SOMEONE
CALIFORNIANS BUTTONWILLOW
CALIFORNIA BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY THAT SHE'LL TALK
CALIFORNIA AND COMMITTEES OF
THE LOS. NEXIUM COMMITTEE FOR
BEDRIJVEN COMMITTEE FOR BETTER
SHAFTER AND LAMONT CONGRESS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS WOULD LINE
THEM THREE SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THE IS
VICTORIA RIGHT WHAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCE THAT COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT ONE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ONLINE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HI NAME IS
JESSICA CRAVEN I AM A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY'S ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS
AND I ALSO STOOD ON THE
PLATFORM COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS
WELL AS THE ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENT SUBCOMMITTEE ALSO
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE LAPD P.
BUT I'M CALLING TODAY TO
REPRESENT FEMINISTS AND ACTION
LOS ANGELES NORTH RIDGE
INDIVISIBLE THE NEW LIKE
CLIMATE COLLECTIVE AND LA FOR
CLIMATE. AND MY CHILD YOU CAN'T
GO OUT AND PLAY ON DIRTY AIR
DAYS TO SAY THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE REALLY
HOPE YOU ALL THE TRAFFIC. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WHAT WE ALL FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME'S A LEASE CALL FINE AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
GLENDALE ENVIRONMENTAL
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB FOUR SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'LL HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
RACHEL SMITH- CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE NORTH MOVEMENT LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS THE- THIRTY
YEARS YOU KNOW OW MANY MORE
PEOPLE AT THE POINT THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET AND I
BASED ON THE PHONE LINE THE
JEWISH AND ACKNOWLEDGES THE
COURTS AND THAT PEOPLE SHOULD.
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BACK TO HAVE LINE NUMBERS.
ONE PLEASE AHEAD. THIS IS
JENNIFER COMPANY FROM THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND STARR
KING UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST
CHURCH WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ROBERT
CABRERA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
TEMPLE BETH EL JEWISH COMMUNITY
CENTER IN ANNAPOLIS CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT CHRIS BEFORE
SIXTY SEVEN. HI ROBERT THANKS
FOR CALLING IN. NEXT PERSON
RIGHT NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DOUG ROGERS I WOULD
PERSON OCCUR RESOURCES. PLEASE
SAVE MY JOB IN THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS IN THE INDUSTRY NO ON AS
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN THIS IS THE
TIME FOR YESS BUT WE WILL NOTE
YOUR SAID NOT COUNTED AGAINST
THE YES TODD MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
QUESTION COMES MY NUMBER THREE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER THREE AWAIT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BARBARA. WE CAN HEAR YOU
BETTER Q. MODERATOR HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE DO WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
PARTY STILL IN QUEUE I'M SORRY
I CAN'T HEAR HOW MANY. FIVE
THIRTY. OKAY WELL WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE AND A HALF MINUTES LEFT
SO LET'S TAKE AS MANY AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU THE PERSON NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER THREE ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE NEED A
ONE TIME NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE LET. HI MY NAME IS
SET THAT I GAVE THEM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL BASSES NETWORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH GREEN ACTION
VALLEY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS NOT
CAMINO ACTION COMMITTEE
PREGNANT AGAINST FRACKING
CALIFORNIA MY MENTAL JUSTICE
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SCHOOLS ALONG WITH THE
LEAP INTEGER IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE NUMBER
TWO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CARLA
ANESTHETICS PHD STUDENT AT CAL
TECH AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SUNRISE MOVEMENT LOS ANGELES
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. YOU VERY MUCH BUT- THANK
YOU NEXT OVER ONE ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE. BUT YOU HAVE TO SAY
SOMETHING FOR US TO HEAR YOU.
NEXT CALL ONE CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU CAN TALK
AFTER THAT A FEW OUTLOOK. AND
ALLISON DOLLMAN- CAMBRIA
CALIFORNIA. I THOUGHT. AND
SEVERAL HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE
TEXTED ME SAYING WE ALL SUPPORT
SB FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THE FROM THE CORPORATE
A CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COLLISION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB. FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXTCODE
LINE NUMBER THREE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SIX OF ONE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KIRTI
CREEK CALLING IN FROM. LOS
ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PARK AT THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PIXIV I
NUMBER TWO TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OLENA
CHRISTENSEN WITH THEIR ENERGY
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND COUNTER
ON AWAY AND NICER HAIDAR I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVENTHS IS THE SUPPORT SECTION
WE WILL NOTE YOUR COMMENTS NOT
COUNTED AS TIME FOR THE
PROPONENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. OUR NEXT LINE OF THE
LINE NUMBER TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
JEREMY CENTERS ME CAL POLY
POMONA EMPTY STUDENT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT COLUMN. NEXT LINE OF THE
LINE NUMBER THREE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS A LONG
SO WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF- MARC- AND
KERN COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M DONE AND I'M AN
ORGANIZED PERSON MIGHT HAVE
BEEN LA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DELEGATE. AND I REPRESENT
MULTIPLE BALLOTS IN NORTH LOS
ANGELES INCOME RIGHT AWAY THE
COURT SB POINTS. THANK YOU MUCH
MODERATE FEW KEY UP L. THIS
PERSON IS TO ALLOW PERSON.
BRIGHTENER LAST LINE WILL GO TO
THE NUMBER SEVENTY. WHAT HAD.
HEY THIS IS THE WITH THE CENTER
ABOUT DIVERSITY SUPPORT THIS
POINT CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE WHO I'M A BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MORE ABOUT
COME THE TIME WE HAVE. OF FOR
THE ME TOO. IN SOME OF THE BILL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES TO ARE SPLITTING
THREE MINUTES- RUDY GONZALES
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND DAVE NELSON FROM THE KERN
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL ONE
THREE OLD ONE AND AS THEY'RE
GETTING READY TO SPLIT THE
THREE MINUTES LET ME JUST SAY
TO THE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. OF
JUSTICE TO PEOPLE I MEAN TO
PEOPLE MY POSITION JUST AS THE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT JUST SAID
THAT SOME PEOPLE CAN'T GET IN
I'M ALSO GETTING TEXTS ABOUT
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION NOT
GETTING IN SO IF YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY'S ON THE LAWN AND IT
IS GOING TO REPRESENT THEIR
OPPOSITION TAX THEM AND GET
YOURS ADDED TO THEM. AND WE
WILL TAKE. WRITTEN OPPOSITION.
AFTER THE HEARING AS WELL SO
THAT NOBODY'S OPINION IS
EXCLUDED FROM THE HEARING. WITH
THAT WILL MOVE TO THE TO LEAD
OPPOSITION ARE WITNESSES YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES BETWEEN.
TOTAL AND WILL BEGIN WITH RUDY
GONZALEZ. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU CHAIR.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THE
CONTINUE READING DAHLE CENSUS
OF BUILDING TRADES ABOUT WAY
BACK ON THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
TRADES HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION IN OUR STATE WE
BUILT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UTILITY SCALE SOLAR WIND
GEOTHERMAL HYDRO ELECTRIC AND
PUMPED STORAGE. AND FRANKLY WE
MAKE CALIFORNIA A GLOBAL LEADER
INCREASE OUR PRODUCTION
BUILDING TRADES- FOR EXAMPLE
HAVE BUILT TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
A LOT TOO SO THAT'S A QUICK ONE
TO MORE THAN ELEVEN NUCLEAR
POWER PLANTS WE HAD A WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE CAPITAL
FOR POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE
AGREEING A CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR RELIABLE
ENERGY FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
THAT'S GOT TO INCLUDE BOTH
MAINTAINING AND MODERNIZATION
OF ENERGY PRODUCTION WITH THE
MOST HIGHLY SKILLED WORKFORCE
UNDER THE MOST STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AS WELL AS
BEING FOUR SIX SEVEN IF THIS
PASSES- AND IT DOES SEEK TO END
ALL EXTRACTIONS BUT I CHALLENGE
YOU THAT IT DOESN'T DO FOR
WORKERS OR FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
WHAT IT CLAIMS ARE DOMESTIC
SUPPLY FACTORS INTO THIRTY TWO
MILLION CARS AND TRUCKS ARE ON
OUR ROADS TODAY. ENDING
EXTRACTION CALIFORNIA LAW AND
THAT THE SUPPLY OR THE DEMAND
FOR THAT- INTRACTABLE SHIPPED
US TO PRODUCTION OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA OR SUPPLY AVENUES-
TO OTHER NATIONS I CHALLENGE
YOU THIS ISN'T GOING TO
ACHIEVING ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
THAT THE AUTHOR CLAIMS IT WILL.
ALSO THOUSANDS OF BLUE COLLAR
JOBS THAT WILL BE LOST AN
EXTRACTION TRIGGER RIPPLE
EFFECT SHUTTLING OUR REFINERY
OPERATIONS. LET'S BE CLEAR THIS
IS CALIFORNIA WE KNOW WHAT
REGULATIONS WITHOUT REAL
SOLUTIONS LEAD TO WE STILL
SUFFERS THE JOB LOSS OF NASCO
NO STATE HAS TAKEN MORE
INDUSTRIAL JOB LOSSES THAT OUR
STATE AND OUR BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS CAN'T AFFORD THIS NOW
WE ESPECIALLY CAN'T AFFORD TO
TRANSITION GOOD WELL PAYING.
CAREER PATHS AND INDUSTRIAL
JOBS AND REPLACING THEM WITH
MINIMUM WAGE GIG WORK IT'S
FRANKLY OFFENSIVE THAT THE
VERSION OF JUST TRANSITION
SENATOR WIENER FROM MY HOME
DISTRICT CLAIMS WITHIN THIS
BILL IS MERELY RELEGATING US.
TO CLEAN UP WORK IT IS GOOD FOR
FROM ANY REAL JUST. AND IN FACT
THIS. ATTEMPT GRABBING. SIX
COULD DIVIDE IN A ROW WHAT
COULD BE. NEED COLD TO THAT.
FROM ALL SIDES AND STAKE. THAT
ALL CAN. I WILL JUST SAY THAT
WE REMAIN FOCUSED BUILDING OUT
IN A ENERGY INTO. THE NEW TO
CREATE JOBS IN PROMOTE IN A-
AND CREATE REAL ENERGY SYSTEM
IN THE STATE THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO MOVE IN TRANSITION IN THE
GREEN WAY THINGS LIKE HIGH
SPEED RAIL CLEAN FUELS AND-
THESE WILL BE NEEDED TO MEET
OUR DRESSES ON THE GIRLS. THIS
HAS TO BE DICTATED BY SCIENCE
AND FACTS NOT POLITICAL
POSTURING AND EXTREME MISTER
CANNELLA ACTIVISM I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY BUT
YOU'RE USING THE ENTIRE THREE
MINUTES FOR YOUR SIDE IT IS. IS
THAT I WASN'T INTENDING TO
SPEAK. YES SIR I HAD. ORDERED
THEN IF YOU COULD WRAP UP ALL
GIVE A MINUTE THAT'LL RUN OVER
BUT I'LL GIVE ME A MINUTE MR
GONZALEZ COULD YOU WRAP UP. GOT
DOUBLE CHECK THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. MISTER NELSON
I'M SORRY THAT TIME WAS MOSTLY
USED BUT I'LL GIVE YOU A MINUTE
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DAVE NELSON I'M THE
PRESIDENT KERN COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION LOCAL
THIRTEEN NO ONE REPRESENTING.
OUR FIREFIGHTERS TOOK MORE THAN
NINE THOUSAND CITIZENS. NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED SQUARE MILES
YES INDUSTRY IS A MAJOR
IMPORTER ARE GETTING PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT RESIDENTS FOR
GOVERNMENT SERVICES THROUGH
PROPERTY TAXES. SENATE FOR
SIXTY SEVEN WHAT FROM THE
PERPETUATE THE PROCESS BUT
SOLUTIONS KERN COUNTY PROJECT
THEY PROJECTED TO COURT A 40%
VALUATION AUGUST PROPERTY. IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WHAT WOULD NEED TO REDUCE
GOVERNMENT. IN PUBLIC SAFETY
WILLING GAS PRODUCTION RISE AND
I POINT ONE BILLION ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTION DIRECTLY TO KERR.
WE ARE DOING OUR PART BY
PROVIDING 50% OF THE STATE'S
ENERGY PORTFOLIO. IN A LOSS OF
INCOME DUE THE STATE'S SOLAR
TAX EXCLUSION WE MUST WORK
TOGETHER PASS RESPONSIBLE WILL
FOLLOW LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDES FOR RESPONSIBLE
PRODUCTION OF OIL AND GAS AS
WELL AS COOLEY BY WHICH
ECONOMIC IMPACTS THE POOR IN
THE- ELIMINATING. AN INDUSTRY
THAT SUPPORTS SO MANY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RICH
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
OF THE NOW WE WILL MOVE. TO THE
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF. ME TOOS
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
AND IF WHEN WE GET TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. IF THERE ARE
PEOPLE. THAT THE ARE CAN GET IN
A YOU GET IT FROM THEM ADD THEM
TO YOUR ME TO USE. AND SO WE'RE
GETTING GOING TO BEGIN IN THE
HEARING ROOM SO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS WHO ARE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING THROUGH
AND ON BEHALF OF THE- LIKELY
HUNDREDS OF OUR MEMBERS YOU
CAN'T GET THROUGH TODAY EITHER.
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL THE STATE ASSOCIATION
LEXICAL WORKERS TO WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS. THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST REPRESENT THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JESSICA FOR ALL IS
REPRESENTING OUR LOCAL ONE
FIFTY TWO CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE CARPENTERS. AND WE ARE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS
RON LET. ME JUST KICKED OVER
THAT WHOLE PODIUM SORRY ABOUT
THAT IT'S BEEN THAT KIND OF. I
REPRESENT CARPENTERS LOCAL ONE
EIGHTY OF SOLANO COUNTY AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HER NAME
IS CURTIS DAY MEMBER OF
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES A
MEMBER OF LOCAL TWELVE AND I
STAND IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOHN TWEED REGIONAL DIRECTOR
DISTRICT APPLE SIXTEEN A U. P.
A. T. WE STAND IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO MY
NAME IS RAHEL NEEDN'T DISCOUNT
OF SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES LOCAL FORTY SEVEN WE
STAND WITH THE BILLION TREES
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD CHARLIE
ROBBERY WAS THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE. AND THE
SAN MATTEO AT BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION STATES TRADES
COUNCIL STANDING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN IN
THIS TIME TAMI NAMA BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AND I'M HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TERM MEMBERS ARE THE
BELCHERTOWN BEHALF OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL IN OUR TWENTY THREE
LOCALS WHO CAN'T GET THROUGH WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR REGISTERING THE
OTHER TWENTY THREE LOCALS. OF
SIGNAL ONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WE WILL MOVE TO
ITEM TWENTY FIVE. ITEMS ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHERE I DO SEE A
QUEUE AT THE PODIUM SO WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. OKAY JUST A
SECOND WE HAVE TO TURN ON THE
MICROPHONE OR TURN ON THAT
SPEAKER WHATEVER IT IS. EIGHT
THERE WE GOOD. OKAY GIVE IT A
GO SEE IF WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
WHY IT MATTERS OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL UNION NUMBER
THREE IN STRONG OPPOSITION WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES PERFECT
THANK YOU WE COULD HEAR YOU
JUST FINE. BETUL BETUL
IRONWORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN
WE STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL WITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN ON BEHALF
OF THOUSANDS OR REFINERY
WORKERS IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
MY NAME IS CHUCK LEONARD
PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS
LOCAL THREE FORTY TWO. I STAND
IN SOLIDARITY AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER CHAIR CHOI ARNTZEN
IRONWORKERS LOCAL EIGHTEEN OUT
OF SACRAMENTO AND WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GERMAN MY NAME IS JASON
LINDSAY IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT SPEAKING FOR
FOURTEEN THOUSAND IRON WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. INTERMARRIAGE
WITH THE NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
IBEW LOCAL THREE FORTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN KEN MILLER
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME
IS MICHAEL JOHN REPRESENTING
THE BOILERMAKERS LOCAL FIVE
FORTY NOT OUT PITTSBURG
CALIFORNIA. WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE TRADES
COUNCIL. AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THAT APPEARS TO BE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE IN HEARING
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE AND THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO JUST
TO NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE OPPOSING SIDE
OF S. B. FOUR SIXTY SEVEN AND
IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE BUT YOU'RE
SO SEATED WITH THAT CAN'T GET
IN YOU CAN ADD THEIR
AFFILIATION TO YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR. YOU PEOPLE OUT.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
NOT POSITION SP FOUR SIX SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE OR THE
LINE OF THREE FORTY NINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD
. ONE FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE. MY APOLOGIES
MISTER CHAIRPERSON BE JUST A
NORMAL. WE'RE GONNA GO THE LINE.
BY NUMBER THREE TWO SEVEN- TWO
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER TWO SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT ONE MODERATE. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRPERSON. BORDERLINE
NUMBER ONE SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS EDWIN
LOMBARD ON THE PRESIDENCY OF
THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE BUT I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING THE BLACK
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
PASTOR THERE WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEXICO LINE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEN
SYMBOLS HAIR I WORKED FOR
CHEVRON AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE CHAIR IF I CAN READ THE
NAMES OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
OUT THERE ABOUT EIGHTY OF THEM.
GO RIGHT AHEAD. OKAY JONATHAN
HARSHMAN TODD LITTLE WORDS
JORDY CHAMBERS BILLY CLAYTON
AMIR MEHMOOD TOM MERRY FIELD
AND USE YOUR PRAKASH. THE
ROBBIE ROBINSON REGION SHALL
JOHNNY RANDY BREAUX THIS AND
CARLA YOU CHIRLA CRYSTAL COLOR
DANIEL VOICE IN. A LEAFLET CAL
THE ARIK. MARSHFIELD KAREN
GRAND SO MICHAEL REACHED ANY
MCKAY. MICHAEL EDGAR BELLOW
BURKE BROUGH RIGHT. RANIERE
READ IT IT JUST APPEARS THIS A
FEW MORE THAN EIGHT. EIGHTY HOW
I MET- YOU HAVE EIGHTY I HEARD
DATE. A THEM THE RECORD WE WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE THE TIME TO
TESTIFY APOLOGIZE I HEARD EIGHT
AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
MANAGEABLE. SO WE APPRECIATE IT
SUBMITS TO THE REST OF THE
NAMES MODERATOR NEXT PEOPLE.
YES AND I FINALLY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVERYTHING'S ALSO SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE ZERO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS BILLION TRADE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS WOULD LINE WERE ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CLINTON BECOME VERY
CORPORATION REPRESENTING OTHERS
SHARED BIG NIGHT SHANE BAIRD
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MOLLY KAMALA ANY G. IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR SIX
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS TO THE LINE NUMBER FOUR
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER TALENT FROM
ERROR ENERGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FOUR SIX SEVEN AS
WELL AS YOUNG YOUNGER MODELS
ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSES SB FOUR
SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WOULD LINE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DOUG CHANCELLOR
REPRESENTING SHE SAID QUITE A
FRESNO KERN NEVER STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
PHIL SORBET WITH MAKERS AND
ENERGY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN STEVEN WORKERS-
I CLEAN CORPORATISM STRONGLY
OPPOSE US BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXAVAR
LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DAVID BOWEN I'M NOT PLEASE-
YEAH ONE CONVENIENCE AND I AM I
AM MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STEELWORKERS LOCAL SIX SEVEN
FIVE PASSED THE PETITION. ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY NUMBER
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS RON NEWS I
WORK FOR PINNACLE AND I AM A
FIELD TECH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT'S WHAT LINE NUMBER
TWO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JAMES FORWARD FROM-
ERROR ENERGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE NUMBER THREE
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS KATHLEEN WALL
FROM ERRANT ENERGY AND I
STRONGLY A QUOTE OPPOSED SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT TO THE LINE NUMBER
ONE NINETY FOUR POLICE. ONE ONE
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT TO THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS RON HUNT I WORK FOR
CHEVRON AND THEY'RE STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. FOUR SIX SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR
LINE NUMBER THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME'S
CHAPLAIN ARE LOCKED. OPERATING
ENGINEERS DISTRICT RAP LOCAL
THREE SECRETARY TREASURER OF
THE HUMBOLDT DEL MAR BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES WEREN'T
STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR
SIX SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
HELLO YEAH IBEW LOCAL FIVE NINE
FIVE MEETING IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS- RICHARD ROTH OF
AMEREN ENERGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO LINE
NUMBER THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RITA WA
AND- I'M MARY ENERGY ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF HATER HEATHER
LEIGHTON BONTA ALSO ENERGY
WHICH STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR
SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE L. A. ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES. ON
BEHALF OF HONOR FORTY THOUSAND
SKILLED AND TRAINED MEN AND
WOMEN ACROSS FORTY LOCAL UNIONS
AND DISTRICT COUNCILS WE STAND
WITH PRESIDENT ROBBIE HUNTER OF
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO FOUR SIX SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOSH
WHEELER AND BEHALF OF TWO OTHER
WORKERS AND THE WINNERS IN
MOSCOW ON HERE WE ALL WORK
PERCENT THE RESOURCES PLEASE
SAVE OUR JOBS AND VOTE NO ON AS
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS FOR
CALLING OFF FROM AIR ENERGY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GO
TO LINE NUMBER THREE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
AUTUMN HIGHER I LOOK AT THEIR
ENERGY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
YOU VERY MUCH. SIX WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT MY NAME IS SEAN
HOLES WERE THROUGH MARINERS G.
AND ON BEHALF OF SABRINA THE
DELGADO INTRANET TO WITH WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER TWO
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DAVE BERTRAM PREMIER
ENERGY I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BEFORE SIX- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MIKE ONE WOULD WORK
FOR ENERGY I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE NOW HAVE ONE NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MATTHEW DONAHUE FOR
ENERGY ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
DEREK SCHAEFER BRAD JONES
ATTACK RISE WHOSE MEGARON
AUGUSTINE. WEST FONG AND RUBEN
REYES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE.
ARE WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO TAKE
ABOUT THE NEXT FIVE AND THEN
WILL HAVE TO NOTE THE OTHERS IF
IN THE RECORD WHEN THEY LET US
KNOW SO A MODERATOR. NEXT
BEAKER. YES NECK FUNDS GOING TO
BE THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JIM
BROWNING FROM ERROR ENERGY AND
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF GEN I IN
BENTON AND BRANDON TRIPP WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
FOUR SIX SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SIX OF ONE
NUMBER TWO ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS OLENA SUTTON
FROM ERIN ENERGY IN ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE QUEUE
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO GET A
NUMBER WE ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
pNUMBER TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JERRY
CRABTREE. ALONG THE SEAN
O'CONNOR LIBERALLY AND CODY
WALTERS WE ALL STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR
MEXICO LINE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
THREE EIGHT ZERO LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WAS THE LINE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN
CURRENT. ENTRY ALONG WITH THE
CURRENT WITH THE COST OF
COLLEGE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB FOUR SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR THIS WILL BE THE LAST
CALL. THE LAST LINE FOR THIS TO
BE THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MORRIS FROM THEIR ENERGY AND
ONE BATH MY COMPANY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. FOUR SIX SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT LET ME JUST NOTE
FOR ALL OF YOU BECAUSE IT WAS A
LARGE NUMBER WAITING IN LINE.
CAN STILL EMAIL THE COMMITTEE
ALL RIGHT US A LETTER AND
REGISTER YOUR YOUR POSITION THE
MATTER IS BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU- MAP
TIMES CHAIRMAN AND- SURE WINNER
LET ME JUST RAISE A COUPLE
CONCERNS ARE BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION AND MAYBE YOU'RE
ALREADY PREPARED IN YOUR CLOSE
TO ANSWER SOME OF THESE ARE.
ADDRESS SOME OF THEM IT'S YOU
KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS JUST
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN. WILL IMPACT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND WILL HAVE
A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
FAMILIES. NOT JUST IN THE AREAS
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT BUT YOU
KNOW STATEWIDE. BY BANNING ALL
IN STATE OIL GAS AND PRODUCTION
HAS BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN WILL
MAKE CALIFORNIA NEARLY 1100%
RELIANT. ON FOREIGN ENERGY
IMPORTS. AND WILL PUT THE STATE
AT RISK OF MARKET VOLATILITY
AND SIGNIFICANT RELIABILITY
ISSUES. CURRENTLY OUR COURTS
OUR PORTS. I CAN'T EVEN TAKE UP
THIS ADDITIONAL CAPACITY. OF
ONE OF THE CONCERNS IS THAT
THIS MAY INCREASE FUEL COSTS.
BY UP TO TEN DOLLARS PER GALLON.
AND RAISE ENERGY COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES. UNFORTUNATELY YES
BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN RESULT WAS
THE RESULT IN THE LOSS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND JOBS AND WILL HIT THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PARTICULARLY
HARD I THINK WE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF THOSE FOLKS THIS THAN
THIS MORNING IN OPPOSITION. OR
AS YOU SAY THE MAJORITY OF THIS
OIL IS PRODUCED BY ELIMINATING
ALL OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION SB
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN- ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND TAX
REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH
PRODUCTION WHICH THE STATE
HEAVILY RELIES ON IN ITS
GENERAL FUND. IF ENACTED FOR
SIXTY SEVEN ALSO SUBJECTS THE
STATE UP TO BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LEGAL LIABILITY AND FINALLY
S. B. FOR SIXTY SEVEN IMPLIES
THAT LOCAL OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IS NOT ESSENTIAL AND
CRITICAL AND WILL DISRUPT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S CRITICAL SUPPLY
CHAINS. DURING THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC NEARLY NEARLY EVERY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT HAS
DECLARED ALL ELEMENTS OF OIL
AND NATURAL GAS SUPPLY CHAIN AS
ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL SERVICES
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO PROTECT OUR
SECURITY ECONOMY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THOSE OF THOSE
THERE'S- SOME THINGS THAT BRING
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION.
SENATOR I THANK YOU CENTER
JONES YES IT DOES. FIFTY THOSE
ARE THE TALKING POINTS- OF THE
OPPOSITION- TO THE BILL- AND-
WE- WE- CERTAINLY- I DON'T
AGREE WITH THEM I THINK PART OF
THE NARRATIVE THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS ATTEMPTED TO
PAINT. IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
SOMEHOW THIS SELF CONTAINED OIL
ECOSYSTEM WHICH IS NOT TRUE
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S REFINERIES WHICH
ARE REALLY A SEPARATE INDUSTRY
FROM THE OIL EXTRACTION
CALIFORNIA REFINERIES. IMPORT
SOMETHING LIKE 70% OF THE OIL
THEY REFINED TO ALREADY TODAY
70% OF THE OIL IS IMPORTED SO
TO SUGGEST THAT WERE SAID THAT
THIS IS SOME SORT OF SELF
CONTAINED. CALIFORNIA IS WE'LL
INDEPENDENT IT'S JUST NOT TRUE
IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA'S
REFINERIES. EXPORT A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF A
REFINED OIL OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THIS IS NOT A
SITUATION WE DRILL IT HERE THEN
IT'S REFINED HERE AND THEN IS
CONSUMED HERE AND WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MAKE A CALIFORNIA HAVE
TO RELY ON OTHER WILL THAT'S
ALREADY HAPPENING- AND SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BOND AND
YOU KNOW I THINK- YOU KNOW THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE PROPOSES
AMENDMENTS. TO EXTEND THE BILL
AL IN TERMS OF THE BOOK OF THE
EXTRACTION DOWN A LARGE
MAJORITY LOOKS TO TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. IS PRECISELY TO IMPACT TO
ENABLE THAT TRANSITION SO IT'S
NOT HAPPENING AROUND THOSE
IMAGE CAME FROM FROM US THEY
WEREN'T REQUESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE WE ASK FROM OUR
SPONSORS. BEST FOR IT IN ORDER
TO TRY TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE
AND YET YES ARE THERE IMPACTS
IN THE BILL OF COURSE LOOKING
TO GET OPTIONS TO THERE ARE NO
IMPACTS IMPACTFUL BUILT. BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING IMPACTED
IN TERMS OF THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY RIGHT NOW. AND YOU HEARD
FROM SOME OF YOU KNOW OUR LEAD
WITNESS- EVEN CENTRAL VALLEY
RESIDENTS VALLEY RESIDENTS WHO
ARE BEING ETCETERA WHO ARE
BEING AFFECTED IN TERMS OF
THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH RIGHT NOW SO
YOU KNOW WE WERE TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE HERE AS I
THINK KNOWLEDGE. IF THIS BILL
MOVES TODAY I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WILL BUT IF IT DOES- YOU KNOW
WITH THIS WILL BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE KNOW THAT BUT I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO ACTUALLY SET UP THE
STRUCTURE. SAID. WE STOPPED
TAKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD.
THANK YOU OTHER SENATORS.
SENATOR EGGMAN THANK YOU. FOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THANK
YOU TO. SENATOR WINNER FOR
BRINGING US A OF THIS BILL- I
WILL I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY AND- AND I JUST
WANNA TALK ABOUT IT JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF GUIDANCE I AM
CERTAIN ON NATURAL RESOURCES.
THIS IS MY SECOND HOUSE NOW-
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE BILLS THAT
COME EVERY YEAR AND EVERY YEAR
IT'S THE BIGGEST BELL EVERY
YEAR'S BIGGEST BELL- THAT GO
TOWARDS AB MANAGING. REGULATING
THE OIL INDUSTRY- AND IF THIS
BILL AND SO EVERY I MEAN TO
CHOICE UP UNTIL JUST A SAY BY
ME AND ON BOTH SIDES RIGHT
EVERY YEAR IT'S THE WORST IT'S
THE BEST IT'S THE WORST IT'S
BEST IT'S THE DEFINING. EVERY
YEAR RIGHT SO IT'S- AND HERE'S
ONE MORE AND THIS ONE REALLY
DOES GO TO SHUT DOWN THE OIL
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA- IF IT
WERE JUST FRACKING EVERYONE
KEEPS ON THE FRACKING BELL. AS
WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A VERY
SMALL COMPONENT OF OIL
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA END OF
THIS BILL FRACKING IS A VERY
SMALL CONSCIOUS FRACKING OKAY
SKERRITT FRACKING. PUSH JUST
SETBACKS. TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED A
LOT LAST YEAR VOTED FOR ONE
THAT'S A THEY CONSIDER THAT. WE
COULD EVEN TALK ABOUT THAT BUT
THE EVERYTHING ELSE IN IT- WHEN
AS YOU AS YOU HAVE SAID. WE ARE
NOT GETTING AWAY FROM OIL OR
GAS IT IN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
NEXT IN NEXT TEN YEARS. I HAVE
AN ELECTRIC CAR. NOW I'M I AM
NOT I AM A ONE INCOME FAMILY I
DON'T I CAN'T AFFORD. A TESLA I
GOT MY SHOVEL KIA. I ALSO I IS
TWENTY FIVE MILES I DO MY PART
I GET TWENTY FIVE MILES GIVES
ME HALF WAY TO WORK BECAUSE
LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS. I
COMMUTE EVERY DAY I'M IN MY CAR
TWO HOURS EVERY SINGLE DAY BACK
AND FORTH. AND I CAN JUST TELL
YOU THAT TIME ON THE ROAD
EXHAUST ME BUT I DON'T HAVE A I
DON'T HAVE A RAIL SYSTEM TO USE
THAT I CAN GO BACK AND FORTH
USUALLY. SO I HAVE TO DRIVE.
AND I HAVE TO DRIVE. AGAIN PART
OF THAT IS ELECTRIC AND PART OF
IT IS NOT. AND I CONSIDER
MYSELF INCREDIBLY PRIVILEGED TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD ONE THAT
WON'T GET TO MIDDLE TWENTY FIVE
MILES. OF ELECTRIC AND I'M JUST
THINK ABOUT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIANS AND MY DISTRICT
THE PEOPLE WHO COMMUTE. THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO DRIVE TRUCKS
THE PEOPLE WHO DRIVE TRACTORS.
NONE OF THOSE ARE ELECTRIC WILL
LIKE TO TRAVEL THAT'S NOT GOING
TO BE ELECTRIC SO WE WOULD HAVE
TO TRANSITION OFFENSE AND- THEN
I AND I DO GREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THAT THE JUST
TRANSITION OF JOBS IS- IS VERY
VERY VERY SLIM AND NOT AND NOT
REAL. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OF
THIS IS A MAJOR IMPACT OF THIS-
IS THE ACCUSED AMOUNT OF JOBS
AND THE CORRESPONDING JOBS THAT
WILL BE LOST THAT GO. ALONG
WITH THIS SO. THAT WE IT THE
END JUST TO JUSTICE. THIS TO
SAY OF COURSE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE LIVING BY BY WELLS THIS
CLOSE IT IS UNSAFE. AND
CALIFORNIA DOES IT SAY FOR THAT.
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD AS
FAR AS I KNOW. WE ARE MORE
REGULAR THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE. SO WHAT WE PRODUCE IS
THE SAFEST SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS WE'RE STILL GOING TO USE IT
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO USE IT
FROM PLACES THAT PRODUCE AT ALL
LESS SAFELY. WITH CARE FOR
THOSE AROUND AND WE DO HERE. SO
I AM ALL FOR LET'S LET'S
CONTINUE TRANSITIONING OFF WITH
ALL DO OUR PART. BUT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE QUITE THERE YET AND
THIS BILL ASSUMES THAT WE ARE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHER
SENATORS CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
MISTER GERALD IS FOLLOW UP ON
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON'S
COMMENTS YOU KNOW- THE STATE IS
INSTALLED OVER ONE MILLION
SOLAR ROOFS WE REGISTERED OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND HYBRID
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE'VE ADDED
TWELVE THOUSAND. MEGAWATTS OF
SOLAR ENERGY THE AVERAGE FUEL
ECONOMY AND FOR THE UNITED
STATES VEHICLES HAS INCREASED
BY 25% GETTING BETTER FUEL
ECONOMY ECONOMY. DURING THIS
LAST THIRTY YEARS OF TRANSITION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ONLY REDUCE
THE OIL USAGE BY 6% AND WE ARE
COUNTING ON OIL AND GAS- AND
PETROCHEMICALS- WE WILL BE
DEPENDED ON THEM FOR YEARS TO
COME. IF YOU LOOK AT FROM
NINETEEN NINETY ONE IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE CALIFORNIA FROM-
IMPORTED OR BROUGHT IN FOUR
POINT 5% OF OUR OIL FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND WE
PRODUCED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SAFELY AND UNDER THE MOST
ADVERSE STRINGENT ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATORY PROCESSES. WE
PRODUCED 50% OF THE OIL THAT WE
USE HERE IN CALIFORNIA NOW WE
IMPORT ABOUT 70% FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AND WE PRODUCE ABOUT
THIRTY PERCENT. FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT THINK I MADE A MISTAKE
IN THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
NUMBERS THE GAP THAT WE HAD
BACK THEN CAME FROM ALASKA.
AGAIN NOT FROM ECUADOR OR
VENEZUELA OR SAUDI ARABIA I'M
LOOKING AT AN ARTICLE HERE
WHICH I KNOW YOU PROBABLY CAN'T
SEE. THIS ARTICLE HAS A PICTURE
OF YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK YOU
CAN SEE IF I BLOW IT THIS
ARTICLE HAS A PICTURE OF
INDIGENOUS INDIANS. INDIGENOUS
INDIANS IN A VENEZUELAN
CORRIDOR- ECUADORIAN CORRIDOR
THESE INDIGENOUS INDIANS THIS
ARTICLE SAYS THAT DAY DID YOU
JUST PEOPLE BLOCKED ECUADOR OIL
AUCTION FROM GROWING AND A
FIGHT TO SAVE THE AMAZON. I CAN
TELL YOU IN KERN COUNTY IN
CIMAREX BUILDING CHEVRON'S
FIELDS THAT THEY OPERATE IN
BEADS FILLED THAT THEY OPERATE
IN THE OIL INDUSTRY IN KERN
COUNTY WERE 70% OF THE OIL. IS
PRODUCED WE ARE NOT FIGHTING
OFF. IN YOU JUST IN THE- AND
HAVE THEIR RAINFOREST
COMPLETELY DESTROYED BY THE OIL
TRIANGLES LIKE THEY'RE IN
ECUADOR. AND CALIFORNIANS FOR.
CONSUMPTION OF OIL HAS NOT
DECREASED BUT 6% OVER THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS AND WE CONTINUE TO
IMPORT OIL FROM FOREIGN NATIONS
THAT ARE NUMBER ONE HOSTILE TO
US. NUMBER TWO HAVE DISMAL
HUMAN RIGHTS- A HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUES AND ALSO HAVE THE WORST
QUALITY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION THEY HAVE NOT IF
THEY HAVE ZERO ZERO- CONSCIOUS
WHEN IT COMES TO ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES WHATSOEVER
YOU HAVE CHILDREN COVERED IN
OIL WORKING IN THESE. CAMPS
THESE- FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND WE
CAN PRODUCE THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS
FOR YOU SO- I SEE ALL THAT JUST
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE BILL. AS
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL
KNOW THIS BILL IS IN EXCHANGE
FOR NINETEEN. WHILE I AM VERY
UPSET ABOUT FOR NINETEEN TAKING
AWAY THOUSANDS OF LOCAL JOBS TO
THOSE THAT ARE- RECENTLY
RELEASED FROM PRISON. THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY FOR YEARS IF NOT
DECADES- I GUESS IF IT IS
UNIONIZED LIKE FOR NINETEEN IT
INTENDS TO DO. AT LEAST THE OIL
INDUSTRY WILL BECOME INSTANTLY
SAFE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY. AND I GUESS THAT'S
THE TRADE OFF THAT YOU HAVE IN
THIS BUILDING SO WHILE I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL AND
AS I HAVE NOT SUPPORTED FOR
NINETEEN ANOTHER BILLS I DON'T
FEEL THAT YOUR BILL IS AS BIG A
THREAT. AS FOR NINETEEN S.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK YOUR BILL
HAS A CHANCE CAL PASSING BUT
FOR NINETEEN WAS THEEXCHANGE
FOR THE BILL'S FAILURE AND FOR
NINETEEN WILL- WILL DESTROY
THOUSANDS OF LOCAL JOBS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY IN KERN
COUNTY. THANK YOU. BAR OTHER
COMMENTS FROM SENATORS. SENATOR
ALAN. SENATOR TIME CAN YOU JUST
GIVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
SORT OF FRONT LINE IMPACTS YOUR
TRYING TO. ADDRESS WITH THIS
BILL I KNOW YOU SPOKE OF THAT
DURING YOUR IN YOUR OPENING-
REMARKS BUT- YOU KNOW I AM IT
SEEMS TO ME THIS AND I HAVE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AMOUNT
FAMILY OF SOMEBODY WHO. GOT
CANCER AND THERE'S A THERE'S A
HE LIVED IN AN AREA WITH A LOT
OF FRACKING IN THE MIDWEST AND-
YOU KNOW ONE NEVER KNOWS HI.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THESE THINGS
BUT- GOOD LUCK WOULD LOVE YOU
TO SORT OF TALK ABOUT WHAT
FRONTLINE. WE MAY LEAD US TO
COME TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
COME UP WITH SOME SORT OF
COMPROMISE. BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT
PEOPLE OUT OF OUT OF WORK I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. CENTER WINNER.
YES THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN-
I JUST WANT TO SAY RIGHT HERE
AND RIGHT NOW- THAT- AND THEN
THE TO ME THE MOST. TIME
SENSITIVE IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS BILL. IS A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT SETBACK BECAUSE
THAT IS REALLY WHAT IS REALLY
HARMING. SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
RIGHT NOW- AND SO IT'S I AM
GLAD TO HEAR YOU KNOW CENTER
EGGMAN. HER COMMENTS ABOUT THE
SEPT SIX SEPARATE PIECES OF THE
BILL. AND AS I SAID TO
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS AND I'VE
SAID EARLIER IN THIS HEARING-
WE ARE- NOT DOCTRINAIRE. ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL WE WANT
TO GET A STRONG BILL
PARTICULARLY THE SETBACKS. FIVE
THROUGH. BUT IN TERMS OF FROM
NINE AM TAX I TALKED ABOUT SOME
OF THE HEALTH ISSUES- WE DO
HAVE- DAN RUSS FROM THE- CENTER
FOR REYES PARTY ENVIRONMENT-
WHO COULD FLUSH OUT- SOME MY
COMMENTS BECAUSE THIS IS ZERO
P. IS A GROUP THAT. IS ON THE
GROUND WORKING WITH THESE FRONT
LINE COMMUTERS EVERYDAY AND WE
HEARD FROM ONE FLOOR AS-
EARLIER TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACTS ON. HIS COMMUNITY. AND
HIS FAMILY. IBERIANS IN THAT
I'LL I MEAN YOU BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER- CUTTING BACK THE
SETBACK- AMOUNT A LITTLE BIT SO
AS TO GET MORE MEMBERS TO FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE- SO WE I THINK
ON THE OIL PRODUCTION SO ORINDA
REAL. EXTRACTION SIDE. WHICH
WOULD SHOW FLEXIBILITY WE HAVE
MORE FLEXIBILITY- ON THE SEPT
BACKSIDE- YOU KNOW I'D I'D WANT
TO CONSULT WITH OUR- WITH OUR
SPONSORS ON THAT NO ONE HAS
SUGGESTED. YEAH BEFORE THIS
HEARING SO WE HAVE NOT HAD
THAT. CONVERSATION BUT I YOU
KNOW I LIKE THIS I THINK WE DO
HAVE FLEXIBILITY- WE WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE AN IMPACTFUL BILL. FIVE
THROUGH WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE.
RELIGIOUS ABOUT YOU KNOW EXACT.
NUMBERS OR OR WHATEVER- BUT I
WANT TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
IF THERE WERE IF THOUGHT WOULD-
YEAH AND YOU KNOW IMPACT BOTH
FOR THE RESULT IN THIS
COMMITTEE. WERE ABSOLUTELY OPEN
TO THE ACCOUNT AND I WILL SAY
THAT IT HAS COME UP TO ME FROM
MEMBER FROM FOLKS IN THE TRADES
NOT THAT THEY YOU KNOW NOT EVER
GONNA FALL UNDER THIS TALE. BUT
BUT THAT THAT THEY THEY THEY
DID FEEL AS THOUGH THE SET BACK
ABOUT THE HOUSE RIGHT NOW TWO
HUNDRED. FETUSES THIS BILL IS.
WAS IT WAS STICKING POINT FOR
SOME OF THEM. YET I- WHICH IS
THAT- YOU THAT- THIS IS A MOUNT
THAT'S BEEN IN PRETTY BILL IT
IS BASED ON SOME SO BUT BUT WE
WILL WILLING TO HAVE A CAR.
VOMITED WANT TO CONSULT WITH
MY- WITH MY SPONSORS ON THEM
ANYWAY VERY SOON HEARING THE
COMMENTS ON FROM AN INDUCTION
THE CENTER. YEAH SO THE- DAN
RASA AS ONLINE. HI YES THANK
YOU SANDERS- SO I THINK THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF DIFFERENT IMPACTS
PREVENT MILLION RESIDENTS WE
LOOK AT INCREASED PRETERM
BIRTHS. INCREASED BIRTH DEFECTS-
WHAT WE LOOK AT INCREASE HAS
ALREADY IT'S- INCREASED CANCER
RATES- YOU KNOW THERE'S THE IN
THESE ATTACKS MANY OF THEM GO
OUT- YOU KNOW TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET ONE KILOMETER TWO
KILOMETERS THREE KILOMETERS
EVEN FARTHER- AND- YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDIES ABOUT
AIR POLLUTION BUT SEEMS TO BE
KIND OF THE- EASIEST PART TO
STUDY. AT THE MOMENT- CONSIDER
SIMPSON GREAT RESEARCH SHOWING-
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AIR
POLLUTION AFFECTS UP TO THREE
COMMERCE- WHAT'S A LITTLE BIT
TOUGHER TO STUDY IS A WATER
POLLUTION IMPACTS WHICH ARE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT AND SEEM TO
BE REALLY IMPACTING
GROUNDWATER- ALSO SOIL HEALTH
OF THE AT THE SAME TIME- AND I
JUST HAD TO- THERE'S- BUDGET- A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE. JUST KIND
OF THE DAILY PROBLEMS NOSE
BLEEDS- YOU KNOW HEADACHES
PEOPLE DOES NOT FEELING WELL
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT ABLE TO
FOCUS IN SCHOOL PEOPLE JUST
MISSING DAYS OF WORK BEING SICK
ALL THESE THINGS INCREASE AS A
RESULT OF BURNING GAS
EXTRACTION NEAR HOMES SCHOOLS.
PLAYGROUNDS. AND SO ON IF YOU.
OKAY COMPLETE YOUR QUESTION
CENTERED AROUND. NO IT'S
HELPFUL AND MAKE YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT'S ULTIMATELY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET OUT AND
ADDRESSING THIS CHALLENGE THANK
YOU I HAVE A REQUEST TO SPEAK
FROM SENATOR LEE MARTIN. AND I
SEE THERE SHE'S ON MUTE CORRECT.
WELCOME. SOMEHOW IT'S NOT ON
MUTED TOTALLY AGAIN. TO HAVE
SOMETHING ON YOUR OWN COMPUTERS
TO SOUND DOWN IS SOMETHING
GOING ON THERE. BECAUSE WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU. IS THERE
SOMEBODY HERE IN THE ROOM THAT
DOES TAX STUFF THAT CAN HELP US
WITH SENATOR LIMON. YEAH. THOSE
TEXT. IT KEEPS SHOWING US
CENTER WE MOAN THAT IT'S ON
MUTE IT AND THEN WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU ARE YOU SURE THERE'S
NOTHING ON YOUR OWN COMPUTER
THE DISLIKE MUTING THIS.
WHATEVER VOEPEL RIGHT BACK IN.
COMMENT OKAY THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
YOU GO OUT AND COME BACK IN
CENTER EARLY MONTEL THOUGH I
THINK WE WERE CLOSE TO THE LAST
ONE SO IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WISHES TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL. ALL IN ORDER TO HOLD FOR
CENTER WOMAN COMING BACK. ALL.
ALL.
THE. SENATE-ROOM ON HIS
BACK CAN WE HEAR YOU. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE IN ALL YOUR
GLORY. WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU CHAIR I
APPRECIATED AND I APPRECIATE
THE PATIENCE WITH ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND EVEN HEARING
FROM OTHER FOLKS HAVE CALLED
IN. I REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT
HAS A LONG HISTORY WITH OIL
PRODUCTION DATING BACK TO THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS BOTH THE
RENTER AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES AND- WHEN THE AUTHORED
SPOKE TO ME ABOUT HIS
INTENTION- AND HAVING REALLY A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL I
AGREED TO COME ON. AS A JOINT
AUTHORS AND DID SO BECAUSE OF
THE HISTORY THAT MY DISTRICT
HAS- WITH OIL EXTRACTION AND
TRANSPORT REALLY AND- MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT I'VE WORKED ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES IN THIS
PARTICULAR SPACE AND- ISSUES
THAT REALLY ARE DRIVEN BY THAT
HISTORY IN MY DISTRICT WHERE WE
WENT FROM RELYING SO MUCH- AS A
COMMUNITY ON THIS FORM- OF OIL
EXTRACTION FOR JOBS TO ALSO
FEELING AND LIVING. A LOT OF
THE IMPACTS WE'VE TALKED THE
WORD IMPACT HAS BEEN USED SO
MUCH TODAY- EMAIL WITH MEMBERS-
AND WITH FOLKS CALLING IN AND
THE IMPACT HAS VERY- THERE HAVE
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING IMPACTS AT TO OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE FORMS
OF EXTRACTION- WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE FRACKING- ANYMORE WE DO
HAVE A CYCLIC STEAMING LOW LOW
PRESSURE A CYCLIC STEAMING. AND
THAT YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT PARTS
OF THE DISTRICT LIKE TRACK
CANYON THAT RANK AMONG THE TOP
ONE PERCENT- FOR GROUND WATER
THREATS BECAUSE OF THIS FORM.
TRACTION ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT. SO IT'S REALLY WITH
THIS PERSPECTIVE- IN
UNDERSTANDING- WHAT IT MEANS TO
HAVE A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
RELIED ON EXTRACTION AND ALSO.
A COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN
IMPACTED INTO MANY WAYS- AND I
DID STILL BE. YOU KNOW I'VE
HEARD ON THE LOT OF WHAT
EVERYONE SAID TO DATE I INCLUDE
THOSE THAT CALLED IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AND THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL EXIST. AS
ALLOWED FOR THIS LEVEL OF
DISCUSSION AND IF THERE'S NOT A
BILL THERE'S NOT A DISCUSSION.
AND THESE ARE REALLY DIFFICULT
DISCUSSIONS I MEAN WE'RE
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS OF WHAT
DOES THE TIMELINE LOOKS FOR IS
IT THIRTEEN YEARS IS IT MORE IS
THAT LAST FOR WHAT FORMS OF
EXTRACTION IN WHAT PARTS OF THE
STATE WHAT KINDS OF AN IMPACT
WOULD THAT HAVE. WHAT DOES JUST
TRANSITION MEAN. TO OUR STATE
AND TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. I
HAVE HAD SOME VERY DIFFICULT
BUT IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY LOCAL I HAVE TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO PARTNERS EIGHT OH
FIVE TO LABOUR'S FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE AND TWO TWENTY TWO YOU A
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS ONE
FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR. A. B. W.
YOU KNOW FOR THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE SHEET METAL WORKERS. THEY
ALL HAVE HARD CONVERSATIONS
WITH ME AND THEY ALL ASKED ME
MONIQUE WHY DID YOU DO THIS WHY
DID YOU PUT YOUR NAME ON THIS
BILL. AND GIVEN THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAD. AND I
SAID LOOK THE PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT INCLUDING YOU HAVE
ASKED ME TO MOVE FORWARD HARD
CONVERSATIONS. AND THIS IS ONE
OF THEM. I COMMEND THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN DIFFICULT
THERE HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW NAME
CALLING THREATS ACCUSATIONS ALL
OF THIS THAT IS COME WITH
CARRYING A BILL THIS STATE-
AND- I THINK IT'S ALLOWED FOR
AN IMPORTANT TEST DISCUSSION. A
DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
I DON'T WANT CALIFORNIANS I
DON'T WANT WORKERS TO BE LEFT
BEHIND WE CAN LOOK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND SEE PLACES WHERE
WORKERS HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND.
AND I WANTED TO SEE AT THE
TABLE TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
BECAUSE I FEEL SO STRONGLY THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD LEAD THE WAY.
CALIFORNIA WORKERS SHOULD NOT
BE LEFT BEHIND THAT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD ENGAGE. IN THIS
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION. I THINK
TODAY. YOU KNOW THE OUTCOME OF
THIS BILL AND HE- WILL AT.
REALLY AND TASTES OF WHERE THE
LEGISLATIVE APPETITE- OF WHERE
WE MAY FALL BUT IT WON'T BE THE
END OF THE CONVERSATION. JUST
LOOK AROUND. THERE ARE PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY THE STATE
IN THE WORLD THAT ARE BEGGING
FOR THIS CONVERSATION THAT ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
FUTURE OF ENERGY LOOKS LIKE.
AND I AM CONFIDENT THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL REMAIN
DESPITE WHATEVER MAY BE THE
OUTCOME OF THIS CALL THIS BILL.
I AM VOTING FOR THIS BILL I AM
I JOIN AUTHOR WITH EITHER OUT
YOU KNOW WITH THE US THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND I HOPE
THAT WE WILL ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT- IT'S DIFFICULT TO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS BUT IT'S
NONETHELESS IMPORTANT AND THERE
IS VALUE IN LEGISLATIVE REVIEW
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS.
LEGISLATIVE DIALOGUE. AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE I LAND.
BUT I WANT TO GIVE THANKS US IN
PARTICULAR TO THE AUTHOR-
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
HAS BEEN TO CARRY A BILL OF
THIS MAGNITUDE AND I KNOW HOW
HARD AND HOW MUCH HE HAS WORK
TO TRY TO LISTEN TO ALL SIDES.
AND FIND A WAY TO KEEP THIS
DISCUSSION ALIVE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENT.
ANYTHING ELSE FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR JOHN.
IT'S JUST A QUICK QUESTION
BECAUSE SOONER YOU'RE- A
CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL AND-
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE. HE YOU
ALWAYS. BRING TOUGH ISSUES TO
US AND THEN. PRISON I'M IN A
VERY PROFESSIONAL MANNER AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE ONE THING
THAT WAS COMPELLING TO ME FROM
YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE
SOME OF THE CHILDHOOD ILLNESSES
THAT THEY WERE BRINGING UP AND-
AND OTHER ILLNESSES. I GAVE UP
HIS MAGIC NUMBER SOME ADULT.
STUFF TOO. CAN YOU JUST BRIEFLY.
WHAT WHAT THAT INFORMATION COME
FROM IS IT IS A SCIENTIFIC
STUDY IS IT WHERE IT IS. ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES HOW DO YOU WRITE
TO THOSE ISSUES AND THOSE
NUMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN QUOTED
BY YOUR- SUPPORT WITNESSES.
SURE THAT. SEVEN FIVE IT COMES
OUR SCIENTIFIC STUDIES OUR BEEN
ENORMOUS NUMBER THE NORMA'S
AMOUNT OF LITERATURE- AROUND
THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF- OF OIL
DRILLING ON PEOPLE'S HEALTH-
AND- INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO- THE BUFFER ZONE OF SETBACKS
ISSUE- AND THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET AS I MENTIONED
RESPOND TO CENTER ALAN'S
QUESTION WAS NOT A RANDOM
NUMBER THAT COMES FROM-
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS- AND SO YOU
KNOW IN SOME WOULD ARGUE FOR
GREATER BUFFER ZONE BUT- BUT WE
THOUGHT THAT THAT. YOU KNOW
MATCH UP WITH THE EVIDENCE- SO
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT LITERATURE
I THINK SOME OF IT IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY CITED AN ANALYSIS I
CAN'T REMEMBER BUT WE CERTAINLY
HAVE IT. AND IT'S- IT'S READILY
AVAILABLE. OKAY I'LL GET TO
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GROW. JUST ON FOLLOW UP
ON MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
DIEGO'S QUESTION- HE HAS ANY I.
R. IT'S BEEN VETTED NOW BEEN
TESTED BY LAWSUIT ANYWAYS- THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE A SCIENCE BASED
SIX PACK A REGULATORY PROCESS-
IN THE STATE SHOULD ACTUALLY
MODEL IT- IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU BUT- WE HAVE
A COMPLETE E. I ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. BY CONSERVATIVE
ADDRESSES THAT PARDON ME SIR
ARTHUR WRITTEN SO THAT
ADDRESSES THE SETBACK ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
ELSE FROM SENATORS. SENATOR
WINNER YOU CAN CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I THINK IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
APOLOGIZE IF I- MISINTERPRETING
I THINK CENTER KIRBY REFERRING
TO- THE MOST RECENT KERN
COUNTY- APPROACH WHICH I THINK
IS A TWO OR THREE HUNDRED FOOT.
ON SETBACK MAYBE I'M WRONG BUT
NEVER CAN TALK AFTERWARDS TO
CLARIFY IT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING
KERN COUNTY JUST APPROVED TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF IN THE FUTURE
FOR THE FUTURE- OF NEW DRILLING
SIS IS NOT LIKE. YOU KNOW THE
INDUSTRY ASSIST TAPERING OFF
LIKE KERN COUNTY IS ACTIVELY
APPROVING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
NEW OIL DRILLING PERMITS- WITH-
I THINK IF I RECALL CORRECTLY I
THOUGHT IT WAS TWO OR THREE
HUNDRED FOOT BUFFER ZONE. AND I
THINK YOU KNOW ON THE SUSPECT'S
PIECES BILL AND HIS WIFE SAID
THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF THE BILL AND WE HAVE
FLEXIBILITY ON THIS BILL- IT'S
ON ON SWITCH OFF SWITCHES ARE
SET TO SOME MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
IF YOU WENT AROUND NOT JUST IN
THE IMPACTED AREAS BUT AROUND
CALIFORNIA. TO LA TO THE BAY
AREA- THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
TO KNOW WE VALLEY INSURANCE YOU
WANT AROUND TO THE STATE AND
SAID WHAT DO YOU TINK ABOUT
SOMEONE DRILLING FOR OIL A.
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FEET FROM
YOUR HOME. WHAT DO YOU ABOUT
SOMEONE DREW FOR OIL. A HUNDRED
HUNDRED FROM THEIR KIDS SCORE
PLAYGROUND I BET YOU MOST
PARENTS WOULD SAY IF THEY HAVE
A PRIVILEGE. AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OFTEN
DON'T HAVE THIS PRIVILEGE. A
LOT OF PARENTS TO SAY I WOULD
PULL MY KID OUT OF THAT SCHOOL
IF THEY HAVE THE PRIVILEGE. OF
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT OR I
WOULD NOT LET MY KID PLAY AT
THE PLAYGROUND. WITH AN OIL
DRILLING- WE'RE WELL ONE
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FEET AWAY.
I THINK PEOPLE. IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE NOT IN THOSE FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES OFTEN DO NOT KNOW.
THE CALIFORNIA HAS NO BUFFER
ZONE. AND THEY ARE HORRIFIED.
WHEN THEY HEAR THAT IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS LEGAL TO DRILL
NEXT TO SOMEONE'S HOME NEXT
YEAR COULD SCHOOL. NEXT TO A
PLAYER AND THAT IS IN
DEFENSIBLE. INDEFENSIBLE I'M
ONE TEXAS. HAS SET BACKS IN
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T. I THINK
THAT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF NO
OFFENSE TO TEXAS. SO COLLEAGUES
THIS IS CENTRE LIMóN SAID THIS
BILL IS YOU KNOW IN MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND
JUST TRANSITION IT'S PART OF IT
AND FRANKLY I DON'T THINK THAT
YOU CAN SOLVE EVERYTHING. COULD
JUST TRANSITION ONE BILL AND
THAT'S WHY THESE OTHER TWO
BILLS FROM CENTER LOAN FROM
CENTER STERN. THESE BILLS ALL
DOVETAIL TOGETHER IN MANY WAYS
AND COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S- IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE
DO A MOTION. SO OF. MOVED BY
STERN- WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE S. B.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT BUT- RE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
LAYERED HI ALL RIGHT JONES
JONES NO ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN EGGMAN NO GROWTH. GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG NOT ONLY. HUESO
LIMON. AN EARLY MON S. B. FOUR
SIX SEVEN I. MON HIS STERN AYE
STERN HI THIS. OKAY WE HAVE
FOUR VOTES WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL. IN OF FOR GOING TO WITH
THE ROOM TO ONE O'CLOCK I KNOW
SOME OF US WILL SNEAK UP CAUCUS.
AND BACK BUT I'M GOING TO MOVE
TO- SENATOR GLAZERS BILL
SENATOR HUESO IT'S GOING TO
TAKE OVER CHAIRING WILL I GO
AND TALK TO THE CAUCUS AND THEN
I WILL COME BACK. AND ALL TRY
TO. NOW WITH HAVE MUCH TIME WE
GO A MONTH. THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO TAKE OF. THE NEXT
BILLING SENATOR GLAZERS. S. B.
EIGHT ZERO FOUR. RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
SENATE GLAZER BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY AND IF WE CAN- GERMAN IF
YOU CAN JUST MOVE YOUR
CONVERSATION OUTSIDE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
GLAZER PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU CHAIR- WAY- PERSON WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE IN THE
STAFF FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK
ON THIS BILL. AND I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED SB EIGHT OH FOUR WOULD
CREATE A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CENTER TO TRAIN FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IN
FORESTRY IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. ACCORDING TO CAL
FIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE AN
ESTIMATED FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION ACRES BURNED DUE TO
WILDFIRES THESE FIRES DAMAGED
OVER TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
BECAUSE THIRTY THREE
FATALITIES. THIS COMES AFTER
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH
WERE THE DEADLIEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. RECOGNIZING THAT THE
DANGERS OF WILDFIRE WERE ONLY
INCREASING THE SENATE CREATED.
THE WILD FAR WORKING GROUP AND
INTRODUCED A BUDGET FRAMEWORK
THE PRIORITIZE FIRE PREVENTION
AND RESPONSE EFFORTS. SB EIGHT
OH FOUR ACCOMPLISHES SEVERAL OF
THE GOALS LAID OUT BY THIS
WORKING GROUP. WITH
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
CENTER WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE
GOAL OF EXPANDING THE WORK
FORCE AND IMPLEMENTING A
VEGETATION AND FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THIS PROGRAM
WOULD NOT ONLY WORK TOWARDS
REDUCING THE TOLL OF WILDFIRES.
BUT WOULD ALSO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATES AND CREATE A
PATHWAY TO GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE COMPLETED.
CONFINEMENT IN LOCAL JAILS OR
STATE INSTITUTIONS. CURRENTLY
THE INCARCERATED AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED ALREADY PLAY AN
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. THE W.
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT REPORTS
AT DAVIS SAFELY ASSIGNED
THOUSANDS OF INMATES TO FIRE
CAMPS. UNDER THIS BILL THE
CENTER WOULD TRAIN A MUCH
NEEDED WORK FORCE TO DECREASE
FUEL LOADS AND IMPROVE FOREST
HEALTH TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
AND WILDFIRE REDUCTION GOALS. I
WANT TO THANK OUR SENATE CO
AUTHORS SENATORS BECKER CENTER
CABALLERO MCGUIRE SKINNER AND
SENATOR WIENER WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS- MACHEL GARCIA
OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND FIRE CHIEF DAVID
WINOKUR. OF THE MORAGA ORINDA
FIRE DISTRICT THANK YOU THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU OF. WE HAVE
MICHELLE GARCIA AND DAVID WOULD
OCCUR THERE IS NO WILL. LEAD
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS ARE SPEAK
TO SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL WE'RE
GOING TO BEG BEGIN. WITH ALL
THE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
INCLUDING THE- LEADS US
SPEAKERS BEGINNING WITH A
MATURE GARCIA. THIS GARCIA-
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE GARCIA I AM
THE PROGRAM COORDINATOR VENTURA
TRAINING CENTER WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. ALSO
KNOWN AS ERC HERE IN SUPPORT
AND SB EIGHT ZERO FOUR. AARON
HE WORKS TO END MASS
INCARCERATION IN CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE
HEALTHY ANIMAL. THERE ARE THREE
EMPOWERS FORMERLY AND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO THRIVE
BY PROVIDING A SUPPORT NETWORK
COMPREHENSIVE REENTRY SERVICES.
AND OPPORTUNITIES. TO ADVOCATE
FOR POLICY CHANGE. AFTER THE
POLICY ADDRESS AND ADVOCACY WE
ARE DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO
THAT IT IS MORE JOBS AND EQUAL
FOR ALL PEOPLE. AND THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AIRSPEED. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY FIRE PROTECTION ALSO
KNOWN AS CAL FIRE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
CDC ARE DEVELOPING ENHANCED
FIRE FIGHTING TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM AT THE
CENTER I TRAINING CENTER.
PARTICIPANTS AT BKC OUR FORMER
OFFENDERS ON PAROLE WHO HAD
RECENTLY BEEN PART OF A TRAINED
FIREFIGHTING WORK ALRIGHT HOUSE
INSPIRED HIM OUR INSTITUTIONAL
FIRE HOUSES OPERATED BY CAL
FIRE AND CDCR. I HAVE DEVOTED
MY LIFE TO SUPPORT THE CURRENT
AND PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
AFTER SERVING TIME MYSELF WHERE
I EVENTUALLY PAROLED I'VE BEEN
INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTER IN
MALIBU CALIFORNIA. HERE THE
BACK BIG GREEN BACK BREAKING
WORK AT BEING IN SERVICE TO MY
COMMUNITY I THINK INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTER I WAS ABLE TO FIND
I FOUNDATION TO MY HEALING
AFTER BEING DEEPLY TRAUMATIZED
AND CHRISTEN WHEREVER STRIPPED
OF MY DIGNITY. WE MOVED FROM
THE LIFE OF MY FOUR CHILDREN
AND LEFT WITH YEARS OF SHAME
AND FEAR CONFIDENCE. TO
MANEUVER THROUGH. THIS CAME
LIVING OUT MY IN. PROTECTING
THOSE COMMUNITY I BROUGHT HARM
TO. BRITAIN IS NOT BUILT TO
BRING ESPECIALLY WHEN. SO TO
THINK THAT MY TENURE FORMA
PRISON CERTAIN SENTENCE FIRE
CAMP SEEM LIKE THE ONLY CHANCE
THINK MY- SOME ST AND MOST
IMPORTANT MY FAMILY. SIMILAR TO
MY- AT FIRE CAMP THE
PARTICIPANTS AT BTC ARE ABLE TO
FIND OUR HIGHER SELVES. THEY
SPEND ENDLESS HOURS WORKING
SIDE BY SIDE WITH CAL FIRE
CHIEF AND CAPTAIN THAT
CONTINUOUSLY REMIND THEM OF
THEIR VALUE AND WORK YEAH
BEFORE LONG EIGHT PICK UP THE
SAME HABITS. THAT THEY AND THEY
BEGIN TO SEE THE SIMILARITIES
INSTEAD OF THE DIFFERENT SAID.
AFTER A FEW MONTHS YOU SEE THE
MAN WALK A LITTLE TALLER SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT MORE COMPETENTLY
AND DIG A LITTLE DEEPER INTO
THEIR HEALING UP THEIR OWN
TRAUMA FOR THEMSELVES. AND ALSO
FOR THEIR FAMILY. ARCEGA AND I
REALLY HAD TO ENTER YOU MU
MAKING REALLY COMMON- DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THERE'S A
THREE MINUTE LIMIT ON. COMMENTS
FOR ORGANIZED PRESENT
PRESENTERS BOB THE TO THE PET.
AT THE POWER IT SECOND
CHAMPIONSHIP SOMETHING YOU
CAN'T TRACE THE DOCUMENT AND SB
EIGHT OAK OR REPRESENT
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PHARMACY INCARCERATED TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF REPENTANCE
LEVINE. AND THEREFORE IT IS FOR
THESE REASONS AND SO MANY MORE
THAT WE ARGUED ABOUT YEAH. PART
OF THAT YEP BY THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. NOW NOW WILL GO TO
DAVID WOULD OCCUR. CONNECT MR.
THE OF THE- DAY ONE AT THE OF
THE MY- DEPARTMENT YOUR
SPEAKING SUPPORT OF S. T. A. OH
FOUR AS A FIRE CHIEF FINANCIAL
WITH THE- THIS. COMMUTE AND
ALLOW URBAN INTERFACE. ON THE
AFFECTED UNCONTROLLED WILDFIRE.
AS PART OF MY JOB A. IN TIME
EFFORT TO THE STATE OF WILD.
THREAT TO THIS. AND ON THE
GROUND. AND I BELIEVE THE
PROBLEM AS WELL THE SOLUTION IS
WELL UNDER. SHARES NATURAL
RECALL PART OF WESTERN. BUT FOR
MOST OF THE PASSENGER WE'VE
TRIED TO EXCLUDE IT. IS TOTALLY
BUILT ON THE WILDERNESS AREA.
THERE WAS. IF YOU WILL THAT
WILL KERRY EXTREME FIRE. YOU
MIGHT GET THE SAME TIME CLIMATE
CHANGES ACROSS THE LINES. WE
NOW TO THE BILL COMING DUE IN
THE FALL OF MAJOR. YOUR YEAR.
IF YOU'LL KERRY FLOWERS THE
HOME AND BUSINESSES BECAUSE-
IMPERATIVE TO FIGHT THEM.
MISTRUST OF ONE WHICH MAKES
PROPERTY EVER MORE DIFFICULT TO
ENSURE I'M NOT GOING AWAY. THIS
IS A PROBLEM WHICH MUST BE
ADDRESSED. IN MY JURISDICTION
WE ANALYZE THE REST UPDATED
SERVICE NAPSTER PRIORITIZE MOST
SUPPORT PROJECTS ADOPTED MORE
STRINGENT PERSON START CREEK.
PLANT NEXT. COMMITTEE SCALED
BACK DURATION EXERCISES. IN THE-
AGGRESSIVE YOUR- CAMPAIGN.
MAINTAINED AFTER. ENTRY BY THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF PRESCRIBED
pRISK COMES FROM THE WILDERNESS
PLAN SURROUNDINGS THEIR YEARS
SINCE OUR OUR SUPPRESSION
DEFERRED FUEL MANAGEMENT
ALLOWED VEGETATION TO
ACCUMULATE TO LEVELS MAKE
PRESCRIBES ARE UNACCEPTABLY
DANGEROUS. ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS ARE CLEAR CUTTING
BULLDOZING OR CHEMICALLY
TREATING WHILE NAY. THE ONLY
FEASIBLE SOLUTIONS DEPLOYMENT
WELL TRAINED HAND CREWS TO
UNDERTAKE THE LABORIOUS PROCESS
OF PLANNING CONTRIBUTION TO
TRADING CONTROL ONCE. SETTING
THE STAGE FOR OUT YOUR
PRESCRIBED FIRE TO CREATE A
VERY FEW MOSAIC WHICH
CHARACTERIZED. OUR STATE BEFORE
EUROPEAN DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
AREA AS IN MOST- URBAN AREAS
STATE. YOUR YOUR RESOURCE A COP
THIS TASK SIMPLY NOT EXIST.
BRINGING CREWS FROM OTHER
STATES ARE JUST. AREAS ACROSS
FROM HIM FOR SMALL TO MIDSIZE
PROJECTS. AT THE SAME TIME I
TRAINED ME. PEOPLE SAID IDLE IN
OUR MEDIA. CENTER BECAUSE THEY
EXTRA IN THE PRE. HELD CALL.
WERE WHILE WEARING ORANGE NO
HONEST SEE OUR CREW. THE OPERA.
TO OFFER THEM. AND ON PATHWAY
FAMILIES IN CAREERS AT SAME
TIME THAT WE CAN OUR OVER. YOUR
CHU. TO GOOD TO BE MATCHED. I
URGE YOU TO PASS A B. AS- EIGHT
FOUR WITH DELAY TO UNLOCK THE
OCT. FOR THE FIERY REDUCTION.
STYLE REAR INTO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL MOVE TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT ZERO FOUR- IF THERE ARE
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND IN
FAVOR OF S. B. EIGHT ZERO FOUR
pTHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED. OKAY
WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO
ONE SEEMS TO BE- LINING UP
THERE- SO WOULD NOW GO TO THE
MODERATOR IN ASKING THE
MODERATOR TO KEEP TO THE
PUBLIC. FIVE FOUR SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR OF SB SIX OH FOUR. FIFTY
FATAL FORUMS ARE NATO. FOR
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN THEY
GENERALLY PRODUCE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT OH FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST FINDS TO BE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ESPANA AS A WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRPERSON ONE
MOMENT. I WANT TO GET MEASURE
INTRODUCED US PORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FROM HAVE ONE PARTY IN Q. WE'RE
GOING TO BUILD CAROLINUM FOR
FIVE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS DEBBIE MICHAEL
ON BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT ARE
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL YET TO BUY IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR- VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PRIORITIES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OSCAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. FOR AND WHILE A WORK QUEUE
IN A NEW SPEAKERS OF JUST ONE
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO REMEMBER TO
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL WE'RE
WORKING ON AS P. ETAL FOUR
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
AMATEUR PERSON WE HAVE NOBODY
ELSE THANK YOU. VERY WELL WILL
MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF US PEDRO FOR.
NONE PRESIDENT WILL GROUP MOVED
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS
PRESENT THERE EITHER WILL MOVE
TO THE PUBLIC. FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT OH FOUR
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF IT- FOR. THANK
YOU ONE CAN LADIES GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT
OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OR THE LINE
OF FIVE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS AS A DOG
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS MISTER CHAIRMAN I
PLEASE JUST HAVE A MOMENT TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT THE CPF
SUPPOSE ALMOST AMENDED POSITION
AND OUR ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH HER GLAZER ABSOLUTELY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
CENTER GLAZER HIS STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE WITH US IN OUR LOCAL
AFFILIATES ON SB EIGHT OH FOUR.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WE CAN FIND A
MUTUALLY AGREEABLE SOLUTION OUR
CONCERNS OF THE MEASURE MOVES
FORWARD. AS CONTEXT CPF WAS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY TWENTY NINETEEN- JUST
ALISTAIR EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
RE ENTRY PROGRAM UNDER CHAPTER
FOUR POINT FIVE A DIVISION
TWELVE OF THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE. THE REASON AMENDMENTS TO
SP EIGHT OH FOUR AD THE
PROPOSAL TO CHAPTER FOUR POINT
FIVE AN OUTLINE THE FOCUS ON
FORESTRY RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
TRAINING. WE BELIEVE THAT IS A
PRUDENT APPROACH AND APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS OF. THE MEASURE WITH
THAT SAID WE BELIEVE THERE IS A
NEED TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT REFERS TO FIRE
SUPPRESSION EMERGENCY INCIDENT
RESPONSE OF INTER TRAINING
SESSION CENTER- TO ALIGN WITH
THE CODE AND THE FOREST AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FOCUS.
ALSO WE WANT TO WORK TO ENSURE
QUALIFYING EXPERIENCE MEANS ANY
STATE AGENCY REQUIREMENTS ARE
HIGHER FORESTRY CONCESSIONS.
FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH THE CAN COMMITTEE ON SOME-OF THE LANGUAGE PROPOSED- IN
THE IN THE A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO ALIGN WITH THE
CURRENT CONSERVATION CRAP
PROGRAM THROUGH. EXCUSE ME
CONSERVATION CAMP PROGRAM CREW
TERMS ARE ALREADY USED IN THE
CODE. AS NOTED WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CENTER GLAZER AND
HIS TEAM'S LONG US TO WORK WITH
US- AND LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING
A SOLUTION AS THIS.
MEASUREMENTS FOR WORK THANK YOU.
VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL TO. A SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITE. ON THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR DO- PLEASE BECAUSE IN
OPPOSITE OF S. B. FOR. AND ONCE
AGAIN RAISED JANET YOUR IN
OPPOSITION S. T. ETAL FOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND AT THIS TIME
INTEREST. CHIPPERS WE HAVE
NOBODY IN Q. OKAY VERY WELL
WILL MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S BETWEEN YOU AND
I GO. I JUST WANT TO SAY I
THINK THERE'S A GREAT BILL I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL. HI I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND JUST- MAKING
SURE THE LANGUAGE IT MAKES VERY
CLEAR. THAT WE DON'T REALLY GET
INTO A- INTO A OF. A DEFINITION
OF WHAT A FIREFIGHTER IS WE
WANT HIM. STAY VERY FAR AWAY
FROM THAT GREAT LINE YES- I'M
SURE YOU WORK ON IT CENTER
GLAZER I TRUST THAT YOU WILL
AND I TRUST AT ONE POINT- THE-
THE FIREFIGHTERS WILL WILL FEEL
COMFORTABLE AS WELL THAT WE
DON'T GET INTO A- AN ISSUE
PROFESSIONS. SO- IF A DID YOU
WANT TO SAY SOME **** CENTER
YES UP SIR AND I DO APOLOGIZE
NO NOT A PROBLEM NOT FROM THE
FREEZIE NOT PROBLEMS GO AHEAD
AND GO TO MY OFFICE AND GET A
JACKET I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. ALSO I THINK THE OTHER
FOR PUTTING HEAVY EMPHASIS ON
HAND CURSOR PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO.
AND BE TRYING TO GET THESE JOBS
I THINK THE BEST SOLUTION FOR
ANY SITUATION WHETHER IT'S
POVERTY PREVIOUS INCARCERATED
KEEP THEM RECIDIVISM RATES IS A
JOB AND HAVE A THAT'S THE BEST
SOLUTION EVER SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT SIR AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT IT'S AN HONOR TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER HERTZBERG.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO JOIN THE
WITH THE CHAIRMAN'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE FIREFIGHTERS I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAME ISSUE
THAT HE RAISED I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE YOU TODAY WITH THE-
ADMONITION THAT I WANT TO
RESERVE MY RIGHT NOT TO VOTE
FOR IT. YEAH ON THE FLOOR IN
THE BILL WE CAN'T SOLVE THAT
ISSUE OF THESE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT ALL CORNY COMEDY CHU
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE THAT
CLEAR AND JOIN IN WITH. A
MISTER HUESO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE. THERE THERE ANYWAY- AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SOME FINAL
COMMENTS- IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONVERSE CONS CONSERVATION
CORPS IS NO GOOD WORK THEY'RE
DOING WHY CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
TAP INTO NOT ONLY THEIR TALENT
BUT ALSO THEIR PREPARATION AND
PREPARING THEM FOR FUTURE WORK
FORCE AND THIS IS THESE ARE
WONDERFUL EDUCATIONAL AND
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM SITE
REALLY APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS
THAT'S WHY I'M I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER. OF THE CONSERVATION
COURSE I WANT TO ADD ON THIS CO
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL. SO IF
THERE AREN'T ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS- SOLUTION JONES MOVES
THE BILL. AND CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND I CLOSE SORRY
APPLE YES PLEASE SORRY ABOUT
THAT- I WANT TO PUT ON THE
RECORD I'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
CLEAN A DIRECT CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY I'M VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN NOT RESOLVE ALL THE
OF REMAINING ISSUES I THINK
THERE- THAT- POURED INTO THEM
AND I THINK THERE'S NO NO
DIFFICULTY THAT I CAN SEE- AND
GOING THROUGH THE THREE
ELEMENTS THAT HE HE IDENTIFIED-
AND- I WOULD NOTE THAT THE-
THANK YOU FOR THAT SUPPORT
FROM. FROM THE CHAIR AND FROM
OTHERS HI THIS IS A PRIORITY
BILL FOR ME THIS YEAR ON THE
MOST IMPORTANT BILLS THAT I'M
CARING CERTAINLY DOES HAVE SOME
BUDGET IMPACT WE SPENT ALMOST
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FIGHTING
FIRES LAST YEAR I THINK WE CAN
DO A LITTLE MORE PREVENTIVE
WORK AND THIS SPACE THAT I
THINK WE ALL SEE A LOT OF
PRODUCTIVE THINGS HAPPENING IN
LOTS OF. DIFFERENT WAYS SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE OKAY VERY WELL. OF BY
ITEM SIX A B. OH. THEM IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
LAYERED JONES. JONES ALL RIGHT
ALLEN. EGGMAN GROVE. GROVE HIGH
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO
BY. WE SAW ALL RIGHT LIMóN.
STERN FOR. IT'S GOT FOUR FOUR
VOTE TO KEEP THE ROLE ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON LASSEN
HERTZBERG ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT ON S. B. FIVE FIVE TWO.
YES. SB FIVE FIVE TWO IS A BILL
PERTAINING TO DROUGHT PLANNING-
RELATED TO SMALL WATER
SUPPLIERS NON TRANSIENT NON.
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS AND I'M
SURE YOU'LL TELL US WHAT THAT
IS. IF INDEED I WILL MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I WORK ON THIS WATER
ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME AND JUST
VERY BRIEFLY ON ON ISSUES OF
CONSERVATION ALIKE- WITH THE-
GUIDANCE OF YOUR- LEED
CONSULTANT WHO IS QUITE
BRILLIANT. ON THIS WE DID
LEGISLATION A FEW YEARS AGO
WHICH RECORD REPORT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHICH THIS
FOLLOWS UP ON. WE BASICALLY THE
BOTTOM LINE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS SMALL
WATER DISTRICTS THAT ARE- LET
ME JUST LOOK AT THE SIZE THINK
IT'S THE SIZE IN TERMS OF
CUSTOMERS- PRODUCT THE NUMBER
HERE BECAUSE I NEVER LOOK AT MY
NOTES- THROUGH THE ORDINANCE AT
ITS- SMALL DISTRICTS. R. I
THINK IT'S LIKE FIFTEEN TO
THREE THOUSAND OR SOMETHING
SMALLER DISTRICTS WHERE WE'RE
BASICALLY TRYING TO GET THEM TO
PLAN AND WE'RE PUT WE'RE
REQUIRING THEM TO SPEAK TO DO
DETAILED PLANNING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW YOU JUST SAW THE
NUMBERS COMING OUT OF DROUGHT
SAID 525% WE SAW THE DROUGHT
SPOKE FOR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IF WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH THE CREW TOOK
SIGNIFICANT WATER SHORTAGES IN
ALL OF THE CONSEQUENCES
ASSOCIATED THERE WELL WE'VE GOT
A PLAN ORGANIZED. IN THESE
THESE IDEAS CAME OUT OF A
RECOMMENDATION OF A REPORT FROM
A WORKING GROUP ON THE SUBJECT
AND- IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
HOMEWORK IN THIS AREA IT'S
REALLY CLEAN UP MEASURE FROM
THE CENTER FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND I DID A FEW
YEARS AGO. TOGETHER WITH THE-
YOUR CONSULTANT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THE TIME WAS THE
CONSULTATIVE COMMITTEE THAT I
WAS CHAIRING SO. WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE GOT A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES HERE. YOU HAVE ON THE
LIST SERVICE CHAIRMAN. OKAY IF
YOU CAN. OKAY IT'S TIME FOR
THANK YOU OKAY SO YOUR CONTENT
YOUR OPENING COMMON YEAH WE
HAVE- SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. BEGINNING WITH
JONATHAN NELSON AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY DANIELLE PLACES
DEFY PLACES IS THAT HOW YOU
PRONOUNCE- BEGINNING WITH
JONATHAN NELSON NELSON ARE YOU
IN THE- YES I AM THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN NELSON AND I'M THE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION FIGHTING FOR STATE
AND AFFORDABLE WATER ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND ALSO SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS. YOU'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE BY TWO WHICH
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA BE MORE
PREPARED FOR FUTURE DROUGHT
BANCORPORATION BASIC.
COMMONSENSE FRANKLY
RECOMMENDATIONS DEVELOPED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES STATE WATER BOARD AND
THE RESPONSIBLE LAST DROUGHT. I
KNOW WE'RE REALLY TIGHT ON TIME
SO I'LL JUST STATE YOU HAVE THE
DROUGHT- IT'S HERE. YEAH OVER
90% OF STATE IN DROUGHT
CONDITIONS RIGHT NOW AT THE END
GOD FORBID YOU KNOW WE WORK.
DIRECTLY WITH COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE JUST DEVASTATED AND THE
LAST DROUGHT IT WOULD PAINFUL.
WITH FAMILIES IN SOME CASES
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES LOSING
ACCESS TO WATER FOR MONTHS OR
EVEN LONGER AND BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF PRACTICE PLANNING.
CALIFORNIA WITH BLACK
SCRAMBLING TO KEEP UP WITH THAT
LAST DROUGHT EMERGENCY WE HAVE
TO DO BETTER. SO TO CLOSE
FRANKLY THE BILL WHICH AGAIN-
PUTS FORWARD REALLY BASIC
COMMON SENSE RECOMMENDATIONS
LIKE- REQUIRING ARE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE A PROACTIVE
DROUGHT PLAN IN PLACE. THIS IS
THE KIND OF PROPOSAL THAT
SHOULD ALREADY BE LOCKED WE
CAN'T CATCH FIFTY FIVE FIVE TWO
BILLION OUT GIVEN THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
BEFORE IT WE. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND GOOD AFTERNOON. TURN MY OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DANIEL
BY. IN WOOD COUNTY MUNICIPAL
YOU TELL. THAT THAT THE AND WE
WERE. PUBLIC WATER AGENCY AND
PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. EIGHT AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND AT FIVE
THANK YOU AND FOR THE SAKE OF
BREVITY I WILL JUST SAY THAT
TEAM. WAS ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE BILL
THAT SENATOR HERTZBERG
REFERENCE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SB SIX OH THANK WE THANK
THE SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
DURING THAT PROCESS. AND IT WAS
NOTED AT THAT TIME MEANWHILE
LARGER SYSTEMS LIKE MOST
INSANELY REYES MEMBERS EVER
ABOUT WATER SHORTAGE
CONTINGENCY PLANS. MORE DROUGHT
PLANNING IS NEEDED FOR SMALL
WATER SUPPLIERS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE RELIANT ON DOMESTIC
WEALTH. AND WE NEED MORE
PLANNING HAD TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN OUR STATE
EXPERIENCE PRINTER OUT AND
FAMILIES CONTINUE KERR- AND
HERE WE ARE IN DROUGHT
CONDITIONS AGAIN HIGHLIGHTING
THE URGENT NEED FOR SB FIVE
THANK YOU. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TODAY. AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL. NOW MOVE TO SPEAK.
IN SOME OF THE MEASURE. LOOK AT
THE GAS. AND INTERESTED. A NO
SPEAK. LOOKING ROOM ONE TWELVE.
ROOM. ONE TWELVE. DO WE HAVE
ROOM ONE TWELVE AN IMAGE OF
ROOM ONE TWELVE NOBODY IS THERE
WILL NOT GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AND ASK FOR- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT ZERO FOUR
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
FOR. YES AND LATER GERMANY PR
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE MARBLE
FLOOR WITH ONE PERSON Q. FIVE
FIVE TWO. OR YEAH. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON BE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT. HELLO OKAY. I KNOW WHEN
I WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LIT LISTED IS AND
HAS BEEN AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN TOOL FOR. THE NOBODY IS
PRESENT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY HERE
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF. EIGHT ZERO FOUR.
THANK YOU WHAT CANADIAN GERMAN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT WE DID HAVE ONE LINE
NUMBER FIVE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE SEVEN FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN Q. OKAY VERY WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS. HI I
IN PARTICULAR DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS THOSE GOOD
PRESENTATION CONGRATULATIONS-
THROUGH COULD YOU WANNA MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS YOU. I
APOLOGIZE TO YOU ASKING THE
QUESTION A SMALL WATER
SUPPLIERS TO FIND BY THE
MEASURE. IS A COMMUNITY WATER
CLOSE TO MY WHILE. CHECK WHAT
IS HAPPENING- MIGHT MY WALLET
YES WE CAN PLEASE- GO AHEAD
PLEASE IT SERVING FIFTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND NINE OR NINETY AND
SERVICE CONNECTIONS INCLUSIVE
AND LESS THAN THREE THOUSAND
ACRE FEET OF WATER ANNUALLY
THAT'S THE SIZE IT'S THE WHOLE
SO BOTTOM LINE QUICK THING IS
IT THIS MEASURES JUST DOING THE
HOMEWORK TE CLEAN UP OF WHAT
WE DID BEFORE AND I GOT TO TELL
YOU THE GENIUS OF THAT IS BEEN
INFORMED BY DENNIS O'CONNOR'S
WORK. WHO WORKED HIS HEART OUT
PUTTING TOGETHER HUGE MEETINGS
IN MY FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF
MICHAEL DARD I NEVER STEAL THE
CREDIT FROM THE PEOPLE THAT
DESERVE IT WITH THAT ASK YOU
AYE VOTE. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WITH. OR. THE MEDICAL GROUP I'M
SORRY. THE BOSTON. OKAY SENATE
BILL FILE ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE
FIVE TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE LAYERED. HI THERE
TO ALL RIGHT JONES JONES AL
RIGHT ALAN. EGGMAN GROVE
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
HIGHWAY SO HI HUESO HI LOAN.
STERN SKIP FOUR VOTES. OR VOTE
THAT'S FOUR VOTES WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL WE HAVE A HARD STOP
LET'S IN THIS ROOM IN EIGHT
MINUTES AND SO. AND I WANT TO
DO IS LIFT CALLS AND SEE. WHERE
WE CAN GO AND- AND I THINK.
COOL COOL. TAKE A BILL OF ON
THURSDAY- OKAY. BACK YES IN- IF
WE CAN TAKE THEM OUT OF ORDER I
THINK. FILE ITEM FIVE IS ONLY
MISSING SENATOR HUESO IS THAT
CORRECT- WE SAW AND HEARD YES
YES. NO WE GOTTA IF. SO COULD
YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER ON
ITEM FIVE FILE ITEM FIVE S. B.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN THE CURRENT
VOTE IS- FOUR TO THREE WHICH
ONE OKAY. THE ITEM FIVE FIVE S.
B. FOR SIXTY SEVEN. WIENER
HERTZBERG HUESO. OKAY OKAY THAT
ONLY HAS FOUR VOTES THAT BILL
FAILS AND WE WILL NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION. SO- WE HAVE TO
HOPE FOR SOME OF THE OTHERS TO
COME BACK ARE THERE ANY THAT
ARE JUST MISSING ANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE ROOM
RIGHT NOW. YEAH WE WEEK WE CAN
RUN THROUGH IT SENATE RACES
MISSING ON A COUPLE OF THEM
MORE THAN ONE ENTERED JUST
START WITH ITEM TOO AND WHAT'S
RUN THROUGH THEM AND- AND THEN
WE CAN SEE IF OTHER PEOPLE GET
HERE IN TIME. BYLER HERE
SENATOR GROWING. FILE ITEM TO
SB FORTY SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ONE. JONES JON SNOW
ALLEN HUESO. OKAY THAT HAS SIX
ONE A BACKER- SIX ONE BACK WHEN
CALLED UPON COULD NOT CONFIRM.
OF ITEM THREE YOU CALL STERN ON
THAT ONE YES I HAVE STE YOUR
YOUR ON THAT ONE OKAY AND THEN
ITEM NUMBER THREE FILE ITEM
THREE SB FOUR OH SIX THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FOUR ZERO-
JONES BY JONES I ALLEN GROVE.
HUESO HUESO ON A LOAN. I'M
SORRY OF ITEM OR- SIX S. B.
FOR- OH SIX. TRANSACTION OF THE
AYE THAT'S TO NOT VOTE TRY OKAY
THAT'S NOT. FILE ITEM WHAT'S
THE TOTAL VOTE BEFORE WE PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL. SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO. FILE ITEM FOR S. B. FOR
NINETEEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO TWO ALLEN. HUESO HUESO
HI THAT IS SIX FIVE WE ALREADY
CLOSED OUT FIVE ITEM SIX- WELL
IN THE SIX SB EIGHT OH FOR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
LAYERED HI THERE ALL RIGHT
ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN ONLINE.
LIMóN STERN AYE STERN ALRIGHT.
THOSE AT SEVEN VOTE SETS SEVEN.
SB FILE ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE FIVE
TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN RA
GROWS GROVE HI LIMóN STERN AYE
STERN HI. THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM NINE THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE THAT'S THE CONSENT
AGENDA SAID ITEM JONES. IT'S A
CONSENT AGENDA ALL ACTION THAT
ALLEN. THE RESULT IN SENATE
GENDA. OKAY OKAY SO THAT IS-
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT EIGHT- JUST
CONSIDER HUESO LEFT WITH SO.
WORLD JUST CLOSE THAT AT EIGHT
FOUR STATE STREET PASS OKAY-
RUN THROUGH THIS ONE MORE TIME-
OF- FILE ITEM TWO SB FORTY
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTERS ONE
TWO FIVE TWO ALLEN. ALLEN ALL
RIGHT HUESO. FILE THAT HAS-
THIS TWO AND- SENATOR HUESO IS
NOT PUTTING ANY LAUGHED.
THERE'S NO WAY TO GET SENATOR
HUESO BACK HERE HE HE HE WAS
NOT VOTING ON THAT BILL- OKAY-
FILE ITEMS THREE SB FOUR OH SIX
THE CURRENT VOTERS. SIX ZERO
ALLEN. ALLEN ARAMBULA GROWS.
WAS NOT ROOTING LIMóN. HE'S
NOT HERE HE SAID SHE SAID-
SERVICE. SEVEN ONE OKAY. FILE
ITEM FOR S. B. FOR NINETEEN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. SIX TWO ALLEN.
SEVEN TWO OKAY WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THAT ONE THAT LED TO
EVERYBODY VOTING THAT OUT
SEVENTY TWO. DISPOSED OF THAT
FILE ITEM SIX S. B. EIGHT OH
FOR THE CURRENT VOTERS. SEVEN
ZERO ALLEN HI ALLEN ALL RIGHT
LU<c.cyan>. THAT'S EIGHT ZERO- AND</c>
THEN FILE ITEM SEVEN SP FIVE
FIVE TO THE CURRENT ROAD IS ONE.
SEVEN ZERO ALLEN. ALLEN HI
LIMóN. WE HAVE EIGHT VOTES AND
THEN LET ME DO A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING THINGS HERE- THERE
ARE TWO BILLS THAT WE DID NOT
GET TO TODAY. WE DID NOT GET TO
SENATOR WAY SAYS BILL FILE ITEM
EIGHT AND SENATOR STERN'S BILL
FILE ITEM TEN THE COMMITTEE
WILL SEEK RULE WAIVERS AND TRY
TO TAKE THOSE UP AT THE
THURSDAY HEARING. SO WITH THAT
AS A TEMP AND JUST ONE QUESTION
THE STAFF BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
SHUT THIS DOWN IN A COUPLE
MINUTES. WERE MISSING ONE OR
TWO VOTERS ON SOME OF THESE
THAT DOESN'T AFFECT THE ABILITY
FOR THEM TO GO ON CONSENT IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE OTHERWISE RUN PLEASE
SO. OKAY GREAT THEN. BAKER ARE
WILL FORMALLY CLOSED THE ROLE
ON PAUL THE OPEN ONCE. AND. BUT
IN EXCEPT FOR ITEM FIVE. EVERY
SINGLE ONE GOT OUT WITH THAT
TWEET. PRIORITY NOTED WHEN IT
HAVE WE'RE DONE WITH THAT OKAY
ANY OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE I DON'T THINK SO THEN
ARE WE WILL STAND ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY.